I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO GET
STARTED I KNOW IF GOING TO HAVE.
SOME COLLEAGUES JOINING US.
BUT THIS WHEN I LOOK AT OUR
AMAZING AGENDA.
REALIZE THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL
OF BEING A VERY LONG HEARING.
IS WE HAVE A LOT TO GO OVER.
SO WELCOME MY NAME IS MARK STONE
I'M CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
AND THIS IS A HEARING THAT'S
BEEN A LONG TIME IN PROCESS AND
HOPEFULLY.
GENERATING SOME [inaudible]
INTEREST.
TALKING ABOUT DIVERSITY AND THE
TOPIC FIRST CAME WITH THE
DISCUSSION AROUND DIVERSITY ON
THE BENCH.
DAD AND I THINK OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS WE'VE SEEN SOME
IMPROVEMENT.
AT ESPECIALLY WE HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE TO BRING COURT RIGHT NOW.
BUT IN LOOKING UP AND DOWN THE
RANKS OF JUDGES ACROSS STATE
MANY OF WHOM HAVE BEEN APPOINTED
OVER THE LAST DECADES IN SOME
QUITE SOMETIME AGO.
I THINK WOULD REALLY
[inaudible]
HAD.
AS FOR THE CLEAR.
NOTION THAT WE HAVE SOME WORK TO
DO WITH THE JUDICIARY BUT THAT
RAISE QUESTIONS BECAUSE THE BAR
IS OBVIOUSLY A PATH TO THE
JUDICIARY ADD WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE BAR.
WE ALSO REALIZE THAT WE HAVE
SOME STRUGGLES WITH DIVERSITY
AND LAW FIRMS IN THE PROFESSION
AND I THINK THE PROFESSION IN
ORDER TO BE.
TRULY RECOGNIZED AS BENEFICIAL
TO CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO LOOK LIKE
CALIFORNIA DOES.
AND I'VE LOOKS BY ALL THE DATA
THAT WE'VE COLLECTED IN THE DATA
WE'RE GONNA SEE TODAY WERE A
LONG WAY FROM THAT.
WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY IN
THE BAR WITHOUT TALK ABOUT
DIVERSITY AT LAW SCHOOLS AND
PIPELINE OF GETTING STUDENTS.
THROUGH THE EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
INTO LAW SCHOOLS AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
THAT THAT REPRESENTS.
WAS LEGISLATURE'S WORKING HARD
TO TRY AND MAKE SURE WE ARE.
EDUCATING ALL STUDENTS BUT GIVEN
SOCIOECONOMIC FACTORS GIVEN
OTHER FACTORS RACIAL FACTORS WE
KNOW THAT THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT EQUAL IN IS
NOT EQUITABLE WHICH MEANS.
THAT PROFESSIONS ARE ALSO NOT
GOING TO HAVE OFFER THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY AS EVERYONE ELSE.
WE'RE ALSO GONNA BE DISK
EXPLORING.
OR TOUCHING ON A NUMBER OF
NOTIONS AND POTENTIAL
IMPEDIMENTS TO DIVERSITY IN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION THINGS LIKE THE
BAR CUT SCORE.
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS NO
RECIPROCITY WITH OTHER STATES WE
HAVE BECOME IN A WAY A BIT OF AN
ISLAND ON OUR OWN THROUGH
HISTORICAL REASONS.
BUT I I THINK I HOPE THAT
THROUGH THIS DISCUSSION AND
OTHER DISCUSSIONS TO COME THIS
IS SUCH A BROAD TOPIC AT THIS
POINT.
LET IT SERVICES.
MORE OF AN INTRODUCTION TO THE
ISSUES TO THE CHALLENGES -- A
STATEMENT IF YOU WELL AND
HOPEFULLY A GAUNTLET LAY DOWN.
FOR ALL OF US TO TAKE OUR PART
RESPONSIBLY FOR OUR PARTS OF
ENSURING THAT WE ARE LOOKING
ACROSS THE LEGAL PROFESSION FROM.
THOSE IN SCHOOL NOW WHO WOULD
SEEK TO BECOME ATTORNEYS TO
THOSE WHO ARE ALL THE WAY UP
BEING APPOINTED TO THE SUPREME
COURT IN CALIFORNIA AND EVERYONE
IN BETWEEN THAT WE ARE ALL
TAKING OUR PART.
IN ENSURING THAT WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT LOOKING AT AND ASK
OURSELVES THE QUESTION HOW CAN
WE BEST ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
MOST DIVERSE BAR THE MOST
REPRESENTATIVE BAR AND BENCH.
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIANS AND THAT
MEANS THERE SHOULD BE NO ISSUES
THAT WE ARE UNWILLING TO LOOK AT
THESE THERE SHOULD BE NO ISSUES.
THAT WE ARE UNWILLING TO TACKLE
IN THAT QUEST I THINK THAT'S
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA AND GOOD.
FOR THE THE LEGAL PROFESSION AS
A WHOLE.
SO WE HAVE QUITE A FEW PEOPLE
THAT THE THE LIST ON THE AGENDA
STARTED TO GET BIGGER AND BIGGER
AS WE REALIZE THERE WERE MORE
AND MORE QUESTIONS.
WE NEEDED TO ASK [inaudible]
AND INFORMATION AND EVEN
QUESTIONS TO PUT ON THE TABLE SO
I FORESEE SEVERAL.
OPPORTUNITIES OVER THE COMING
YEARS TO BE TALKING ABOUT THAT
AS WELL HOPEFULLY SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER.
AND I'M ASSUMING WE'RE GOING TO
BE RAISING A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
THAT.
GIVE US BETTER DIRECTION THE
LEGISLATURE THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO BE
DOING A BETTER JOB WITH RESPECT
SO WE'RE ASKING THAT SPEAKERS BE
ABOUT SEVEN MINUTES OR SO I KNOW
THAT THESE ARE JUDGES AND
LAWYERS.
ADD.
THE WORST PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
AND I SPEAK FOR MYSELF TO ASK TO
BE BRIEF.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
COVERING ALL OF THE GROUND
ANSWERING ALL OF THE QUESTIONS
OBVIOUSLY IN THIS HEARING. TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF THE TIME OF THOSE
ESPECIALLY ON THE PANELS.
AFTER YOUR PANELS.
IT'S I WILL TRY AND MAINTAIN
SOME TIME BUT I WILL TELL YOU A
VERY INTERESTED IN THIS TOPIC
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GIVE EVERYBODY THE CHANCE TO
TALK.
BUT THEN ALSO THE ELEMENT OPEN
THIS UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE'VE
GOT IT ALL SIGN UP LIST GOING.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SIGN UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU HAVEN'T
SIGNED UP ON THAT LIST THAT WILL
NOT PRECLUDE YOU FROM MAKING A
PUBLIC COMMENT.
BUT DEPENDING ON WHEN THAT
STARTS THOSE MIGHT BE LIMITED TO
FAIRLY SHORT STATEMENTS.
WHICH I HATE TO DO BECAUSE
GETTING PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT AT
ALL THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY
CRITICAL AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY.
EIGHT IN AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THE SOMEBODY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BUT WE HAVE ALSO ASKED
THE LEGISLATURE HAS A NUMBER OF
ETHNIC CAUCUSES.
THAT WE'VE INVITED TO JOIN US
AND THE OUR IS A BIT EARLY I
SUPPOSE.
BUT THAT WE HAVE INVITED AT A
NUMBER OF LEGISLATORS TO COME TO
THE DIS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO HELP US WITH THIS.
BECAUSE THE VARIOUS CAUCUSES THE
API CAUCUS THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS LATINO CAUCUS.
HAVE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
INSURING.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS VERY
COGNIZANT OF DECISIONS THAT WE
MAKE WITH RESPECT TO RACE AND A
SPECIAL. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND
STRUGGLING WITH AND HAS BEEN
GETTING GREAT GUIDANCE FROM THE
GLBT CAUCUS.
BECAUSE LET'S SAY WE HAVE NOT
ALWAYS BEEN SENSITIVE TO THE
THAT BRETT OF PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE TRYING TO BE.
MUCH BETTER ABOUT IT AND AS WE
HAVE NOW MORE AND MORE.
PEOPLE OUT OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
EDUCATING US AS WE DO POLICY.
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLEAN UP ALL STATUTES TO TAKE
OFFENSIVE LANGUAGE OUT AND AND
MODERNIZE WHAT WE'RE DOING SO
THAT'S A CAUCUS THAT REPRESENTS
A VERY IMPORTANT PART.
OF OUR DISCUSSION AS WELL.
SO.
THIS REYES WELCOME.
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS I WILL WARN YOU THAT
LEGISLATORS WE'RE IN A VERY BUSY
TIME WERE COMING UP WITH A HOUSE
OR TO DEADLINE.
THE BIG APPROPRIATIONS HEARING
IS ON THURSDAY TO LEGISLATORS
ARE BEING PULLED IN MANY MANY
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS THIS IS
BEING RECORDED.
SO EVERYONE WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
IT TO PLEASE DO NOT BE OFFENDED
OF LEGISLATORS ARE COMING AND
GOING AS THEIR SCHEDULES DICTATE
AS WE ARE TRYING TO MANAGE
POLICY THAT WE HAVE.
ACROSS THE BOARD IT'S JUST A
FEATURE OF HEARINGS THAT WE HAVE
EVEN POLICY HEARINGS LEGISLATORS
HAVE TO COME AGO BECAUSE OF
OTHER POLICY HEARINGS THAT
THEY'RE IN.
SO WE'RE BEING.
YANKED VARIOUS WAYS SO -- DON'T
DON'T TAKE ANY OFFENSE TO THAT
THAT'S JUST THE NATURE OF THE
BUSINESS.
ALL RIGHT I LIKE TO CALL THE
FIRST PANEL.
WHICH IS GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
THE IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSITY IN
THE LEGAL PROFESSION IN THE
COURTS THIS IS AN INTRODUCTORY
PANEL.
CHARACTERS RAZA WHO'S A LAW
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW
COME ON FORWARD. TO THE TO THE
PANEL ERIC HARRIS LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
AB RICK'S BIRTH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
IS RICK HERE YET I DIDN'T SEE
HIM EARLIER.
AND JUDGE ELIZABETH MISIA'S
ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT --
HERSELF HAS OVERCOME
[inaudible]
DIVERSITY AND TAKES IT VERY
SERIOUSLY GIVING BACK.
SO WE ARE JUST OF THE STARTING
MISTER TO AS THE CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER CAUCUS
I'D LIKE TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE SOME OPENING REMARKS OF
YOUR OKAY WAS SETTLING WE WILL
WORK ON THAT.
A LITTLE BIT LATER.
ALL RIGHT SO [inaudible]
JAVA [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
MY NAME IS GOT A BILL THAT I
SENT HIM A RISING THREE L. AT UC
DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW.
I GREW UP IN THE VERDANT FIELDS
OF SALINAS CALIFORNIA AND YOUR
MYERS ANA.
I HAD TO HOMES GROWING UP.
ROWS AND ROWS OF LETTUCE
BROCCOLI ANDSTRAWBERRIES
COVERED MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND
PESTICIDES FILLED MY CHALDEAN
LITTLE CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE
ONLY IF YOU'RE GETTING RECORDED
THANK YOU.
WHEN I WAS YOUNG EVERY YEAR
AROUND NOVEMBER MY FAMILY AND I
PACKED ALL OUR BELONGINGS INTO
BOXES AND CRATES? TO DRIVE DOWN
TO THE LETTERS HARVEST OF
SOUTHERN ARIZONA.
WE WERE MIGRANT FARM WORKERS.
I REMEMBER IT CLEARLY AS IF IT
WERE YESTERDAY.
WE PACKED TWO DISHES OLD POTS
AND CLOTHES AN EMPTY TNA BOXES
MY FAMILY AND I ALL NEW THAT
COME EARLY NOVEMBER.
WE WOULD START PACKING OUR
THINGS TO DRIVE DOWN TO ARIZONA
AND IN MAY DRIVE BACK UP NORTH.
WE DID THIS FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
AND IT WAS THE BEST PART OF MY
LIFE.
IT CREATED A TYPE OF BOND WITH
MY FAMILY THAT COULD NEVER BE
BROKEN.
THOUGH THERE WAS LOVE AND JOY IN
THESE BEAUTIFUL FOURTEEN YEARS
OF MY LIFE.
I ALSO MISSED OUT ON A LOT OF
EDUCATION AS A RESULT OF THE NAY
UNSTABLE NATURE OF MIGRATING.
THIS WAS BECAUSE WHEN WE ARRIVED
WE OFTEN DIDN'T HAVE A PLACE TO
STAY.
MY NEAR MY WHOLE FAMILY STAYED
IN MY UNCLE'S LIVING ROOM IN HIS
GREEN TRAILER.
THE NEXT YEAR.
WE COULD BUY A TRAILER AND THE
YEAR AFTER THAT.
WE COULD AFFORD AN APARTMENT.
I NEVER KNOW IF I WAS GOING TO
HAVE A ROOM OF MY OWN OR A PLACE
TO STUDY.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN SELFISH
DIVIDED.
I NEVER KNEW HOW FAR I WAS GOING
TO BE FROM SCHOOL IF I HAD TO
WALK OR TAKE THE BUS.
BUT I KNEW THAT MY OLDER SISTER
AND MY MOM AND I WOULD GET THEIR
AFTER BEING ENROLLED IN SCHOOL
OVER IN ARIZONA FOR SIX OR FIVE
MONTHS.
IT WOULD BE TIME TO MOVE BACK TO
SALINAS.
MY SISTER AND I WOULD AND FORMER
TEACHERS PACKER THINGS THEIR
GOODBYES AND DRIVE DOWN TO
HIGHWAY EIGHT BACK TO SALINAS.
IT WAS A CYCLE THAT TO THIS DAY
MY BODY FEELS EVERY WINTER AND
EVERY SPRING.
AT AROUND THE FOURTH GRADE I
REALIZE THAT I DIDN'T KNOW HOW
TO READ WELL.
I HAD LOW GRADES WAS TERRIBLE AT
MATH AND AS A RESULT OF
MIGRATING AND THE EDUCATIONAL
INCONSISTENCIES I GOT BEHIND ON
MY MAJOR SUBJECTS.
IT WAS THE MIGRANT PROGRAM THE
BILINGUAL PROGRAM AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND MY MOM THAT
GOT ME THROUGH MY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL EDUCATION.
FAST FORWARD TO MY SOPHOMORE
YEAR IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I KNOW I WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND I LEARNED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH THE GIRLS
INC PROGRAM.
GIRLS THINK EMPOWERED MANY OF US
YOUNG LATINO WOMEN IN MANY WAYS.
THEY DID WORKSHOPS FIRST TO
LEARN ABOUT DIFFERENT CAREERS
THEY BROUGHT AN ATTORNEY WHO
SPOKE TO US ABOUT PUBLIC
INTEREST WORK.
AND THEY TOOK US TO DIFFERENT
UNIVERSITIES.
UC DAVIS INCLUDED.
THE MENTORS OF GIRLS AND TAUGHT
US ABOUT SELF CARE SELF.
OF GOAL SETTING AND SELF GROWTH
EVENTUALLY I GRADUATED FROM
NORTH SALINAS HIGH SCHOOL IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN I WAS ACCEPTED
INTO ST MARY'S COLLEGE OF
CALIFORNIA.
EVEN THOUGH I EXCELLED IN
COLLEGE IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE I FUNDED MY WAY THROUGH
IT ON MY OWN.
CORRECT THREE OR TWO JOBS EVERY
SEMESTER TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
I WORKED AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
SAID AT ADMINISTRATIVE SECRETARY.
BABYSITTER TRANSLATOR ZOOM BUT
TEACHER AND POLICY CONSULTANT.
THAT'S HOW I COULD AFFORD TO PAY
RENT.
IN BETWEEN JOBS I WENT TO CLASS
AND THE WRITING CENTER.
I NEVER KNEW A PRIVATE TUTOR BUT
I USE THE RESOURCES ON CAMPUS AS
BEST AS I COULD.
I CONSTANTLY APPLIED FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS SO THAT MY PARENTS
WOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT.
ME AND COULD SUPPORT MY TWO
YOUNGER SISTERS.
BUT THERE IS ALSO ANOTHER VERY
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT PERSON IN MY
ST MARY'S COLLEGE CAREER.
IT WAS MY PROFESSOR MYRNA
SANTIAGO WHO WAS THE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE HISTORY PROGRAM
SHE WAS MY MENTOR TOOK ME UNDER
MY TOOK ME UNDER HER WING.
AND TAUGHT ME HOW TO WRITE WELL.
THE MOST DIFFICULT PART OF GOING
TO COLLEGE WAS PROBABLY
TRANSITIONING TO AND FROM
BECAUSE I WAS AND I WAS THE
FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE AND GRADUATE FROM IT.
NO ONE IN MY FAMILY HAD
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
UNITED STATES SO THERE WAS NO
ONE I COULD REACH OUT.
TO BUT THERE WAS.
BUT THERE WAS ALWAYS MY PARENTS
WERE WILLING TO SUPPORT ME.
AND THEN I A ALSO REACHED OUT TO
PROFESSOR MANA SANTIAGO TO TALK
ABOUT TAKING THE L. SAT.
SHE RECOMMENDED A PROGRAM.
THAT WAS CALLED THE KING CALL
OUT REACH PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF LAW [inaudible]
THIS PROGRAM.
WAS A PERFECT PROGRAM FOR ME
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO LEARN
ABOUT THE REQUIREMENTS TAKING
THEY ALL SAT.
AND HOW TO GET INTO LAW SCHOOL.
I KNEW THAT I WANTED TO GO INTO
LAW SCHOOL BECAUSE I HAD SEEN A
LOT OF THE INEQUALITIES THAT MY
PARENTS FACED WHILE THEY WERE
FARMWORKERS.
I I KNEW THAT.
THEY WERE WORKING LOW INCOME
JOBS WITH NO BENEFITS AND I
WANTED TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
THEM AND FOR OTHER FARMWORKERS.
TODAY I AM AMONG THE MINORITY OF
LATINOS WHO MADE IT INTO LAW
SCHOOL.
SO FAR MY LEGAL CAREER I HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE WORKERS
RIGHTS CLINIC THE IMMIGRATION
CLINIC AND CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
IN THOSE POSITIONS I HAVE
PROVIDED LEGAL COUNSEL TO
MONOLINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKERS OR
FOLKS WERE LOW INCOME.
I'VE PROVIDED LEGAL SERVICES TO
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND WOODLAND.
LOW INCOME AN INDIGENT FOLKS IN
SACRAMENTO AND WILL ONE DAY
RETURN TO THE SALINAS VALLEY. TO
DO THE SAME WORK.
I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE MADE THE RIGHT DECISIONS
AND ENDED UP WHERE I AM TODAY
BUT NOT EVERYONE RECEIVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES AS ME.
URGE YOU TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS THAT INCREASE DIVERSITY
IN THE LEGAL PROFESSION BECAUSE
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE LIKE ME
WHO WANT TO GIVE BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
PROGRAMS LIKE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WRITING WORKSHOPS
READING PROGRAMS AND THE ARTS
HELP STUDENTS EXPRESS THEMSELVES
AND FIND PASSIONS LIKE THEY DID
FOR ME.
I ALSO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT MORE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS THE THAT
WILL EMPOWER FAMILIES TO DEAL
WITH THE STRESS AN
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA.
SO THAT STUDENTS CAN THRIVE IN
THEIR CAREERS AND FAMILIES CAN
HEAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK WHAT WE'LL DO
IS GO TO THE PANEL AND THEN OPEN
UP FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER HARRIS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
OPENING THE DOOR FOR THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY TO BE IN
THIS FROM TODAY.
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS I'M A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
DRC IS THE CALIFORNIA PROTECTION
AND ADVOCACY AGENCY FOR THE
STATE AND THE LARGEST DISABILITY
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN THE
NATION.
WE ASSIST THOUSANDS ANNUAL
ANNUALLY AND A MYRIAD OF
DISABILITY RELATED ISSUES
INCLUDING EDUCATION.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH CARE CIVIL
RIGHTS HOUSING IMMIGRATION.
AND ACCESSIBILITY THROUGH
MULTIPLE AVENUES SUCH AS IT
INDIVIDUAL REPRESENTATION
LITIGATION AND LEGISLATION.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE
REPRESENTED IN LAW SCHOOLS IN
THE BAR AND ON THE BENCH.
BECAUSE OUR EXPERIENCE AND POINT
OF VIEW MATTER.
ACCORDING TO THE US CENSUS
BUREAU ABOUT 19% OF THE
POPULATION HAD A DISABILITY IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THERE ARE THREE MAIN ISSUES
INVOLVING DISABILITYDIVERSITY
IN THE LAW.
FIRST WE HAVE A PIPELINE PROBLEM.
WHERE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE LESS LIKELY TO
APPLY AND BE ADMITTED TO LAW
SCHOOL?
ONLY TWELVE POINT 3% OF WORKING
AGE PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
HELD A BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR
HIGHER.
COMPARED TO THIRTY POINT 6% OF
NON DISABLED PERSONS.
SECOND THERE IS ALSO A STRONG
DISABILITY POVERTY CORRELATION.
MANY INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE NOT ABLE TO
FINANCE LAW SCHOOL AT ALL.
THIRD THE NUMBER OF LAWYERS WITH
DISABILITIES IT'S HARD TO
DETERMINE.
UNLIKE RACE GENDER ETHNICITY AND
MORE RECENTLY SEXUAL ORIENTATION
THERE IS LITTLE REPORTING ON
DISABILITY STATISTICS.
PAST ABA PRESIDENT WILLIAM
NEUKOM STATED IN HIS PRESIDENT'S
MESSAGE THAT ALTHOUGH IT IS
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE THE EXACT
DEGREE.
THAT THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY IS
UNDER REPRESENTED IN THE LEGAL
COMMUNITY IT IS EVIDENT THAT
LAWYERS WITH DISABILITIES.
TO HAVE GREATER DIFFICULTY
GETTING A JOB AFTER LAW SCHOOL.
AND HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT THE LAWYERS WHO DO
NOT HAVE DISABILITIES.
MANY LAWYERS WITH DISABILITIES
STILL END UP WHERE THEY ALWAYS
HAVE.
CHANNEL TOWARD GOVERNMENT WORK
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS OR SOLO
IN SMALL FIRM EMPLOYMENT.
OFTEN WITH DISABILITY RELATED
PRACTICES.
OLD ATTITUDES AND PERCEPTIONS OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
BEEN SLOW TO CHANGE.
ADDITIONALLY.
DEAR SEE ADVOCATES FOR
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT THE BENCH CAN BE BETTER
REFLECTIVE OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
WELL THERE HAS BEEN IMPROVEMENT
AND ETHNIC AND OTHER DIVERSITY
GROUPS THAT IS NOT TRUE OF
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES.
THERE ARE THIRTEEN TOTAL JUDGES
OR 2% OF CALIFORNIAN JUDGES WHO
HAVE IDENTIFIED WITH HAVING A
DISABILITY.
LAWYERS AND JUDGES ARE CHANGE
AGENTS FOR ENTIRE COMMUNITIES.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES BRING A
PERSPECTIVE AN OUTLOOK THAT IS
UNIQUE AND IMPORTANT.
THEY CAN ALSO ENHANCE THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THROUGH OTHERS AND HELP WORK
THROUGH THE PIPELINE OF LAW
SCHOOL THE BAR EXAM.
THE LEGAL PROFESSION AND THE
JUDICIARY.
MY EXPERIENCE I AM RARE.
MY LAW SCHOOL HAD APPROXIMATELY
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
I WAS THE ONLY INDIVIDUAL WHO
USED TO WILSHIRE AT THAT LAW
SCHOOL.
LAW SCHOOL AS WE ALL KNOW IS
CHALLENGING ON ITS OWN.
READING AND ANALYZING CASES
DOESN'T EXACTLY COME NATURALLY.
I ALSO HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
ADDED STRESS OR BURDEN OF BEING
THE DISABLED REPRESENTATIVE OR
PERSON WITH EIGHTY A PERSPECTIVE.
I DID NOT HAVE COLLEAGUES THAT I
COULD SHARE THAT EXPERIENCE WITH.
IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH LAW SCHOOL
WITHOUT OTHER STUDENTS AND
FACULTY WHO HAD SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES AS ME.
ADDING TO MY OBSTACLE COURSE
THAT IS DISABILITY I AM AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE.
THE INTERSECTION ALLEY OF
DISABILITY AND RACE CAN ADD EVEN
MORE CHALLENGES.
THE SPACE WAS DIFFICULT TO
UNDERGO WHILE I WAS IN LAW
SCHOOL.
I MOSTLY HAD TO STAY CONNECTED
WITH MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
IT WAS A REAL CHALLENGE. TO MAKE
MYSELF FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
WHILE IN LAW SCHOOL.
AS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE WITH
A DISABILITY I HAVE LEARNED HOW
TO MAKE DISCOMFORT ACTUALLY
COMFORTABLE FOR ME.
HOWEVER WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW THE
NEXT SET OF LAW STUDENTS OF
COLOR WITH DISABILITIES TO HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE SAME THING
THAT I WENT THROUGH.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD TREAT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AS IF WE ARE
IMPORTANT.
WE HOPE THE STATE.
WILL BE AS WELCOMING AND
UNDERSTANDING OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AS IT CAN AND
CONSIDER THINKING OUTSIDE THE
BOX.
AT THE R. C. WE SEEK TO ADDRESS
ONGOING BY SEIZE FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
BOTH VISIBLE AND INVISIBLE.
WITH THE SPECIFIC GOAL OF
BROADER INCLUSION IN COMMUNITIES
BOTH PROFESSIONALLY AND
PERSONALLY.
THE LEGAL PROFESSION HAS A LONG
WAY TO GO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS A BURKE THANK YOU I KNOW
YOUR FLIGHT WAS DELAYED IT WAS
SO WHICH IS TOP GETTING UP HERE.
TO START MY DADDY'S YES EXCUSE
YOU ARE THANK YOU GOOD MORNING --
MY NAME IS RICK SERVER -- AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA THE NATION'S
LARGEST STATEWIDE LGBT CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION -- I'M ALSO
A LAWYER AND PRIOR TO BECOMING A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR I PRACTICE LAW FROM WAS
TWENTY NINE YEARS AT LAKE MEN
WALK INS.
LLP NOW THAN LATE NATION'S
LARGEST US BASED LAW FIRM --
WHEN I BEGAN MY PRACTICE AT LATE
THEM IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THERE WERE VERY FEW OUT LGBT Q.
LAWYERS AT MAJOR FIRMS ANYWHERE
IN THE COUNTRY?
AND THEY WERE NOT AT LAKE THEM.
WHEN I CAME OUT THE FIRM IN
NINETEEN NINETY AS A FIFTY YEAR
ASSOCIATES I BECAME THE FIRST
OUT LAWYER IN THE FIRM AND WHEN
I WAS ELECTED TO THE PARTNERSHIP
IN?
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE FIRM'S
FIRST OPENLY GAY OPENLY LGBT Q.
PARTNER.
I REMEMBER THAT WHEN I CAME OUT
IT WAS SORT OF A BIG DEAL AND
ALTHOUGH THERE WERE.
OTHER LGBT KILLERS IN THE FIRM
WHO WERE NOT OUT OF PARTNERS AND
ASSOCIATES.
NONE WERE OUT BECAUSE OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT SOCIAL STIGMA THAT
WAS SO PRESENT AT THAT TIME AND
THE RISK OF BEING OUT HARMING
THEIR CAREER -- TO LIKE THEM IS
CREDITED REMEMBER MY DEPARTMENT
HAD CALLING ME INTO HER OFFICE
THE DAY AFTER -- IT BECAME CLEAR
I WAS OUT BECAUSE I DID A
FUNDRAISER FOR BARBARA BOXER AND
WAS IN THE PAPER.
AND THAT'S HOW I SORT OF CAME
OUT -- AND SHE BASICALLY COMIC
OFFICE AND SAID THAT YOU KNOW
SHE WAS PROUD OF ME AND THAT IT
WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON MY
CAREER AND LUCKILY IT DIDN'T --
BUT AS THE OTHER LGBT ASSOCIATES
AT THE FIRM.
YOU KNOW WAITED OVER THOSE
COUPLE YEARS -- NOT COMING OUT
AND WANTED TO SORT OF TO LOOK AT
WHAT THE FIRM I DO -- WITH MY
NEW REVELATION -- THEY BECAME
COMMAND AFTER ACCOUNT FOR
PARTNER AND YOU KNOW -- TO ITS
CREDIT -- I AND OTHERS WORKED
WITH LATE THEM AND NOW DO THEY
LIKE IT HAS HUNDREDS OF LGBT Q.
LAWYERS.
A ROBUST AFFINITY GROUP AND THE
FIRM IS OUR LOW LOW QUALITY
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST PROVIDE A
PARTNER HAVING CONTRIBUTED TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
LEGAL SERVICES IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
ON ONE OF THE TRENCH INTO
MILITARY CASES WHERE THE
REPRESENTING US -- I SALE OF
THAT IT'S THE PREDICATE TO JUST --
EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT --
REPRESENTATION IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AS BOTH FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF PROVIDING ROLE
MODELS AND ALSO FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF HELPING TO
EDUCATE.
HEARTS AND MINDS WITHIN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION AND WITHIN THE
WORK PLACES IN WHICH WE ALL WORK.
OUR MISSION AT A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
IS TO BRING THE VOICES OF LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND OUR ALLIES THE
INSTITUTIONS OF POWER. TO CREATE
A WORLD THAT'S HEALTHY JUSTIN
FULLY EQUAL FOR ALL LGBT Q.
PEOPLE.
A KEY OBJECTIVE OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IS TO ADDRESS
THE SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
THE LGBT Q. PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
COMPETE TO THE REST OF THE
PUBLIC AND LGBT PEOPLE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL
COMPARED TO THE REST THE PUBLIC
MORE LIKELY TO BE LIVING AND
POVERTY MORE LIKELY TO BE.
ARRESTED MORE LIKELY BE
CONVICTED ON A REST AND IF THAT
AND LGBT Q. PERSON IS ALSO A
MEMBER OF A COMMITTEE OF COLOR
AND IMMIGRANT A PERSON LIVING
WITH HIV.
THERE THEY FARE EVEN WORSE ON
ALL OF THOSE STATISTICS -- SO IN
ADDITION TO PASSING LAWS
ACHIEVING FULL OF THE QUALITY
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY REQUIRES THAT WE FOCUS
ON THE INSTITUTIONS OF POWER AND
THAT'S WHY.
IT'S IN OUR MISSION AND AND THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT SERVE THE
BROADER PUBLIC OFTEN OF WHICH
LACK THE CULTURAL COMPETENCY TO
SERVE LGBT Q. PEOPLE.
AND WHICH SOMETIMES ARE OUTRIGHT
HOSTILE TO OUR COMMUNITY THE
LEGAL PROFESSION THE JUDICIARY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE
AMONG THE KEY INSTITUTIONS THAT
WERE FOCUSED ON THAT'S WHY
QUALITY CALIFORNIA SPONSORED A.
B. EIGHTY SEVEN AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE -- TO HAVE
A DISCRIMINATION AGAINST LGBT Q.
PEOPLE IN JURY CALIFORNIA JURIES
AB TWENTY FIVE OH FOUR AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER EVAN LOW WHICH REQUIRED
LGBT Q. CULTURAL KANSI TRAINING
FOR CALIFORNIA OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY THREE AUTHORED.
BY THEN -- DOUBTS SENATOR
SHIRLEY WEBER WHICH ADDRESS
RACIAL IDENTITY AND LGBT Q.
POLICE PROFILING.
OUR LEADERSHIP PROGRAMS ARE
SIMILARLY AIMED AT PREPARING
LGBT Q. PEOPLE FOR GOVERNMENT
SERVICE THE WILLIAMS INSTITUTE
STUDY SHOWED THAT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THAT THE RAW ELEVEN OUT
OF TWO THOUSAND OR SO --
APPOINTED PEOPLE ENDS CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT.
INDEED IT DOES YOU ARE SIMPLY
UNDER REPRESENTED THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AND WITHIN THE
JUDICIARY IT'S REALLY HARD TO
ESTIMATE THAN THAT WHAT THAT
UNDER REPRESENTATION IS BECAUSE
NO ONE CANCERS.
WERE NOT COUNTED IN THE CENSUS
PRESIDENT TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
DECIDED NOT TO INCLUDE
ACCOUNTABILITY TO KEEP PEOPLE
THE TWENTY TEN A CENSUS -- BUT
THE WILLIAMS INSTITUTE IS
ESTIMATED THAT ARE -- THAT WE
ARE 45% OF THE POPULATION WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S ABOUT DOUBLE --
BASED UPON THE SOCIAL STIGMA AND
AND UNDER REPORTING BY MEMBERS
OUR COMMUNITY AND INDEED A POLL
THAT WE COMMISSIONED -- QUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN A REPORTED THAT 12% OF
CALIFORNIA REGISTERED VOTERS
DONE BY TOLCHIN RESEARCH
IDENTIFIES MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY SO.
THE YARDSTICKS ARE SOMEPLACE
BETWEEN FIVE AND PROBABLY 10% AS
REALLY THE YARDSTICKS GIVEN
THOSE WE KNOW THAT LGBT PEOPLE
ARE STILL SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER
REPRESENTED THE LEGAL PROFESSION
BASED ON THE VERY LIMITED
INFORMATION -- THAT WE HAVE
ALTHOUGH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BAR BEGAN -- TO COLLECT ONLY IN
NINETEEN TWENTY NINETEEN THIS
YEAR.
WHAT WE CALL SAID YOU DATA
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY DATA?
AS PART OF A VOLUNTARY SURVEY
THE MOST RECENT FACT SHEET
PRODUCED BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BAR ON ADVANCING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION.
CONCLUDES THAT CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS ARE LESS DIVERSE THAN
THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND WHILE THE
FACT SHEET APPROPRIATE INCLUDES
INFORMATION ON GENDER AND RACE
IT SHOCKINGLY PROVIDES NO
INFORMATION.
ABOUT DISABILITY OR YOU ARE SO
G. DATA -- THERE ARE SEVERAL
NATIONAL SOURCES THAT HAVE
REPORTING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LGBT COMMUNITY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF LEGAL PLACEMENT.
TRACKS THE PERCENTAGE OF LGBT Q.
LAWYERS IN LARGE LEGAL EMPLOYERS --
AND BASICALLY IN TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NOW REPORTED THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF LGBT Q. LAWYERS IN
THOSE FIRMS WAS APPROXIMATELY
TWO POINT 86%.
UP FROM 1% WHEN THEY STARTED
TRACKING THAT DATA IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO IN TERMS OF
JUDGES.
THE DATA -- IS SIMILARLY LOW --
BASED ON DATA FROM THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA ONLY SIXTY
TWO OUT OF SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE JUDGES ON THE
CALIFORNIA BENCH IDENTIFY.
AS LGBT Q. AND THERE'S ONLY ONE
TRANS GENDER JUDGE ALAMEDA
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE VICTORIA
CALICO SKI.
AND THAT'S AFTER TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE REALLY THE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS MADE BY
GOVERNOR BROWN WHO POINTED SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR OF THOSE
JUDGES.
AND OF WITH A 6% OF WHICH WERE
LGBT Q..
SO I GUESS AND YOU KNOW
SOMETHING ALL OF THIS UP I HAVE.
YOU KNOW WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT
IT'S IMPORTANT WE PRIDE ROLE
MODELS THE JUDICIARY IS AN
IMPORTANT INSTITUTION -- THAT --
GOES TO SORT OF WHETHER NOT WE
REALLY ACHIEVE JUSTICE IN OUR
COURT SYSTEMS AND I HAVE TO
CLOSING THOUGHTS THAT I'D ASK
YOU TO FOCUS ON FOR LGBT Q.
PEOPLE VOLUNTARY DATA COLLECTION
IS IMPORTANT TO MEASURE NOT ONLY
HOW FAR WE NEED TO GO. TO CHI
BETTER INCLUSION BUT ALSO TO
ELEVATE WHETHER OUR CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL COURT SYSTEMS ARE CHEATING
MEASURES OF JUSTICE.
WE NEED THE BARD EVALUATE THE
DATA THAT THEY'VE ALREADY
STARTED TO COLLECT AND WE NEED
STUDY DATA ON ALL GOVERNMENT
ROGRAMS THAT THAT BASICALLY
TOUCH BASE TOUCH WITH THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE THE
SECOND AND I'LL CLOSE WITH THIS --
BUT THAT'S WE SPONSORED ALL
THESE DATA COLLECTION BILLS --
TAPPING THE COURTS AND LEGAL
PROFESSIONAL BE COMPLICATED BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT WE FIGURE THAT
OUT SOON SECOND CONDUCTING LGT
CULTURAL COME TO TRAINING FOR
ALL JUDGES LAWYERS COURT STAFF
IS A HIGH PRIORITY.
WHEN LGBT PEOPLE INTERACTED THE
LEGAL PROFESSION IN OUR COURTS
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND AND THEY WERE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT AND
TRAINING WILL DOT AND THAT?
DISCRIMINATION OR LACK OF
ACCEPTANCE UNDERSTANDING BUT IT
WILL BE HALF WILL HAVE A BIG
IMPACT ON INCLUSION IN THE
PROFESSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT THANK YOU.
JUDGE MISSUS.
GOOD MORNING I'M FIRST OF ALL TO
EVERYONE PRESENT TODAY -- I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND I KNOW
THAT I WAS INVITED TO SPEAK ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSITY AND
THE LEGAL PROFESSION.
AND THE COURTS -- SIDE FIRST
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MYSELF I AM
CURRENTLY -- THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA LATINO JUDGES
ASSOCIATION.
I AM THE CO PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
I AM THE CHAIR OF CJ'S TASK
FORCE ON GENDER RACE ETHNICITY
FAIRNESS IN THE COURTS.
AND I AM THE CHAIR OF THE
ADVISORY BOARD OF THE ELIZABETH
GET IT ON MY CS LEGAL STUDIES
ACADEMY AT SANTANA HIGH SCHOOL.
NOW I SAY THIS BECAUSE IF
SOMEONE HAD ASKED ME WHEN I WAS
FIVE YEARS OLD. TEN YEARS OLD IF
I WOULD BE HERE TODAY.
I WOULD HAVE SAID ONLY IN MY
DREAMS.
I'M I OFTEN SPEAK AND I SPEAK TO
THE COMMUNITY AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME.
AND I ASKED TO BE INTRODUCED AS
THE GARDENER'S DAUGHTER.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE MY FATHER
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE.
AND GET THE ROOF OVER OUR HEADS.
DOING MANUAL LABOR EVERY DAY OF
HIS LIFE.
AND SO IDENTIFY VERY MUCH OF
THIS BUT RATHER.
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT. TO TELL
MY STORY.
AND EVEN PUT IT ON MY STORY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT MY STORY.
IT'S THE STORY OF SO MANY OTHERS.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER.
IS THAT NO ONE THOUGHT THAT I
WOULD BE HERE TODAY.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
WHEN I WAS HAVING MY EDUCATION
IN SANTA ANA.
AND I FLUNKED SECOND GRADE.
AND I WAS TOLD WHAT CLASSES I
BELONG.
TO AND WHERE I HAD TO ASK IN
FIFTH GRADE. TO BE PLACED IN A
BETTER ENGLISH READING CLASS THE
ULTIMATELY WAS WHAT OPEN THE
DOORS AND GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I HAVE TO
THIS DAY.
IT WAS.
A TEN YEAR OLD KID ASKING FOR
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN I
WAS ULTIMATELY PLACED IN GAVE
CLASSES GIFTED AND TALENTED
EDUCATION.
AND I COULDN'T PASS THE TEST
BECAUSE I DIDN'T GROW UP
[inaudible]
WITH PUZZLES.
WITH CREATIVE THINKING SKILLS.
I WAS GOING TO TAKE IT OUT OF
THAT CLASS.
BUT IT WAS MY MOTHER WITH A
SIXTH GRADE EDUCATION THAT
MARCHED INTO THE SCHOOL AS THAT
IF SHE CAN DO THE WORK THAT SHE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO REMAIN.
AND SO I REMAINED IN THOSE
CLASSES AND IT'S BECAUSE OF THAT
THAT I HAD HONORS CLASSES AND AB
CLASSES.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT IN HIGH
SCHOOL MY ENGLISH MY A. P.
ENGLISH TEACHER.
TOLD FIVE OF THE CLASS MEMBERS
THAT THEY COULD PASS THE TEST
AND AT THE REST OF US COULD NOT.
AND SO MANY OF THE STUDENTS
STOPPED GOING TO CLASS.
I WOULD SHOW UP.
AND I WOULD DO MY HOMEWORK FOR
OTHER CLASSES.
I WAS OFTEN TRIED PEOPLE OFTEN
TRY TO DEFINE.
IF I TELL ME WHAT I COULD AND
WHAT I COULD NOT DO.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN I
APPLIED TO COLLEGE.
THE BEST OF MY CANCER COULD
WRITE FOR ME WAS THAT I WAS NICE
AND PRETTY.
TOO AND THAT HELPED.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN I WAS
IN COLLEGE.
AND I WAS.
WORKING OVER THIRTY PLUS HOURS
AND TAKING EIGHTEEN UNITS
BECAUSE I NEEDED TO GRADUATE
NINETY TO MAKE MONEY.
THAT MY COUNSELOR TOLD ME THAT I
COULDN'T GET MYSELF INTO LAW
SCHOOL.
AND SO I SAID THANK YOU.
SO WHAT IS IT THAT I NEED TO DO
SO THAT I CAN APPLY.
AS I TOOK THE MONEY THAT I HAD
SAVED WORKING FOR MIGRANT
EDUCATION DURING THE SUMMER
[inaudible]
AND I PAY FOR ELSE THAT CLASS.
AND I TO BE ALL SET.
AND I SAID YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
KNOW MY STORY I DIDN'T GET THE
BEST SCORE BUT I TOLD MY STORY
AND I GOT MYSELF INTO LAW SCHOOL.
AND SO I WILL TELL YOU THAT
HAVING DATED MY HUSBAND THEN
BOYFRIEND FOR EIGHT YEARS WHO
LIVED IN ONE HOUSE DOWN.
WE DECIDED TO GET MARRIED RIGHT
BEFORE GOING OFF TO LAW SCHOOL.
AND I STARTED I GOT MARRIED IN
JULY I STARTED SCHOOL IN AUGUST
AND I WAS PREGNANT BY DECEMBER.
AS I DID MY FIRST YEAR OF LAW
SCHOOL PREGNANT.
AND I'M CERTAIN THAT THERE WERE
BETTER THE PREGNANT LADY WASN'T
GONNA MAKE IT THROUGH WHEN SHE
WAS GOING TO GET CUT HER FIRST
YEAR.
BUT I REFUSED TO MAKE THAT
STEREO TYPE TRIP.
AND I KEPT GOING AND I KEPT
WORKING HARD AS I HAD MY BABY MY
FIRST YEAR OF LAW SCHOOL.
WE WENT BACK TO ORANGE COUNTY
AND FOR TWO YEARS I DROVE TO SAN
DIEGO EVERY OTHER DAY.
I WAS A FULL TIME STUDENT I WAS
A FULL TIME ON AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT WHEN.
WHEN I WAS IN LAW SCHOOL?
I APPLIED FOR THE THIRD PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
DO YOU GET A PAID CLERKSHIP.
AND I DIDN'T GET IT AND I REALLY
NEEDED THE MONEY.
THAT.
I DECIDED THAT I WAS GOING TO
WORK FOR FREE AND SO I CALLED
THEM AND I SAID CAN I CLICK FOR
YOU.
THAT CAN I IN TURN FOR YOU
EXCUSE ME.
AND THIS IS WHAT WE NORMALLY
DON'T THINK IN TERMS AND I SAID
I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WE GIVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY.
AND SO THEY GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I WAS THERE
BEFORE THE PAID IN CLERK WAS
THERE.
AND SHE TOOK LUNCH AND I DIDN'T
AND SHE LEFT FOR THE DAY AND I
REMAIN AND SHE CAN COME ON THE
WEEKENDS AND I SHOWED UP ON THE
WEEKENDS AND I WORK.
AND SO WHEN I GRADUATED.
I DIDN'T APPLY FOR A JOB BECAUSE
I BODY INTO THE NARRATIVE THE
PEOPLE LIKE ME DON'T PASSED THE
BAR THE FIRST TIME AROUND.
AND SO IT LO AND BEHOLD I DO.
AND I DON'T HAVE A JOB.
AND THERE'S A VACANCY AT THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
AND SO I SAID IT.
I'D LIKE TO APPLY THEY SAID WE
DON'T HIRE STRAIGHT A LAW SCHOOL
AND I SAID AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT I WORKED REALLY HARD FOR YOU.
AND ALTHOUGH ONE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY WILL YOU LET ME UP
APPLY.
WILL YOU GIVE ME THE THE
INTERVIEW AND THEY SAID WE WILL
AND I CONVINCED THEM.
AND THEY GAVE ME THE JOB.
AND FOR FOURTEEN YEARS I WAS A
DEPUTY FEDERAL PUBLIC DEFENDER
THE ONLY LATINA PRACTICING OUT
OF THE RONALD REAGAN FEDERAL
BUILDING CENTRAL DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN I
WAS ON THE BOARD OF THE LATINO
LAWYER BAR ASSOCIATION.
WITH VERY COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH
LET THE NEXT ON THE BENCH.
AS I SAID YOU KNOW I'M NOT MUCH
OF A TALKER I'M MORE OF A DO OR
WHAT WE APPLIED.
I THINK I WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT
A FLIGHT.
BUT WHEN I APPROACH PEOPLE ABOUT
APPLYING TO BECOME A ORANGE
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE.
I WAS TOLD PEOPLE LIKE YOU DON'T
GET APPOINTED.
YOU SEE I WENT TO CAL STATE
FULLERTON I WENT TO CALIFORNIA
WESTERN AND WITH AN IVY LEAGUE.
I HEARD THINGS LIKE LEGACY IN
PEDIGREE.
AND SO I SAID YOU KNOW I'M GONNA
APPLY ANYWAY.
AND I APPLIED FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND I'M VERY PROUD TO
SAY THAT WHEN I SUBMITTED MY
APPLICATION AND I TOLD MY STORY.
TO THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BROWN.
THAT HE HEARD IT.
AND SO BY DECEMBER TWENTY TWELVE
I WAS APPOINTED AN ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT I'M ONE OF
FOR LATINOS THAT CURRENTLY SIT
ON THE BENCH OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT I WAS A
SUPERVISOR TWO YEARS INTO BEING
EIGHT OR COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE.
AND THAT SIX YEARS INTO MY
PRACTICE I'M ON THE FELONY TRIAL
PANEL WHICH GENERALLY DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
AND THE REASON WHY I SAY ALL OF
THIS AND I KNOW THAT MY MOTHER
TAUGHT ME HUMILITY.
BUT IT'S BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO TELL OUR STORY BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST MINE IT'S MISTER DRAW
THOSE AS WELL ONE DAY I HOPE
THAT SHE WILL JOIN ME ON THE
BENCH.
AND SO I CLOSE WITH THIS.
AS THE JUDGE FIRST AND FOREMOST
I APPLY THE LAW.
I CONSIDER MYSELF A WISE LATINA.
I HOPE THAT THE RICHNESS OF MY
EXPERIENCE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
HELP ME REACH A BETTER
CONCLUSION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA OPEN UP FOR
QUESTIONS AND FIRST OF ALL THIS
BUT THE RATHER.
AND REALIZE YOU WITH GIRLS THINK
THE LAST TIME.
I INTERACTED WITH THEM WAS
EARLIER THIS WINTER AND THEY
CAME UP INTO THIS HEARING ROOM.
AND I GOT A CHANCE TO TALK TO
THEM AND I THINK APROPOS.
THE THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE
THAT YOU FACE AND ESPECIALLY.
THAT THE TWO OF YOU ARE NOT
CHALLENGES THAT I FACED BEING
WHITE BEING MALE.
THAT THAT'S KIND OF THE CLASSIC
PRIVILEGE AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALL NEED
TO BE VERY COGNIZANT OF BUT I
ASKED THE GIRLS TO COME UP AND
SIT UP HERE.
AS OPPOSED TO OUT THERE.
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN'T ENVISION
YOURSELF IN A ROLE.
THEN YOU CLOSE THOSE DOORS
ESPECIALLY WITH OTHERS TELLING
YOU YOU'RE NOT QUALIFIED OR
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO GET THERE.
SO I THINK THAT'S FOR ALL OF US
TO REMEMBER AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GIVING KIDS IN STUDENTS.
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO ENVISION
THEMSELVES.
WHERE THEY DREAM OR OR WHAT'S
POSSIBLE OTHERWISE THEY DON'T?
GO UP THERE SO BUT UP ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT CAME UP AND
MISTER HARRIS MRS VERY THE YOU
BOTH BROUGHT UP WITH DATA.
AND DATA COLLECTION AND THE FACT
THAT WE'RE NOT COLLECTING A LOT
OF DATA AND OTHERS THAT WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE AROUND IT.
BUT YOU ALSO AN INTEGRATED.
IF WE'RE GONNA COLLECT DATA
THERE IS STIGMA IN GLBT AND IN
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT?
AS WE COLLECT DATA AS WE REALLY
THAT THAT WE'RE ABLE TO GET.
TO THE TRUTH OF WHO PEOPLE ARE
AND AND GET THAT WILLING.
TO RISE ABOVE THAT STIGMA AND
AND BE COUNTED CORRECTLY SO THAT
WE CAN TRACK AND UNDERSTAND AND
THEN KNOW THAT HELPS US
UNDERSTAND WHERE OUR PROBLEMS
ARE.
SO IF IF BOTH YOU CAN HELP WITH
THAT QUESTION [inaudible]
MR -- THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION -- THAT QUESTION
ACTUALLY GETS BROUGHT UP A LOT
AND ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT --
THINGS TO REMEMBER IS THAT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES -- JUST
LIKE THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY DO NOT
HAVE TO DISCLOSE -- THAT IS A
PERSONAL DECISION -- AND THAT IS
ONE THAT IS OFTEN VERY VERY
CHALLENGING ESPECIALLY IF YOU
HAVE A AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY -- PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISABILITY MENTAL -- HEALTH --
DISORDER OF HOWEVER IN MY
OPINION OF THE LEGAL COMMUNITY
CAN DO ITS BEST TO BE AS
WELCOMING AS POSSIBLE -- HAVE
THE TYPE OF ATTITUDE AND
WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT -- THAT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WOULD
WANT -- TO APPROACH WOULD --
EMBRACE.
AND WOULD FEEL EMBRACED -- I
BELIEVE THAT HAVING OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION OR AROUND THE LEGAL
PROFESSION ON THE JUDICIARY --
WHO ARE COMFORTABLE AND AT PEACE
WITH WHO THEY ARE OF AND ABLE TO
TELL THEIR STORIES -- IT WILL.
INVITE A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES -- TO BE MORE OPEN --
ABOUT WHO THEY ARE -- AND KNOW
THAT THEIR TRUTH AND THEIR
EXPERIENCES ARE IMPORTANT AND
WILL BE TAKING OF INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN THEY GO TO LAW SCHOOL OR
INTO THE LEGAL PROFESSION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I MEAN THE
FIRST STEP IS TO ACTUALLY ASK
VOLUNTARY QUESTIONS ON ALL FORMS
IT'S NOT HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA
I THINK WE HAVE THREE AREAS
WHERE.
IT'S HAPPENING WHICH IS THEN THE
HEALTH AREA EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATION NOW -- BUT REALLY IT'S
YOU KNOW EVEN THOUGH NOW BECAUSE
BEEN.
ASKING ABOUT -- SEGMENTATION
GENDER DAILY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE BAR DID
NOT START ASKING ABOUT THAT
UNTIL THIS YEAR'S SO -- YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THAT QUESTION BE ASKED I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW HAVE THIS SENSE THAT IS
SOME HOUSE SHAMEFUL TO ASK
SOMEONE ABOUT THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY
AND WE CAN'T.
WE HAVE TO GET PAST THE STIGMA
OF THAT BEING A BAD THING -- AND
SO OBVIOUSLY YOU DON'T WANT TO
FORCE ANYONE TO EVER ASKED IT'S
GOT ALWAYS BE A VOLUNTARY
QUESTION BUT I THINK EVEN JUST
ASKING THE QUESTION IS THE FIRST
STEP.
IF THERE ARE WAYS AND YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY IN A GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM IT'S HARDER TO SORT OF
FIGURE THIS OUT BUT WE DO KNOW
WHEN -- WHEN RESPONSES ARE
ANONYMOUS ARE SOMEWHAT ANONYMOUS
THAT THE RESPONSE RATES GO UP --
WE WERE SHOCKED FRANKLY WHEN WE
DID OUR POLL IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND IT WAS A
STATISTICALLY VALID POLL OF
REGISTERED VOTERS ARE SUBTLE
PUBLIC BUT IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S A
PRETTY GOOD SAMPLE OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE. TO FIND OUT THAT 12% OF
THE CALIFORNIA RICHARD VOTERS
IDENTIFIED AS MEMBERS OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
THAT WAS SHOCKING TO US MOST
ESTIMATES.
YOU KNOW THAT ARE OUT THERE ON
CITIES BEFORE HAD ESTIMATED
BETWEEN FOUR AND 5% OF PEOPLE
SELF REPORT.
A WE HAD ALWAYS ASSUMED THAT
THAT WAS ABOUT DOUBLE BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT STIGMA PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING FROM
CONSERVATIVE RELIGIOUS
BACKGROUNDS.
OFTEN WILL NOT EVEN THINK OF
THEMSELVES AS A MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY EVEN THOUGH MAYBE THEY
MAY BE ENGAGING AND SAME SEX
ACTIVITIES TO SOME EXTENT.
SO -- I THINK FOR YOU KNOW
FINDING.
WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN ASK THE
QUESTION COMFORTABLY IT'S YOU
KNOW ON A FORM WHERE PEOPLE CAN.
RESPOND WHEN THEY'RE SITTING BY
THEMSELVES I MEAN THERE'S A LOT
THERE'S A LOT OF WAYS WE DO
CULTURE COME TO TRAINING AND
HEALTH CARE SETTINGS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE REALLY ARE TRAINING
EVERYONE TO DO ALWAYS ASK THE
FORM PUT IT ON THE BOTTOM.
PICTURE IT'S VOLUNTARY AND WE
KNOW THAT WHEN THAT HAPPENS
PEOPLE FILL THE FORM OUT BUT
FIRST QUESTION IS ASKING THE
QUESTIONS.
POINT TAKEN THAT JUST ASK THE
QUESTIONS AND THEN.
SEE IF THERE'S A WAY TO DIG A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER IF IF
NECESSARY.
GOOD AND WE HAVE A CAPTIVE
AUDIENCE BOTH WITH THE BAR.
AND THE BENCH SO WE WE DO KNOW
HOW TO REACH EVERYBODY AND AND
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THE THREATS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE PANEL SO MUCH ROOM FOR
THE DIVERSITY THAT IS HERE -- AT
THE AT THE WITNESS TABLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I YOUR MESSAGE IS IS HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR -- JUDGMENT CS I I'VE
HEARD YOU SPEAK BEFORE IT AND I
I REALLY ADMIRE WHERE YOU CAME
FROM -- BECAUSE YOU GIVE HOPE.
TO OF GOT IN -- AS SHE'S -- AS
AS SHE'S LOOKING AT HER FUTURE
SHE NO SHE'S GOING TO BE ON THE
BENCH OR SHE'S GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT -- THE EVERYTHING IS
AVAILABLE TO HER.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
STARTED TALKING ABOUT THE
DISABILITY.
AND THEN YOU'RE ALSO AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT
THE INTERSECTION NOW TO
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO BE SO
CONCERNED WITH -- AND IT.
THOSE STORES HAVE TO BE OPENED.
AND RICK WHAT CAN I SAY I BUT IN
ATTORNEY FOR SO MANY YEARS I
LOVE HAVING COLLEAGUES SITTING
HERE WITH US RIGHT -- KNOWING
THAT THAT THAT WE'RE RIGHT WELL
REPRESENTED -- IT I BUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
DIVERSITY AND JUST AS YOU SAID I
THANK THINK THAT EVERYBODY IT'S
ALWAYS TRYING TO DEFINE US --
HE'S A DISABLED MAN -- HUGHES
AND LGBT -- WARRIOR -- SHE'S
JUST A STUDENT AT THE FARM
WORKER.
BUT THEY CAN'T DEFINE US AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT EVERYTHING
THAT WE ARE WE WE GET TO SHOW
BECAUSE WHEN WE HAVE THAT
DIVERSITY WHETHER IT'S ON THE
BENCH OR WE HAVE IT WITH -- WITH
WITH OUR IN OUR LEGAL PROFESSION
OR ANYWHERE -- THAT'S WE HAVE
GREATNESS IS WHEN WE DO HAVE
DIVERSITY SO IT'S IT'S ALL OF
YOU THAT HELPS TO MAKE OUR
PROFESSION GREAT.
AND TO THE BENCH GREAT SO I I
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF FOR FOR
BEING HERE FOR TESTIFYING YOUR
WORD IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO THANK YOU LET ME
FIRST THANK THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR FOR HOLDING THIS.
IS HEARING AND I DID HAVE A
CHANCE.
TO MAKE A FEW OPENING COMMENTS
I'D LIKE TO DO IT BUT WITH --
SOME REFLECTION ON THE COMMENTS
HE JUST MADE A PERSONAL JUDGE
MISIA'S THANK YOU.
FOR HOW YOU SHARE YOUR STORY --
I THINK FOR MANY OF US WHO ARE --
ATTORNEYS OF COLOUR HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE WERE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE HERE EITHER -- AS SOME OF
IMMIGRANTS -- I WASN'T SUPPOSED
TO BECOME A LAWYER.
MY TEACHERS AND SEEN AS A LAWYER
MY FAMILY CERTAINLY DIDN'T THINK
THAT ANY OF US.
WOULD BE IN THE PROFESSIONS THAT
WE'RE IN NOW AND AND YET WE ARE
HERE -- AND I THINK FOR MANY OF
US.
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WHILE WE WERE THE LUCKY FEW.
THAT WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR LEGAL PROFESSION
LOOKS AS DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA
IS -- APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
ABOUT DATA SOMETHING I'VE HAD A
THE HONOR TO WORK WITH THAT MR
SUPPORT EQUALITY CALIFORNIA ON
BUT AS A STATE BARS OWN DATA
SHOWS AND I THINK THE NEXT PANEL
IS GOING TO TALK ABOUT.
THE DATA IS REALLY STARK ABOUT
HOW MUCH WORK WE HAVE TO DO.
THE FACT IS -- THE LEGAL
PROFESSION IS ALMOST 80% WHITE
WHILE THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC IS
ONLY 30% 37% WHITE -- THE FACT
IS THE LEGAL PROFESSION IS
ALMOST 60% MALE.
WHICH MEANS ALMOST 50% MORE MEN
IN THE LEGAL PROFESSION THAN
WOMAN -- AND YOU CAN LOOK AT
EVERY INDICATOR OF HOW WE'RE
DOING WITH REGARD TO DIVERSITY
WERE NOT DOING WELL I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HEAR LATER.
ABOUT SOME STUDIES SPECIFICALLY
IN THE API COMMUNITY -- BUT
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR COMMUNITY SOME NUMBERS AND
FOR EXAMPLE MAJOR LAW FIRMS.
API'S HAVE THE HIGHEST ATTRITION
RATES THE LOWEST RATE OF
PARTNERSHIPS TO ASSOCIATES --
VAST MAJORITY IF API ATTORNEYS
REPORT EXPERIENCING VERY LITTLE
ACCESS TO MENTORSHIP.
IMPLICIT BIAS.
AS WELL AS LOW REPRESENTATION IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN
GOVERNMENT SECTOR AND AND THIS
IS.
NOT JUST THE STORY THE API
COMMUNITY IT'S IS THE STORY OF
OF ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES -- I
WANT TO JUST OBSERVE ONE THING
WHICH IS A FEW YEARS AGO WE HAD
A PRETTY ROBUST CONVERSATION FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AROUND STATE BAR
REFORM.
IN I DON'T THINK IT WAS AN
ACCIDENT -- THAT ALONG WITH THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
REFORM WAS BEING DRIVEN BY
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE THREE
ETHNIC CAUCUSES.
AND I THINK FOR MANY OF US WE
HAVE SEEN THE MAJOR INSTITUTIONS
IN THE STATE -- NOT FOCUSED ON
THESE ISSUES -- AND AFFECT ALSO
TO OBSERVE THAT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THE MOST ROBUST
LEADERSHIP AND WHEN IT COMES. TO
TWO ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING
DIVERSITY -- ARE IN BARSA
STATIONS ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE BAR AND ETHNIC BAR
ASSOCIATION AND WOMAN BAR
ASSOCIATION TEN LGBT BAR SISSY
ACTIONS.
IN PART BECAUSE THE MAIN LEGAL
INSTITUTIONS HAVE NOT FOCUSED ON
THIS -- THE MAIN.
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR STATE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE STATE BAR THE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAVE
HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN VIEWED.
BY COMMUNITIES OF DIVERSITY AS
INSTITUTIONS THAT SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON THESE ISSUES.
I WILL SAY IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS IN THE LAST YEAR I HAVE
NOTED.
I THINK A CHANGE IN TONE FROM
THE STATE BAR IN THE DISH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ABOUT THE
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE ON THESE
QUESTIONS AND ISSUES I KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE FROM THEM LATER.
BUT FOR I THINK MANY OF US THE
JURY IS GOING TO BE OUT.
UNTIL THE DATA CHANGES I THINK
IT'S EASY TO TALK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES IT'S EASY TO SAY WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THESE ISSUES BUT
IT'S MUCH HARDER TO ACTUALLY
MOVE THE CHANGE FORD SO -- LET
ME JUST END MY COMMENTS WITH THE
QUESTION IF THERE WERE ONE OR
TWO MAJOR INSTITUTIONAL CHANGES
THAT YOU COULD MAKE -- WHAT
WOULD THEY BE WHAT WOULD THEY BE?
I'M AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS.
I WILL SAY THAT -- THE
INSTITUTIONAL CHANGES THAT.
THAT OUR OUR HOPE -- TO BY OUR
LET THE NEXT COMMUNITY
PARTICULAR THE CALIFORNIA AT THE
NO JUDGES ASSOCIATION
OPPORTUNITY.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
TALK ABOUT BEING A GARDENER'S
DAUGHTER IS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT IT'S IT'S HARD WORK IT'S
SUPPORT BUT IT'S OPPORTUNITIES
ULTIMATELY.
AND THOSE OPPORTUNITIES MEANS
THAT WE NEED TO BE -- WE HAVE
NEED TO HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE.
AND WE NEED TO BE WELL
REPRESENTED IN JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
AB RIGHT WELL REPRESENTED IN
CEDAR.
WE NEED TO BE WELL
REPRESENTATIVE NAH AS PROFESSORS
IN THE LAW SCHOOLS.
WHEN YOU BE WELL REPRESENTED --
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND SO -- THE INSTITUTIONAL
CHANGE THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
HAPPEN IS.
NOT ONLY HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION BUT MAKING CERTAIN
THAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
MADE TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
QUALIFIED BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WELL QUALIFIED
TO TAKE THOSE POSITIONS
[inaudible]
OTHERS.
I I WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT AND I
AM PART OF THE LET US A LAW
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION AT UC DAVIS
AND I HAVE BEEN PART OF MANY
CLASSES.
STUDENT ASSOCIATIONS -- THROUGH
UNDERGRAD AS WELL AND I THINK
ONE OF ONE OF THE REAL LEADERS
FOR A LOT OF US HAS BEEN THE
HEALTH THAT.
I HAD TO TAKE IT TWICE TO BE
ABLE TO GET INTO LAW SCHOOL
WHILE WORKING FULL TIME.
I DIDN'T EVEN GET A CHANCE TO
FINISH.
ALL THE SESSIONS BECAUSE I HAD
TO WORK A JOB IN HALF AND SO.
I THINK THAT -- THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE -- THERE NEEDS TO BE
CHANGING HOW WE EVALUATE --
STUDENTS IN TERMS OF LIKE WHAT
THEY HOW THEY QUALIFIED TO GET
INTO LAW SCHOOL I THINK THAT ALL
SIDE IS.
IS.
NOT NECESSARILY A GOOD MEASURE
OF WHETHER YOU WILL SUCCEED IN
LAW SCHOOL AND I THINK THAT.
A LOT OF STUDENTS HAVE OTHER
QUALITIES THAT THEY CAN OFFER
THAT WILL DIVERSIFY THE LEGAL
PROFESSION NOT JUST IN TERMS OF
WHETHER YOU'RE A MINORITY OR NOT --
BUT I THINK THAT A LOT OF A LOT
OF UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
BRINK QUALITIES FROM REAL LIFE
THAT THEY CAN ADD -- TO THEIR
PRACTICE IN THE LEGAL PROFESSION --
AND I AGREE WITH JUDGE MESSY AS
IN TERMS OF OPPORTUNITY I THINK
THAT -- I HAVE I WAS BLESSED
WITH A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
ALONG THE WAY BUT I ALSO LOOKED
FOR THEM.
BECAUSE THEY WERE EASY TO FIND --
SO OPPORTUNITY RESOURCES IN THE
AISLES THAT THANK YOU.
I I'D SAY STATES -- SORT OF TWO
THINGS ONE IT'S I THINK IT'S
REALLY PART TO REMOVE BARRIERS.
TO ENTER THE PRACTICE --
ECONOMIC VERY SIR BIG ONE FOR
THE LP HE COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED SELLING
FOCUSING ON WAYS OF INCREASING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE NO MATTER
WHAT COLLEGE YOU'RE GOING -- TO
IT'S HOW IT'S ALWAYS HARDER AT
THE LAW SCHOOL LEVEL AND SO
THAT'S A BIG BARRIER FOR FOLKS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY -- I THINK THE
OTHER THING I WOULD SORT OF SAY
IS CULTURAL COMES THE TRAINING
IS IMPORTANT AND IT'S NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT FROM LGBT Q.
PERSPECTIVE BUT I THINK IT IS
THAT THERE SHOULD BE GENERAL
DIVERSITY TRAINING I MEAN -- THE
KINDS OF STORIES THAT THE JUDGES
TALKING ABOUT OF YOU KNOW ABOUT --
BEING YOU KNOW HEARING MESSAGES
THAT -- YOU KNOW SHE SHOULDN'T
BE REACHING FOR SOMETHING SHE
WANTS TO DO -- I MEAN THOSE ARE
YOU KNOW.
NOT USING THE RIGHT LANGUAGE
REFERRING TO LGBT Q. PEOPLE IN
WAYS THAT ARE NOT RESPECTFUL
THAT HAPPENS.
IN ALL UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES AND SO THAT IS WHY
WE HAVE BEEN SUCH.
OF YOU KNOW PUSHING SO MUCH ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF INCLUDE
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION TRAINING
THAT INCLUDES ALL TO THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY BUT REALLY ALL UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES AND IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR JUDGES.
I MEAN THAT HAS AN IMPACT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE IN
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE COURT
ROOM COURT STAFF -- AND EVEN IN
THE LEGAL PROFESSION AMONG
LAWYERS HAVE IN THERE IS -- YOU
KNOW IT'S PART OF THE CONTINUING
LEGAL EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
THERE IS SOME -- REQUIREMENTS ON
AND ELIMINATION OF BIAS BUT
GENERALLY THOSE PROGRAMS DOWN
EXTENDS TO THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
AND THAT FRANKLY I THINK --
THERE WHICH WEEK GENERALLY
BECAUSE SO MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE -- YOU KNOW GIVEN
FOR BY FOR PROFIT OUTSIDE --
FOLKS IN THE QUALITY IS IN HIGH
IN MY OPINION -- TO PAY YOU BACK
A LITTLE BIT OFF OF PREVIOUS
COMMENTS -- THE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT -- THINGS THE
INSTITUTIONS CAN DO IS OPEN THE
DOOR -- FOR THESE COMMUNITIES OF
I WROTE I WANT TO THANK AGAIN
THE CHAIR -- AND HIS STAFF HOME
FOR INCLUDING THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY IN THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE SO OFTEN -- IN
CONVERSATIONS LIKE THESE ONES
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITIES LEFT
OUT -- KIND OF FORGOTTEN ABOUT
YOU KNOW WE THINK OF THE
DIFFERENT CAUCUSES HERE IN THE
BUILDING WE THINK OF OF THE
BLACK CAUCUS OR THE A PR CAUCUS
OF LATINO CAUCUS.
BUT OFTEN TIMES OF THE
DISABILITY -- GROUPS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY INCLUDED IN AND NOT
ONLY IS IT IMPORTANT TO HAVE --
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY AT MY
TABLE LIKE THIS ONE BUT ALSO
HAVING THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
INCLUDED AT DECISION MAKING --
TABLES AS WELL -- TABLES WHERE --
PEOPLE CAN REALLY REALLY IMPACT
CHANGE OF IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION -- I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT.
IT WAS FOR ME GROWING UP BEING
ABLE TO LOOK AT AFRICAN AMERICAN
ATTORNEYS -- AFRICAN AMERICAN
JUDGES OF AND KNOWING THAT
BECAUSE THEY CAN DO IT I CAN DO
IT -- AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR ME
GROWING UP I DIDN'T SEE.
VERY MANY OF ATTORNEYS ARE
JUDGES WITH DISABILITIES -- THAT
I COULD RELATE TO SO IT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT AND AND I KNOW
THAT.
HOME. FOR MYSELF IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT I PAY IT FORWARD AS WELL --
WHEN I SEE -- KIDS WITH
DISABILITIES -- WHO ASPIRED TO
TO BE GREAT -- INSPIRED TO DO
AMAZING THINGS WHETHER IT'S AS A
LOBBYIST.
OR IN THE LEGAL PROFESSION OR
ANY OTHER PROFESSION THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I ENCOURAGE THEM
AND I SHOW THEM THAT THAT THEY
CAN BE EXACTLY WHO THEY WANT TO
BE.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE AND
I WANT TO JUST REFLECT ON THEM
FOR A MOMENT BUT TO SAY.
AN APOLOGY TO THE CHAIR WE ONLY
HAVE TWO MORE DAYS -- BEFORE WE
HAVE TO START VOTING ON HUNDREDS
OF BILLS NEXT WEEK AND I KNOW --
THAT EVERYONE'S TRYING
FRANTICALLY DO LAST MINUTE
MEETINGS -- BUT I WILL SHARE
THAT THIS VERY CONVERSATION IS
ONE I'VE HAD OFTEN NOT JUST WITH
LEGAL.
LEADERS AROUND -- SO REST
ASSURED WE ARE TO BE FOCUSED ON
THIS TOPIC REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
WE ARE PHYSICALLY HERE NOT.
ON A FEW THINGS I'M HOPING THE
REST OF THIS HEARINGS GOING TO
COVER -- ONE THAT THE TOPIC
AROUND TESTS AND THE L. SAID IN
A PARTICULAR THIS THE BAR EXAM.
UP THE DATA IS VERY VERY CLEAR
AND HOW THESE EXAMS SEEM TO BE
BORING -- FUTURE LEADERS WITHIN
THE LEGAL PROFESSION.
THAT REPRESENT THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR STATE AND IT IT'S IT'S IT'S
A CONVERSATION I THINK WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO HAVE ITS ONE
WERE ALL VERY CONCERNED ABOUT --
I THINK THEY'RE MANY REASONS ON
BOTH SIDES OF Y. THING SHOULD OR
SHOULD NOT CHANGE BUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THE BURDEN
OF PROOF SHOULD LIE WITH THE
STATUS QUO BECAUSE THINGS HAVE
TO CHANGE.
THE SECOND SET OF QUESTIONS I
REALLY DO HOPE ARE ANSWERED IN
ON SOME OF THE PANELISTS ALLUDED
TO THIS IS JUST.
AGAIN HOW DO WE PUSH THE LEGAL
PROFESSION IN EVERY PART OF THE
PROFESSION TO GET MORE DIVERSE
NOT JUST BROADLY RIGHT YOU CAN
LOOK AT DATA ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
BUT WHAT CAN BE DONE
SPECIFICALLY.
WITHIN THE PRIVATE BAR AND LAW
FIRMS TO MOVE THINGS FOR WHAT
CAN BE DONE IN ACADEMIA WHAT CAN
BE DONE AND GOVERNMENT.
WHAT CAN BE DONE IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST NONPROFIT SECTOR MY
HOPE IS THERE WILL BE SUBSEQUENT
PANELS THAT DIVE SPECIFICALLY
INTO INTO THOSE QUESTIONS --
BLESSING WANT TO SAY IS THE GOOD
JUDGE REFER TO OPPORTUNITIES AND
HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS ARE
AT THE TABLE AND WHAT I HAVE.
MY MY CONCERN ABOUT THE MAJOR
LEGAL INSTITUTIONS IN MOVEMENT
FOR REFORM IS WE HAVEN'T SEEN.
CHANGE YET.
AND THESE ARE INSTITUTIONS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN AS DIVERSE AS WE
NEED THEM TO BE THEMSELVES AND
SO WHEN IT SUGGESTED FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL CAN
LEAD ON THIS.
THAT IS GREAT NEWS BUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- A BENCH THAT IS
BY AND LARGE STILL DOMINATED BY
FOLKS THAT DON'T REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE AND SO MY
QUESTION TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WOULD BE.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THINGS FORWARD -- GIVEN THE
LACK OF DIVERSITY THAT THE
INSTITUTIONAL FLEX -- TO THE
STATE BAR I'LL JUST NOTE --
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME HEADWAY
THIS YEAR AFTER BAR REFORMS WERE
PUT INTO PLACE BY A STATE BAR
PRESIDENT WHO REFLECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE WHO
HAPPENS.
TO HAVE COME THROUGH SOME OF THE
ETHNIC BARS THAT I WAS REFERRING --
TO AND YOU HAPPEN HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED TO HIS POSITION.
AFTER THE STATE BAR FORMS THAT
WE PUT IN PLACE AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT AFTER HE LEAVES --
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT
CONTINUITIES GOING TO EXIST
WITHIN THE STATE PARTY WITH THE
SPORTS SO MY HOPE IS TO COME
BACK TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS
DIRECTLY IN FUTURE PANELS BUT IF
I'M NOT ABLE TO GET BACK -- I DO
HOPE MY STAFF WILL BE HERE WILL
BE MONITORING AND WILL CONTINUE
TO WATCH THIS.
THE LAST THING I'LL JUST SAY IS
THERE A LOT OF GREAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COME TOGETHER TODAY FOR
THIS HEARING THE THE CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF YOU PUT TOGETHER AN
AMAZING LAST.
I'D LOVE TO JUST LITERALLY LOCK
EVERYONE IN A ROOM.
AB THIS ROOM.
UNTIL YOU ALL FIGURED OUT.
BECAUSE I TRULY THINK THE
ANSWERS ARE PROBABLY IN THIS
ROOM ON AND WHAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT IS A LOT OF IDEAS WILL
COME OUT OF THIS AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE THE HEAD WITH THAT
WE NEED -- BUT I WILL BE LOOKING
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS AS IF YOU
IN THE AUDIENCE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE MOVE THIS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD WE NEED TO
LEAD.
WE REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF THE
WORLD HERE WE ARE ON THE CUTTING
EDGE OF SO MANY THINGS AND YET
OUR OUR LEGAL PROFESSION.
IS IS IS IS PROBABLY STILL STUCK
A COUPLE DECADES BACK.
AND IT'S UP TO US TO BE THE
CHANGE THAT WE WANT AND I DO
BELIEVE AND KNOW THAT EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM.
INCLUDING FOLKS FROM THE MAJOR
INSTITUTIONS AS WELL AS FOLKS ON
THE OUTSIDE.
OUR 1000% COMMITTED TO FIGURE
THIS OUT SO LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THAT WANT TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THIS
PANEL I GUESS JUST A COUPLE
CLOSING THOUGHTS MS BUT THE ROSA.
THIS COMMITTEE LOVES TO GET IN
TURN.
SO YOU SHOULD CONSIDER THAT IT
AND MISTER HARRIS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT I THINK WE HAVE
WITH THE DIVERT THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY.
IS THAT THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE
IS ABLE BY.
SO PERHAPS YOU SHOULD THINK
ABOUT COMING UP IN JOINING US.
AT SOME POINT IN IT KERRY THAT
VOICE FORWARD WHICH IS EXACTLY
THE POINT OF YES WE NEED TO DO
MORE.
TRAINING AND REDUCING BIAS AND
ALL BUT UNTIL.
A BODY LIKE THIS OR PROFESSION.
LOOKS LIKE CALIFORNIA AND HAS
SOMEBODY THERE REMINDING US AS
WE DO POLICY IT BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET THOSE.
VIEW POINTS PUT FORWARD.
SO IT'S TO PROD THE EDUCATION
YES THE DATA COLLECTION
ABSOLUTELY BUT ALSO THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE TO WORK TO MISTER CHOOSE
POINT MAKING SURE THAT.
THE LEGAL PROFESSION ACROSS THE
BOARD.
LOOKS LIKE CALIFORNIA AND WILL
THEN START TO BE SEEMING MORE
WELCOMING BECAUSE IT WILL BETTER
AS A BODY UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES
THAT IT'S FACING AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
A SO THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
NEXT ISSUE WHICH IS REALLY
TALKING A LOT ABOUT.
THE PIPELINE.
AND THE THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE ARTIFICIAL HURDLES
THAT KEEP PEOPLE OUT AND AND WE
WERE NOT.
PREPARING PEOPLE ALWAYS. TO BE
THEIR THEIR BEST INTO THE
PROFESSION.
SO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO
WILL BE JOINING US LANDING KLEIN
WHO IS A FELLOW.
WITH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HERE.
WE HAVE MIKEL KERR LANDER
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DAVIS TO TALK ABOUT
ISSUES IN THE EARLY PART OF THIS
PIPELINE.
KELLY SIMS BUTLER.
ASSISTANT DEAN GRADUATE STUDIES
AT THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
DAVIS TALKING ABOUT LATER PARTS
OF THE PIPELINE.
SONG RICHARDSON DEAN OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IRVINE
SCHOOL OF LAW TALKING ABOUT
EXACTLY THE CUT SCORE.
AND WE'RE VERY HONORED TO HAVE
JUST AS GOOD IN LIEU OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT.
CAREER ADVANCEMENT AND DIVERSITY
I KNOW IS VERY HIGH ON JUSTICE
LOSE.
LIST OF ISSUES WITHIN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION THAT HE IS WORKING ON
SOLVING.
RIGHT DOCTOR KLEIN.
AT FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
AND FOR HAVING ALL THESE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE TOGETHER AND I
I WANT TO TAKE THINK THE FIRST
PANEL -- FOR THEIR REMARKABLE
TESTIMONY AND I THINK THAT NOW
THAT WE'VE HEARD A BIT ABOUT THE
PERSONAL DIFFICULTIES THAT ARE
FACED BY A DIVERSE POPULATIONS
IN ACCESSING THE LEGAL
PROFESSION -- IT'S SORT OF
USEFUL TO FRAME THE REST OF OUR
DISCUSSION TODAY.
WITH SOME OF THAT THE STATISTICS
IDENTIFYING JUST EXACTLY WHAT
THE SCOPE OF UNDER
REPRESENTATION IS IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AND THE JUDICIARY AS
A WHOLE -- I WANNA GIVE A BIT OF
A DISCLAIMER HERE THAT -- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M GOING TO
FOCUS PRIMARILY ON RACIAL
DIVERSITY -- BUT THAT THIS IS
NOT.
TO DISCOUNT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOR EXAMPLE LGBT Q. ADD
DIVERSITY TRANS GENDER DIVERSITY
DISABILITY PER DIVERSITY AND THE
LIKE -- WE DO HAVE SOME
STATISTICS ON THAT IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER FOR THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED AND I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
DISCUSS THAT -- DURING THE
QUESTIONING PERIOD.
SO.
THE LEGAL PROFESSION IS AMONG
THE LEAST DIVERSE PROFESSIONS IN
THE NATION -- AND IF YOU LOOK UP
HERE YOU CAN SEE THAT -- WITH
SEVERAL OTHER PROFESSIONS THAT
REQUIRE SIMILAR AMOUNTS OF
TRAINING AND PROFICIENCY AT
LEGAL PROFESSION NONETHELESS
FALLS SHORT IN TERMS OF
REPRESENTATION OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR -- SO ABOUT BETWEEN A
QUARTER AND A THIRD OF
PHYSICIANS FOR EXAMPLE ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND YET ONLY 12%
OF LAWYERS NATIONALLY ARE
COMPRISED OF PEOPLE OF COLOR --
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S LAWYERS ARE
MARGINALLY MORE DIVERSE THAN THE
NATION'S AS A WHOLE WITH 80%
BEING WHITE VERSUS 88%
NATIONWIDE -- WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUELY DIVERSE
DEMOGRAPHICS WITH ONLY 37% BEING
WHITE COMPARED 273% IN THE
NATION AS A WHOLE -- IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT MINORITY UNDER
REPRESENTATION IN CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS IS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC -- AND THIS IS TRUE
IN SPITE OF SEVERAL EFFORTS BY
THE LEGISLATURE BY THE FORMER
GOVERNOR AND VARIOUS NON PROFITS
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS. TO
ATTEMPT TO INCREASE DIVERSITY
WITHIN THE LEGAL PROFESSION --
IT IS TRUE THAT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE THERE
HAVE BEEN MARGINAL INCREASES IN
ATTORNEYS OF COLOUR AT YOU CAN
SEE THERE ARE QUITE SMALL HERE
BUT NONE THE LESS AT THAT TREND
IS MOVING IN THE CORRECT
DIRECTION -- BUT THIS
IMPROVEMENT AT BEST ONLY KEEPS
PACE WITH THE DEMOGRAPHIC THE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT IF YOU
LOOK AT THESE CHANGES OVER TIME
WHEN CONSIDERED RELATIVE TO THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE POPULATION.
WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE AN INCREASE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE IN THE
OVER REPRESENTATION OF WHITE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AND IF YOU LOOK AT
FURTHER DOWN HERE.
AT WE CAN SEE HOW THIS WORKS AND
WE CAN SEE THAT THERE IS
ACTUALLY A RELATIVELY FLAT LINE
FROM 200-012-2017 IN TERMS OF
THE REPRESENTATION AS A
PROPORTION OF THE POPULATION FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR -- THERE ARE
SEVERAL REASONS THAT MIGHT BE
THE CASE AND HOPEFULLY THE REST
OF THE PANELS TODAY WE'LL
DISCUSS THESE IN MORE DETAIL --
BUT I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT
VERY BRIEFLY ON ONE OF THESE
POSSIBLE BOTTLENECKS IN TERMS OF
DIVERSITY.
IN THE LEGAL PROFESSION AND
THAT'S RACIAL DISPARITIES IN BAR
EXAM PARTICIPATION AND PASSAGE
RATES.
I'M [inaudible]
SO.
I'M JUST HIGHLIGHTING A SINGLE
ONE OF THESE ISSUES BUT IT'S
VERY CLEAR HERE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS FIRST CHART.
THAT THE PERCENTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA BAR EXAM TEST TAKERS
AT AS A FUNCTION OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE POPULATION IS
ALREADY QUITE UNEQUAL ACROSS
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT Y. AN API INDIVIDUALS
ARE.
FAIRLY WELL REPRESENTED IN TERMS
OF CALIFORNIA BAR EXAM TEST
TAKERS.
BLACK INDIVIDUALS ARE ABOUT EVEN
WITH THE POPULATION AND HISPANIC
INDIVIDUALS.
AS WE SEE IN BASED ON SOME OF
THE HURDLES THAT THEY FACE
PERSONALLY -- SEEM TO FALL QUITE
SHORT IN TERMS OF REPRESENTATION
HERE.
AT BUT THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT
ACT XIN ISN'T NECESSARY ON THE
BAR EXAM AS A WHOLE IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS ISSUES ACROSS VARIOUS
RACES -- SO IF WE LOOK AT THE
BAR EXAM PASSAGE RIGHT ACROSS
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS AT WE CAN SEE
THAT ABOUT 60% OF WHITE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BAR EXAM.
AT PASSED IN THIS IS COMPARED TO
ABOUT 32% OF BLACK INDIVIDUALS
AND IN THE UPPER FORTIES FOR A.
B. I. R. HISPANIC INDIVIDUALS --
AND JUST DEMONSTRATING THAT THE
HISPANIC DEMOGRAPHIC SEEMS.
THERE'S BEEN A DEMOGRAPHIC SEATS
TO SUFFER -- PREDOMINATELY FROM
A LACK OF PARTICIPATION AND WE
CAN SEE THAT A MULTI FACETED
APPROACH IS NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO ENCOMPASS -- SORT OF ALL OF
THESE DIVERSE GROUPS IN TERMS OF
INCREASING REPRESENTATION IN THE
JUDICIAL PROFESSION -- AND THAT
CONSIDERING DIVERSITY SORT OF
MONOLITHIC LEE IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE CORRECT APPROACH.
IT IS ALSO THE CASE THAT WESEE
SOME BOTTLENECKS IN TERMS OF
CAREER ADVANCEMENT AMONG WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THE
LEGAL PROFESSION -- SO WE CAN
SEE THAT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE PERCENTAGE OF ASSOCIATES
WALLETS REMAINED RELATIVELY FLAT
ACROSS AT THE PAST.
DECADE OR SO.
WE CAN NONETHELESS SEE THAT
WHITE MEN COMPRISE A SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF THE POPULATION OF
ASSOCIATES IN THE FIRST PLACE AT
REFLECTING SORT OF THE LACK OF
DIVERSITY IN THE GYM AND THE
LEGISLATIVE.
ART I'M SORRY IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AS A WHOLE -- BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE PERCENTAGE
OF PARTNERS IS DRAMATICALLY
DOMINATED BY WHITE MEN AND WE
CAN SEE THAT THERE'S A SOMEWHAT
NEGLIGIBLE PERCENTAGE OF
PARTNERS THAT THESE LAW FIRMS.
AT AT THE AT THE BOTTOM HERE AB
THAT HAS CHANGED VERY LITTLE
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS -- IT'S
TEMPTING TO ATTRIBUTE THE DEARTH
OF MINORITY PARTNERS TO A LACK
AN IMPENDING DIVERSITY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE
SOME DIVERSITY IMPROVEMENTS THAT.
HAVE NOT YET TAKEN EFFECT AS
PEOPLE CRITICS APPEARANCE AT BUT
THIS EXPLANATION DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE REFLECTED BY THESE DATA AS
YOU CAN SEE THERE'S VERY LITTLE
INCREASE -- IN THESE VARIOUS
RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS FOR
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS AND THIS
IS IN CONTRAST TO WOMEN WHICH
HAVE AT LEAST THAT VERY.
MARGINAL BUT GRADUAL INCREASE
HERE THAT MAY REFLECT SOME
DIVERSITY EFFORTS -- THAT'S NOT
TO SAY THAT WOMEN IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION ARE BEING WELL
REPRESENTED IN TERMS OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF PARTNERS -- SO
THAT VERY GRADUAL INCREASE IN
THE PERCENTAGE OF OF WOMEN
PARTNERS IS NONETHELESS IN THE
CONTEXT OF A MUCH MORE DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN THE PERCENTAGE OF
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE WOMEN IN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION -- AND YOU CAN
SEE A SORT OF COALESCING AND
GENDER IDENTITY -- OF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE WHILE IT
STILL DOESN'T QUITE REFLECT THE
POPULATION AND IT'S AT LEAST
TRAINING IN THE CORRECT
DIRECTION -- BUT THIS
NONETHELESS UNDERSCORE SOME OF
THE OBSTACLES THAT AT WOMEN
ACTUALLY FACE IN TERMS OF CAREER
ADVANCEMENT -- AND THESE
LIMITATIONS AND CAREER
ADVANCEMENT ARE OFTEN ATTRIBUTED
TO THE POSSIBILITY THAT WOMEN
TAKE MATERNAL LEAVE AND
THEREFORE TAKE TIME OUT OF THE
LABOR FORCE.
AT WHICH DOLLARS THEIR CAREER
ADVANCEMENT BUT THE DAY DON'T
SEEM TO SUPPORT THAT SO EVEN
AMONG WOMEN WHO WORK SIMILAR
HOURS AND DON'T TAKE TIME OUT OF
THE LABOR FORCE TO HAVE CHILDREN.
AB THEY'RE STILL ABOUT 40% LESS
LIKELY THAN SIMILARLY SITUATED
MAN TO FIND THEIR WAY INTO THE
POSITION OF A PARTNER.
AND THOSE LIMITATIONS AND LEGAL
CAREER ADVANCEMENT AMONG PEOPLE
OF COLOR AREN'T LIMITED TO
PRIVATE LAW FIRMS AND REACHING
PARTNER BUT ALSO SEEM TO EXTEND
TO THE BENCH -- THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION MADE DIVERSIFYING
THE JUDICIARY A PRIORITY AND
INDEED DID INCREASE DIVERSITY IN
JUDICIAL REPRESENTATION AND YOU
CAN ACTUALLY SEE A LITTLE BIT
HERE THERE'S SOME UP TICK AT THE
COMBINATION OF THAT
ADMINISTRATION AT THE END -- BUT
THESE HAVE LARGELY OVER THE PAST
DECADE AND A HALF.
KEPT PACE WITH BUT NOT EXCEEDED
THE DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA -- AS OF TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
COURTS ARE EXCLUSIVELY WHITE.
TWELVE EXCLUSIVELY MALE AND TEN
CONSIST EXCLUSIVELY OF WHITE
HETEROSEXUAL ABLE BODIED MALES --
SO CLEARLY THERE'S STILL A LONG
WAY TO GO IN TERMS OF INCREASING
THE ACTAL REPRESENTATION OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR ON THE BENCH.
AND ONE THING THAT'S WORTH
NOTING HERE.
SORRY I WILL CLOSE UP QUITE
QUICKLY I ONE THING THAT'S WORTH
NOTING HERE IS THAT BLACK JUDGES
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN
TERMS OF REPRESENTATION MOVING
FROM BEING UNDER REPRESENTED IN
THE POPULATION TO ACTUAL SLIDE
OVER REPRESENTATION -- BUT THIS
DIVERSITY IS EXTREMELY LIMITED
IN TERMS OF GEOGRAPHY WITH ONLY
FORTY ONE OF CALIFORNIANS.
I'M SORRY WITH FORTY ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
TRIAL COURT STILL NOT HAVING A
SINGLE BLACK JURIST -- SO THAT'S
HOW IT'S THAT ALTHOUGH WE'VE
SEEN SOME IMPROVEMENTS IN
GEOGRAPHICALLY LIMITED SCOPES
AND IT'S NECESSARY TO CONTINUE
AND EXPAND THESE DIVERSITY
EFFORTS IN ORDER TO HAVE.
SORT OF A STATE WIDE AB
POPULATION OF JUDGES THAT
REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE AS A WHOLE AND I'LL STOP
THERE IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THANK YOU THIS IS
UNDERSCORES WHY WE LOVE HAVING A
SCIENCE FELLOW.
IN THE COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS KIND OF DATA RESEARCH.
PROFESSOR KARLAN -- THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY.
THE GOALS OF MY REMARKS ARE TWO
FOLD FIRST I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
SOME BROADER CONTEXTUAL FRAMING
FOR EDUCATIONAL INEQUALITY IN
THIS COUNTRY AND IN THE STATE.
WHICH SETS THE STAGE FOR
UNDERSTANDING THE EDUCATIONAL
TRAJECTORIES.
AB AND DISPARITIES IN
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT WE SEE
PRIMARILY BY RACE ETHNICITY BUT
ALSO BY SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE.
AND SECOND I WILL UMMARIZE WHAT
WE KNOW TO BE THE BIGGEST
DETERMINANTS OF EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT AM INCLUDING ACT
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL.
SO FIRST DAY TWO MINUTE I THINK
PRIMER OF EDUCATIONAL EQUALITY.
EDUCATION IS OFTEN VIEWED AS AN
INDIVIDUAL PURSUIT BE HEARD SOME
OF THAT THIS MORNING EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS ARE MARKED.
BY A SERIES OF CHOICES THAT
INDIVIDUALS MAKE THAT SHAPE
THEIR DESTINATIONS HOW MANY
HONORS OR AP CLASSES TO TAKE HOW
MUCH TO STUDY WHERE TO APPLY FOR
COLLEGE WHAT TO MAJOR IN.
AND WHETHER AND WHERE TO PURSUE
GRADUATE STUDY.
AND THIS VIEW PERMEATES OUR
NARRATIVE OF EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
AT THE IDEA THAT IF YOU WORK
HARD AT SCHOOL ANYONE CAN AND
OUT THAT.
PICTURE ELITE SCHOOL OR BECOME A
LAWYER OR FILL IN THE BLANK.
THAT REALITY OF INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE AND SELF DETERMINATION
HOWEVER IS AT BEST MISLEADING.
AND AT TO A VERY LARGE EXTENT
BASICALLY UNTRUE.
IN FACT RESEARCHERS HAVE
REPEATEDLY DOCUMENTED THE WAYS
IN WHICH INDIVIDUAL CHOICES ARE
CONSTRAINED BY MULTIPLE SOCIETAL
FORCES AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT SORT YOUNG
PEOPLE.
AMONG AN EQUAL PATHWAYS OF
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY.
THESE CONSTRAIN CHOICES THAT
TYPIFY OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM FROM
EARLY CHILDHOOD INTO POST
SECONDARY AND PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOLING IN THE U. S..
AND THEY'RE BOTH EXPLICIT
INVISIBLE AS WELL AS MORE HIDDEN
AND LESS VISIBLE BARRIERS.
STUDENTS SCHOOLING EXPERIENCES
IS THE DOMINANT WAYS IN WHICH
EDUCATIONAL PATHWAYS ARE MARKED.
MORE EXPLICITLY SCHOOL QUALITY
AND CURRICULAR DIFFERENCES SORT.
STUDENTS INTO EDUCATIONAL
SETTINGS THAT DIFFER BY
SUBSTANTIVE CONTENT PACE OF
INSTRUCTION PEDAGOGICAL
APPROACHES AND MANY OTHER
RESOURCES.
AND THIS DIFFERENCE IN START
DIFFERENTIATION STARTS WITH
ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL ENVIRONMENTS
WHICH ARE HEARING MORE AND MORE
ABOUT THESE DAYS THAT PROMOTE
SCHOOL READINESS.
GATEKEEPING COURSES IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL YEARS RIGOROUS HIGH
SCHOOL CURRICULA TO FACILITATE
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION INTO POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLING.
AND FINALLY SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF A COLLEGE DEGREE
WITH A COMPETITIVE GPA AND
PREPARATION FOR ADMITTANCE TO A
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL.
AND WE'VE MADE GREAT EFFORTS TO
EQUALIZE SOME OF THIS
DIFFERENTIATION WHEN VISIBLE
STATE FUNDED PRESCHOOL OUR
SCHOOL FUNDING FORMULA.
INCREASED ADVANCED PLACEMENT
OFFERINGS IN SCHOOLS THAT SERVE
AT LARGE PERCENTAGES OF SENSE
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS.
BUT IN MANY CASES ACCESS TO GOOD
INSTRUCTION OR OTHER COLLEGE
PREPARATORY OPPORTUNITIES ARE
LESS VISIBLE THESE INCLUDE
UNEQUAL ACCESS TO SUCH COURSES
WITH IN A SCHOOL.
LESS ENCOURAGEMENT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THOSE COURSES AND
IN GENERAL LACK OF EXPOSURE TO
THE PROFESSIONAL NETWORKS
NECESSARY. TO REACH SOME OF
THESE -- GATEKEEPING AT SPACES.
SO STUDENTS ARE NOT RANDOMLY
PLACED INTO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS BUT RATHER THEIR
PATHWAYS ARE SHAPED YES BY THEIR
INDIVIDUAL DETERMINATION BUT
IMPORTANTLY BY THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THEY ARE EXPOSED.
TO AND THE RESULT IS THAT
EDUCATIONAL PATHWAYS TEND TO
SELF PERPETUATE.
THAT IS QUALITY EARLY SCHOOLING
EXPERIENCES BEGET BETTER
PLACEMENT INTO SECONDARY SCHOOL
DECISIONS.
AND THEN MORE INTENSE ACADEMIC
RIGOR IN HIGH SCHOOL THAT
RESULTS IN MORE SELECTIVE
COLLEGE ADMISSION.
AND GREATER LIKELIHOOD OF DEGREE
ATTAINMENT IT TO BEGIN WITH BUT
ALSO PROFESSIONS FURTHER
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLING OR LABOR
MARKET SUCCESS.
SO THE PRIMARY WAY IN WHICH
EDUCATORS AND POLICYMAKERS HOPE
TO BREAK THIS SELF PERPETUATING
NATURE OF EDUCATIONAL PATHWAYS.
AND IMPROVE MOBILITY BETWEEN
EDUCATIONAL DESTINATIONS IS
THROUGH INCREASED ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
HOWEVER TOO OFTEN WE RELY ON THE
SET OF INPUTS THAT DIRECTLY
REFLECT THAT ACCUMULATED
ADVANTAGES AND DISADVANTAGES
BETTER REFLECTED IN THAT SAT
SCORE OR ELSE OUT SCORE OR THE
SELECTIVITY OF THE UNDERGRADUATE
INSTITUTION.
AND AS A RESULT THE RACIAL
ETHNIC OR SOCIOECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE GAP THAT WE SEE ON
THESE ASSESSMENTS AND HERE I
SPEAK TO STANDARDIZED TESTS IN
PARTICULAR.
ARE SIMPLY HOLDING UP A MIRROR
TO THE INEQUITIES IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND IN SOCIETY
AS A WHOLE.
SO ALTHOUGH HIGHER EDUCATION AND
LEGAL EDUCATION IN THIS CASE MAY
NOT SEE ITSELF AS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THESE THESE INEQUALITIES.
THE ONLY WAY TO REDUCE THESE
INEQUALITIES IS TO EQUALIZE
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES EARLIER
AND STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL CAREERS.
SO WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT
DETERMINES OF EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT.
SUMMARIZING ABROAD AND MULTI
DISCIPLINARY LITERATURE ON
PREDICTORS OF POSTSECONDARY
SUCCESS INCLUDING GRADUATE STUDY
I WOULD SAY THERE ARE THREE MAIN
BUCKETS.
THE FIRST IS ACADEMIC
PREPARATION STUDENTS EXPOSED TO
A MORE ACADEMICALLY RIGOROUS
COURSE OF STUDY ARE BETTER
PREPARED FOR THE DEMANDS OF
COLLEGE AND ARE MORE LIKELY TO
COMPLETE COLLEGE.
AND ARE MORE LIKELY TO GO TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL THIS IMPACTS
GRADUATE STUDY IN SEVERAL WAYS
FIRST IS OBVIOUSLY PREPARATION
FOR LAW SCHOOL OR ANY OTHER
GRADUATE SCHOOL.
WHICH IS OFTEN POORLY UNDERSTOOD
BUT WE PROXY FOR IT BY THE
SELECTIVITY OF THE UNDERGRADUATE
INSTITUTION OUR COLLEGE GPA.
HOWEVER STUDENTS OFTEN ENTER
COLLEGE WITH THIS AN EQUAL
PREPARATION MANY STRUGGLE TO
MAINTAIN A STRONG ENOUGH GPA TO
BE COMPETITIVE FOR LAW SCHOOL.
OR ARE SIMPLY SELF SELECTING OUT
OF GRADUATE STUDY GIVEN THE
CONSISTENT NEGATIVE SIGNALS THEY
GET FROM THE GRADES IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THE SECOND BUCKET IS ON COLLEGE
OR GRADUATE SCHOOL KNOWLEDGE AND
INFORMATION.
THERE ARE A HOST OF
INFORMATIONAL BARRIERS THAT
PRESENT A CHALLENGE TO
HISTORICALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS AND POST SECONDARY
SCHOOLING.
THESE INCLUDE INFORMATION ABOUT
COSTS AND EDUCATION FINANCING
KNOWLEDGE OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
GRADUATE SCHOOL OPTIONS FIELDS
OF STUDY AND APPLICATION
PROCEDURES AND I COULD GO ON NOT --
AND THESE INFORMATION BARRIERS
ARE THE ONES WE HERE WE HEARD
SOME TODAY OUR OUR OUR EFFORTS
AT AT PROGRAMS OF TRYING TO
REMEDY.
FINALLY THE OTHER BUCKET IS KIND
OF SOCIAL PSYCHOLOGICAL FACTORS
IT'S HARD TO DO THIS BROAD AREA
OF JUSTICE.
IT IS BROAD AREA JUSTICE IN A
FEW SENTENCES BUT IN SHORT
NAVIGATING COLLEGE AND GRADUATE
SCHOOL CAN BE HARD.
NO MATTER HOW WELL PREPARED YOU
ARE ACADEMICALLY OR HOW MUCH
INFORMATION YOU HAVE.
AND SCHOLARS FROM ACROSS THE
SOCIAL SCIENCE DISCIPLINES HAVE
DOCUMENTED THE NEED TO CULTIVATE
A SENSE OF RESILIENCE AND SELF
ADVOCACY NECESSARY. FOR CAL FOR
COLLEGE AND GRADUATE SCHOOL
SUCCESS AND WHICH WE KNOW IS
EVEN HARDER FOR STUDENTS WHO MAY
BE THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILIES
TO GO TO COLLEGE OR GRADUATE
SCHOOL HAVE TO WORK WHILE
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL.
OR MAY NOT HAVE THE MANY PEERS
OR MENTORS THAT COME FROM RACIAL
ETHNIC OR SAYS OR SOCIAL
BACKGROUNDS LIKE THEIR OWN.
THESE THREE AREAS ARE OFTEN THE
TARGET OF VARIOUS PIPELINE
PROGRAMS THAT ASSIST
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS FROM
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS.
WITH A HOST OF ACADEMIC SUPPORTS
INCREASED INFORMATION ABOUT OUT
ALL ASPECTS OF GRADUATE STUDY
FROM APPLICATION MEETING HOW TO
MEET WITH A FACULTY MEMBER TO
ASK FOR A LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATION.
AND TO UNDERSTAND THE PROFESSION
MORE GENERALLY.
AND VARIOUS EFFORTS FOR SELF
AFFIRMATION AND SOCIAL BELONG
EXPERIENCES ACT AGAIN ARE HUGELY
CRITICAL -- FOR PARTICULARLY
CERTAIN SUBGROUPS SO IN SOME
HIGHER EDUCATION INCLUDING
GRADUATE STUDY CAN DISREGARD OR
IGNORED WHAT CAME BEFORE WHICH
MAY SEEM PREFERABLE GIVEN THE
COMPLEXITY.
BUT MOST HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING LAW
SCHOOLS FEEL SOME RESPONSIBILITY
TO ADDRESS THESE DEEP INEQUITIES
THAT RESULT IN THE KINDS OF
ADMISSIONS PROFILE THAT THE SEAT.
SO HOW THEY DO SO HAS IMPORTANT
CONSEQUENCES NOT JUST FOR THE
CURRENT STUDENTS BUT FOR MANY
STUDENTS TO CALM.
AND ADMISSION IS ONLY ONE ASPECT
OF THIS EFFORT I'LL BE AN
IMPORTANT ONE BUT SUSTAIN
SUPPORT THROUGH GRADUATE STUDY
IN.
AN INTO THE PROFESSION REQUIRES
EARLIER INVESTMENTS IN ACADEMIC
PREPARATION IN REDUCING
INFORMATIONAL BARRIERS AT IN
CULTIVATING THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
IS INCLUSIVE AND WELCOMING TO
HISTORICALLY IS STARKLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS.
SO WHILE IT IS ALWAYS INSPIRING
FOR ME AS WELL TO HEAR THE
STORIES OF PERSONAL STORIES IN
PARTICULAR.
HAVE THE CURRENT STUDENT KAREN
BUT RAZA -- IT IS TIME THAT WE
MOVE BEYOND JUST THAT THE BEAT
THE ODDS STORY TO COMPLETELY
CHANGE CHANGE THOUGHT SO.
STOP [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GREAT.
WE ARE TO TEAM BUTLER.
PLEASE GOOD MORNING.
SO -- I WAS ACTS TO SPEAK ON
UNDERSTANDING THE SCOPE OF THIS
PROBLEM IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
GRE AND I AM HERE REPRESENTING A
PROJECT AS WELL SO I WANTED TO
SAY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT AND
THEN I'LL GET INTO.
A DISCUSSION BUT I'M PART OF A
OF A OF THREE CAMPUS PROJECT
THAT IS LOOKING AT THE ISSUE
THAT YOU ALL ARE LOOKING AT HERE
IN THE LEGAL EDUCATION IT'S THE
ALLIANCE FOR MULTI CAMPUS
INCLUSIVE GRADUATE ADMISSIONS --
WE CALL IT A MICAH AT UC DAVIS
AS THE LEAD CAMPUS WITH --
PROVOST RALPH TEXTER AS THE PI
IN ONE OF THE DIVERSITY OFFICERS
WITHIN THE GRAD DIVISION JUST OF
THE MONEY AND ALL AS THE CO PI.
AND WE ALSO HAVE PARTNERS AT
UCLA AND USC AND THIS QUESTION
IS HAS A RESIDENT HIGHER
EDUCATION REGARDING STANDARDIZED
TESTING AND THE BEAR YEARS THAT
IT IS CREATING.
FOR DIVERSE STUDENTS ACROSS THE
THE PLANE AND HOW THEY ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS -- HIGHER EDUCATION
WHETHER IT BE GRADUATE SCHOOL
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL AND AND HOW
IMPORTANT OR IMPERATIVE IT IS
THAT OUR PROFESSIONALS.
ARE ACTUALLY.
MATCHING OUR DISTRIBUTION OF
POPULATIONS ACROSS OUR STATE IN
OUR NATION AND SO -- OUR GOAL IN
THE PROJECT IS TO REALLY TRY.
TO FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN MAKE
THAT DISTRIBUTION OF THE
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHEN I SAW THIS TOPIC ONE I
WAS NOT A WEIRD THAT WITHIN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION THE CONTEXT WAS
CHANGING IN THE SENSE THAT THERE
WAS AN AD INTEREST IN
DIVERSIFYING ADMISSIONS.
TO LAW SCHOOL.
IN AN INTEREST TO DIVERSIFY THAT
PROCESS THE GRE THE GRADUATE
RECORD EXAM WAS LOOK TO AS THE
POSSIBILITY TO OFFER THIS --
OPPORTUNITY HOWEVER WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF GRADUATE EDUCATION WE
ARE QUESTIONING THE USE AND DE
EMPHASIZING THE USE OF THE GRE.
SO I WILL APPROACH IT THIS WAY
AND I THINK YOU ALL HAPPENED THE
HAND OUTS HERE I'M I APOLOGIZE
TO THOSE OUT IN THE AUDIENCE BUT
THE PROBLEM HOW CAN WE IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY OF THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AND THE DUDE.
JUDICIARY -- BASICALLY THE
ARGUMENTS THAT I SAW TO BE THE
DRIVING FORCES THAT THE G. R. E.
WHAT X. BAN ACCESS TO LEGAL
EDUCATION THE POOL OF TEST
TAKERS IT'S WITHIN THE JURY ARE
MUCH HIGHER THAN THOSE.
WITHIN THE ELSE THAT.
HOWEVER I WILL SHARE THAT THE
DIVERSE CITY ACROSS IT'S NOT --
ANY MORE DIVERSE ACROSS THE GRE
AND THE JET THE GRE TEST HAS
ALSO BEEN EVALUATED AS BEING
BALLOT AND RELIABLE -- HOWEVER
BIASED -- SO THE DIVERSITY TOOL
THE G. R. E..
TEST TAKERS THERE ARE OVER THREE
TIMES TO FOUR TIMES AS MANY TEST
TAKERS OF THE GRE COMPARED TO
THE L. SAID.
SO I THINK THE ARGUMENT THAT THE
POOL OF APPLICANTS COULD
INCREASE IS BALLOT.
HOWEVER THERE IS A QUESTION
ACROSS THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
POPULATION WHO ARE TAKING THE
TEST AND THEY ALMOST NEAR EACH
OTHER SO WITH IN THE ELSE THAT
YOU HAVE ABOUT 80% OF THE TEST
TAKERS.
WHITE THE SAME EXIST WITH THE G.
R. E. WHEN YOU LOOK AT U. S.
DOMESTIC TEST TAKERS.
THE DISTRIBUTION OF ASIAN.
AMERICANS IS SLIGHTLY INCREASED
IN THE GRE BUT 12214% ONLY 8% IN
THE L. SAT WITH AFRICAN
AMERICANS -- BEING ABOUT THE
SAME DISTRIBUTION 12214% ACROSS
BOTH THE JURY AND THE L. SAT AND
THEN -- LATIN X. MEXICAN%
HISPANIC NON WHITE.
TEST TAKERS ARE SLIGHTLY HIGHER
IN THE L. SAP VERSES THE G. R.
E. WITH ONLY ABOUT. 628% TAKING
THE GRE AND 10% TAKING THE L.
SAT NATIVE AMERICANS ARE ALSO
OVER REPRESENT AND TAKING THE L.
FAT VERSUS TAKING THE GRE WITH
ABOUT 10%.
OF NATIVE AMERICANS TAKING THE
TEST VERSUS 4% [inaudible]
TAKING -- THAT JERRY.
SO I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE IS SOME.
POSSIBILITY OF INCREASING
DIVERSITY HOWEVER I WANT TO
CAUTION WHEN WE SPEAK TO
DIVERSITY IN USING TOOLS. TO DO
THE WORK FOR US BECAUSE OF THEIR
LIMITATIONS AND POSSIBLY -- BUT
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN THE
JURY'S -- SCORES SO THE GRE TEST
REFLECT DISPARITIES AS MY
COLLEAGUE MCCALL HAS MENTIONED
THAT MIRROR BASICALLY THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC -- DIFFERENCES
DIFFERENCES ACROSS RACIAL BOUNDS
OF POVERTY -- GENDER DIFFERENCES
IN AND IT.
HAS NOT BEEN CLEAR OF HOW TO
CORRECT THE DIFFERENCES IN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE GRE TEST AND
SO WE WANT TO CAUTION AS WE'RE
USING THIS TOOL.
IN OUR ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
I HAVE A GRAPHIC THAT I'VE
SHARED JUST SO YOU CAN VISUALLY
SEE IN THOSE WHO HAVE.
THE PACKET THAT BASICALLY IF YOU
JUST LOOK ACROSS THE
DISTRIBUTION WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
IS ASIAN AMERICANS WHITES.
OTHER HISPANIC A MEXICAN AFRICAN
AMERICANS PORTER RICANS THE
NATIVE AMERICANS ARE
DIFFERENTIALLY DISTRIBUTED
ACROSS THE BOARD ON THEIR SCORES
OF THE G. R. E..
N. IF WE HAVE CERTAIN SCORES ARE
CUT OFF THEN HUGE POPULATIONS
ARE DISADVANTAGED AUTOMATICALLY
IF WE'RE USING THE SCORES AS OUR
PRIMARY INDICATOR OF SUCCESS IN
OUR ADMISSIONS PROCESS THE
CONTINUING ALTHOUGH THE JURY
PROVIDES A A LARGER POOL.
OF APPLICANTS FOR LAW SCHOOL THE
DIP TO HIGHLIGHT THE THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE POOR
PERFORMANCE DIFFERENTIALS ACROSS
THE APPLICANTS THE JURY IS ONLY
MODESTLY PREDICTIVE OF STUDENT
SUCCESS.
AND THIS IS REALLY CLEAR EVEN
ETS EDUCATIONAL TESTING SERVICE
ALSO STATES THAT THE JURY ONLY
MODESTLY PREDICTS SUCCESS AND
IT'S TYPICALLY THE FIRST TWO
YEARS OF COURSEWORK. FOR
STUDENTS NOT REALLY PREDICTING
SOME OF THE FACTORS THAT WERE
MOST INTERESTED IN WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT STUDENTS AND THEIR
ABILITIES TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
GRADUATE EDUCATION.
AND PERSIST BEYOND -- GRADUATE
SCHOOL.
I'M GONNA TRY TO GO FASTER HAD
LOTS TO SAY -- IN IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT WE NOTE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED BY SCHOLARS IS THAT.
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SCORES
AND DISTRIBUTION IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONSIDER
CHANGING THE CULTURES WHICH ARE
EVALUATING THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR WORK?
SO.
I THINK THIS KEBAB POSSIBLY BE
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT I CAN SHARE IS THAT NOT
ONLY DO WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
INDICATORS THAT WERE USING WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO PREDICT SUCCESS
IN ADMITTING STUDENTS.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO CONSIDER
TRAINING DEVELOPMENT AS
MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS --
PANEL OF THOSE WHO ARE REVIEWING
OUR STUDENTS AND THOSE WHO SERVE
AS GATEKEEPERS WE NEED TO
ONGOING TRAINING ON IMPLICIT
BIAS ON CULTURAL COMPETENCE ON
DIVERSITY ONGOING TRAINING SO
THAT WE ARE AWARE THAT WHAT WHAT
WE REALLY HAVE FOUND OUT IS YOU
CAN'T ELIMINATE BIAS BECAUSE
WE'RE HUMAN.
BUT WE CAN BECOME MORE AWARE OF
THE BIAS THAT EXIST WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING IT AT APPLICANTS ACROSS
THE RANGE AND DISTRIBUTION AND
SO IN AN EFFORT NOT TO COMPOUND
THESE ISSUES IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT NOT TO USE THE TOOL.
BUT TO EDUCATE OUR PANELS AND
REVIEWERS.
L. FAT FACULTY IN HIGHER ED TO
BE MORE MINDFUL OF WHAT THE WORK
IS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO SO
CREATING MORE ACCOUNTABILITY IN
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT WE
ARE PLACING.
THE BURDEN ON THOSE WHO ARE
SERVING AS GATEKEEPERS TO BE
MINDFUL BEYOND THE TOOLS THAT WE
USE.
AND I'LL STOP THERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DINNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU THE BAR EXAMS
CUT SCORE AND IT'S
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT.
I'M I'M OFTEN ASKED TO SPEAK
ABOUT DIVERSITY IN THE CONTEXT
OF MY WORK ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON
IMPLICIT RACIAL AND GENDER BIAS
AND STEREOTYPE THREAD AND RACIAL
ANXIETY -- AND I MENTION THAT
BECAUSE ALL OF THE RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES THAT DIVERSITY OF
ALL TYPES OF RACIAL DIVERSITY
AND GENDER DIVERSITY RESULTS IN
MORE INNOVATION RESULTS IN MORE
CREATIVITY.
AND THAT IT CAN HELP PEOPLE AND
SYSTEMS TO THRIVE AND THAT'S WHY
DIVERSITY IS SO IMPORTANT WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF THE LEGAL
PROFESSION ITSELF SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE.
THE RESEARCH ALSO DEMONSTRATES
THAT INDIVIDUALS THRIVE WHEN
THEY HAVE A SENSE OF BELONGING
WE'VE HEARD SOME OF THAT ALREADY
THIS MORNING.
AND WHEN THEY CAN SEE PEOPLE
AROUND THEM WHO ARE LIKE THEM
AND AS PEOPLE ON THAT FIRST
PANEL STATED THIS MORNING THEY
WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO BE WHERE
THEY ARE.
AND I WASN'T SUPPOSED TO BE THE
D. IN OF A TOP TWENTY FIVE
SCHOOL HI THERE -- MY MOTHER IS
A KOREAN IMMIGRANTS MY FATHER IS
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MEMBER OF
THE ARMY AND LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE
OF ALREADY SHARED THIS MORNING
THROUGHOUT MY ENTIRE CHILDHOOD.
IF IT WEREN'T FOR MY MOM WHO
WORKED AT OF ROPE FACTORY -- IN
THE NIGHT SHIFT THROUGHOUT MY
ENTIRE HIGH SCHOOL CAREER AND IF
IT WEREN'T FOR MY FATHER ALSO
PROVIDING US WITH EVERY BELIEF
IN THE FACT THAT MY BROTHERS AND
I COULD MAKE IT AND COULD DO IT.
AND IF IT WEREN'T OR ALL OF THE
PEOPLE OF COLOR THE SUCCESSFUL
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THAT SUPPORTED ME THROUGHOUT MY
ENTIRE EDUCATION AND THEN IN LAW
SCHOOL ALL THE WAY TO
ENCOURAGING ME. TO BECOME THE
DEAN OF THIS ONE I WOULD NOT BE
HERE AND I KNOW THAT IT MAKES AN
INCREDIBLE DIFFERENCE TO MY
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY TELL ME
ALL THE TIME.
AND TO MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
LAW PROFESSOR PROFESSION TO SEE
THE TYPE OF DIVERSITY THAT EXIST
AND TO HAVE THIS SENSE OF
BELONGING SO IT IS.
CRITICAL AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR FOR HAVING THIS HEARING TO
REALLY EXAMINE.
THESE ISSUES.
AND SO IN LIGHT OF THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSITY TO THE
LEGAL PROFESSION I JUST WANT TO
BE BLUNT.
IF WE CARE ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION AND I WILL ASSUME
THAT WE DO.
THEN THE CURRENT TO BAR EXAM CUT
SCORES IS SIMPLY UNCONSCIONABLE.
WE HAVE THE SECOND HIGHEST CUT
SCORE IN THE NATION ONLY
DELAWARE IS HIGHER.
NEW YORK'S CUT SCORE IS.
ONE THIRTY THREE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE CUTS SCORE FOR PASSING
THE BAR EXAM IS.
ONE THIRTY FIVE CALIFORNIA'S CUT
SCORE IS.
ONE FORTY FOUR AND WE KNOW
WITHOUT ANY DOUBT THAT ARE
ABNORMALLY HIGH CUT SCORE HAS A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
SO IF OUR CUTS GORE HAD BEEN ONE
THIRTY FIVE WHICH I MENTIONED
ALREADY IS THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
THEN 43% MORE WHITES WOULD HAVE
PASSED THE BAR EXAM IN JULY. 64%
MORE ASIANS WOULD HAVE PASSED
THE BAR EXAM 68% MORE LATIN ACTS
WOULD HAVE PASSED THE BAR EXAM
AND ONE HUNDRED AND 23% MORE
AFRICAN AMERICANS WOULD HAVE
PASSED THE JULY BAR EXAM.
IF OUR CUTS SCORE WHERE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF ONE THIRTY
FIVE AND IF THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAD TAKEN THE BAR IN NEW YORK OR
IN MOST OTHER STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THEY WOULD BE PRACTICING LAW
RIGHT NOW.
INSTEAD BECAUSE OF OUR OUT LIAR
CUT SCORE MANY OF OUR PROMISING
AND TALENTED Là GRADUATES ARE
LOSING THEIR JOBS.
AND INCREASING THEIR DEBT.
SO IT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
ARE ABNORMALLY HIGH CUT SCORE
ADVERSELY IMPACTS THE DIVERSITY
OF THE LEGAL PROFESSION AND IF
WE WERE TO REDUCE THE CUT SCORE.
AT LEAST TO THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
WE WOULD IMMEDIATELY ENSURE THAT
THE LAWYERS ENTERING THE
PROFESSION IN CALIFORNIA COME
CLOSER TO REPRESENTING OUR
POPULATION AND ALSO DIVERSITY OF
STUDENTS WHO GRADUATE FROM OUR
LAW SCHOOLS.
SO WHAT THEN IS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR FAILING TO
REDUCE OUR CUT SCORE.
YOU WOULD IMAGINE THAT THE
JUSTIFICATION WOULD BE A
COMPELLING ONE GIVEN WHAT WE
KNOW IS THE ADVERSE IMPACT ON
THE DIVERSITY OF THE LEGAL
PROFESSION BUT THE ONLY
JUSTIFICATION.
THAT HAS BEEN GIVEN FOR KEEPING
OUR CUTS SCORE ABNORMALLY HIGH
[inaudible]
IS TRADITION.
SO AGAIN TO BE BLUNT IT IS
SHAMEFUL IN MY OPINION TO RETAIN
A CUT SCORE BASED SOLELY ON
TRADITION WHEN WE KNOW THAT A
DRAMATICALLY LIMITS THE
DIVERSITY OF THE LEGAL
PROFESSION.
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO LET'S CONTINUE TO STUDY THE
PROBLEM AS THE BAR SUGGEST THAT
WE SHOULD.
BUT LET'S REDUCE THE CUT SCORE
WHILE WE DO SO.
BECAUSE THE DIVERSITY OF THE
LEGAL PROFESSION IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WE SAY THAT WE CARE ABOUT.
DEPENDS UPON IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JUSTICE LIEU.
WELCOME THANK YOU -- THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN STONE AND MEMBERS AND
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE -- I'M
VERY DELIGHTED.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING I'M GRATEFUL TO ALL OF
YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING THIS --
THIS ISSUE -- CHAIRMAN STONE
LIKE MANY CALIFORNIANS I GREW UP.
IN AN IMMIGRANT FAMILY IN FACT
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THIS IS MY HOMETOWN AND COMING
BACK HERE TODAY.
REMINDS ME OF THE VERY FIRST
LAWYER I'VE EVER MET.
HIS NAME WAS BOB MATSUI.
AND HE WAS MY CONGRESSMAN AT A
TIME WHEN.
THE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES INCLUDED JUST
THREE ASIAN AMERICANS.
WHEN I WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL
BOB SPONSORED ME TO BE A PAGE IN
THE?
US CONGRESS BACK WHEN THERE WERE
SUCH THINGS.
AND FROM HIS MENTORSHIP AN
EXAMPLE I CAME TO REALIZE THAT A
PERSON LIKE ME COULD GROW UP TO
BE A PERSON LIKE HIM.
AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHY
DIVERSITY MATTERS IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION -- I THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BOB MADE IN MY LIFE.
I ALSO THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE THAT A MORE INCLUSIVE
LEGAL PROFESSION MIGHT OF MADE
IN BOB'S LIFE.
YOU SEE IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO
WHEN BOB WAS SIX MONTHS OLD.
HE AND HIS FAMILY WERE FORCIBLY
RELOCATED FROM THEIR HOME IN
SACRAMENTO TO THE INTERNMENT
CAMP.
AT TO A LAKE.
AND THIS STAIN ON OUR NATIONAL
HISTORY HAS MANY CAUSES BUT IS
WORTH ASKING I THINK.
WHETHER COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED
IF MORE PEOPLE LIKE BOB MATSUI
HAD OCCUPIED THE TOP ECHELONS.
OF GOVERNMENT AT THE TIME.
AND THE FACT THAT BOB'S NAME NOW
GRACES THE FEDERAL COURTHOUSE
JUST THREE BLOCKS FROM HERE.
IS A POIGNANT REMINDER OF THIS
LEGACY.
THE ISSUE OF DIVERSITY HAS
ALWAYS BEEN DEEPLY PERSONAL TO
ME AND NEVER MORE SO THAN NOW.
WHEN I WAS APPOINTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IN?
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN I DO NOT
FULLY APPRECIATE HOW UNCOMMON IT
WAS. FOR AN ASIAN AMERICAN TO BE
A JUDGE.
AMONG NEARLY SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
JUDGES IN CALIFORNIA LESS THAN
6% WERE ASIAN AMERICAN AT A TIME.
WHEN ASIAN AMERICANS WERE OVER
13% OF THE STATE POPULATION
TODAY?
NEARLY 8% OF CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ARE ASIAN AMERICAN COMPARED 215%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION.
LESS THAN 11% OF OUR JUDGES ARE
LATINO.
COMPARED 214% OF THE STATE
POPULATION THESE NUMBERS.
ACTUALLY REFLECTS SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS SINCE I JOIN THE BENCH.
BUT THEY'RE STILL A LONG WAY TO
GO.
THE MOST LIKELY PATHWAYS TO THE
BENCH REMAIN AN OBSTACLE COURSE
FOR MANY GROUPS [inaudible]
CONSIDER PROSECUTORS.
A STUDY BY STANFORD LAW SCHOOL
FOUND THAT AMONG CALIFORNIA
PROSECUTORS IN SUPERVISORY
POSITIONS IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN ONLY 9%
WERE ASIAN TEN POINT 8% WERE
LATINO SIX POINT 6% WERE BLACK.
73% OF THE SUPERVISORS IN DA
OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WERE WHITE.
IN A STATE WAS POPULATION IS
LESS THAN 40%.
WHITE.
CONSIDER LAW FIRMS YOU SAW SOME
OF THE DATA EARLIER.
A TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SURVEY OF
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MAJOR
FIRMS BY VAULT IN THE MINORITY
CORPORATE COUNSEL ASSOCIATION.
REPORTED.
THAT 92% OF EQUITY PARTNERS WERE
WHITE AS WERE 89% OF NOT EQUITY
PARTNERS.
ATTRITION RATES AMONG ASIAN
BLACK AND LATINO ASSOCIATES ARE
MUCH HIGHER THAN THOSE AMONG
WHITES.
NOTABLY FORTUNATELY SOME OF THE
FIRM'S DEMONSTRATING LEADERSHIP
ON DIVERSITY ARE RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF
YOUR NEXT PANELISTS HAILING CHEN
WAS RECENTLY APPOINTED THE CO
MANAGING PARTNER OF MUNGER
TOLLES OLSEN.
BUT WE NEED A LOT MORE HAILING
CHANCE IN THE PIPELINE FOR
ADVANCEMENT IN OUR PROFESSION.
OR CONSIDER JUDICIAL CLERKSHIPS
WHICH IS AN EARLY PRESTIGE
MARKER AFTER LAW SCHOOL THE DATA
FROM THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
FOR LAW PLACEMENT SHOW.
THAT ASIAN BLACKS LATINOS
COMPRISED 14% OF FEDERAL LAW
CLERKS IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN EVEN THOUGH
THEY MADE UP 23% OF THE
GRADUATES FROM THE TOP THIRTY
LAW SCHOOLS.
THIS DISPARITIES TROUBLING
BECAUSE A JUDICIAL CLERKSHIP IS
OFTEN EXPERIENCE THAT STIMULATES
INTEREST IN BECOMING A JUDGE.
IN A RECENT MEDIA INTERVIEW I
WAS ASKED TO REFLECT ON MY OWN
PATH TO THE BENCH.
I SAID THAT MUCH OF MY PATH
AROSE.
FROM SHEER LUCK.
LUCK THAT I FOUND CERTAIN
MENTORS LOCK THAT SOME OF THOSE
MENTORS INTERVENED AT CRUCIAL
MOMENTS.
AND OTHERS WERE WILLING TO TAKE
A CHANCE ON ME.
AND I SAID FOR EVERYONE OF ME
WHO HAS HAD GOOD FORTUNE THERE
ARE OTHERS.
WHO ARE TRYING TO NAVIGATE THEIR
CAREERS ON THEIR OWN?
OR FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
YOU KNOW I'M REMINDED OF THE OLD
ADAGE.
THAT OPPORTUNITY IS WHERE LUCK
MEETS PREPARATION.
MUCH OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS TO
REDUCE THE ELEMENT OF LOCK.
SO THAT PREPARATION IS THE MAIN
GATEWAY TO OPPORTUNITY.
IN A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
STUDY THAT I CO AUTHORED WITH
SEVERAL YELLOW STUDENTS.
WE SURVEYED OVER SIX HUNDRED
ASIAN AMERICAN LAWYERS AND ASKED
WHAT OBSTACLES TO ADVANCEMENT
THEY EXPERIENCE.
THE MOST COMMON ANSWER WAS
INADEQUATE ACCESS TO MENTORS AND
CONTACTS.
IN MANY WORKPLACES ACCESS TO
IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIPS IN
NETWORKS.
IS THE TOUGHEST NUT TO CRACK.
BUT THIS CANNOT BE LEFT TO LUCK.
IF WE WANT DIVERSITY AT THE TOP
OF OUR PROFESSION.
WE HAVE TO MAKE INCLUSION AND
INTENTIONAL AND SYSTEMATIC PART
OF WORKPLACE POLICIES AND REWARD
STRUCTURES IT MUST BE BAKED INTO
THE WAY WE DEVELOP TALENT.
AND FACILITATE ADVANCEMENT.
SO CLOSE I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
THIS COMMITTEE FOR SHINING A
SPOTLIGHT ON THIS ISSUE WE NEED
TO DISCUSS IT WE NEED TO MONITOR
IT.
AND WE NEED TO KEEP MEASURING
PROGRESS BECAUSE WHAT GETS
MEASURED GETS MANAGED.
TRANSPARENCY AND AWARENESS ARE
THE PREREQUISITES FOR DEVELOPING
SOLUTIONS AND MOTIVATING ACTION.
SO MY HOPE IS THAT THIS HEARING
WILL BE THE FIRST OF MANY
PERHAPS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
THAT BRINGS SUSTAINED ATTENTION
TO AN ISSUE THAT IS VITAL TO THE
EFFICACY OUR PROFESSION.
AND TO THE WELL BEING OF OUR
SOCIETY AS A WHOLE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND BE PLEASED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
THANK YOU JUST AS A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US.
SEVERAL TIMES THIS NOTION OR
THIS STATEMENT I'M NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE HERE.
AND AND THAT'S JUST FRUSTRATE
TRUE AND I KNOW HOW WE GET THERE
BUT HOW DO WE GET TO THE POINT
WHERE [inaudible]
THAT'S NOT.
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM PEOPLE
ANYMORE AND THIS NOTION OF LOCK
AND OPPORTUNITY?
COMING TOGETHER OR LIKE IN
PREPARATION COMING TOGETHER THAT
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY I THINK
THAT'S GENERALLY TRUE BUT AS
WE'VE HEARD.
THERE ARE GATEKEEPERS ALONG THE
WAY AND THEIR GATES ALONG THE
WAY.
THAT INORDINATELY THE INFLUENCE
[inaudible]
THAT.
OPPORTUNITY THE REGARDLESS OF
PREPARATION AND REGARDLESS OF
LOCK THAT ESSENTIALLY TAKE
LOCKED OUT OF THE EQUATION.
IS WHAT IT SEEMS AND SO THAT
THAT THAT THAT GATE IS IS
ALLOWING SOME THROUGH IT AND NOT
ALLOWING OTHERS THROUGH.
REALLY BASED ON PREPARATION.
SO I WAS I WAS GONNA ASK A
LOADED QUESTION BUT I JUST CAN'T.
BECAUSE IT'S ONE IT'S A QUESTION
THAT COMES UP THAT THAT THAT
MAKES ME CRAZY AND THAT'S THIS
NOTION THAT IF WE DROP THE CUT
SCORE.
IF WE ADDRESS THE LSAT IF WE
ADDRESS THE GRE.
ART WE DUMBING DOWN [inaudible]
THOSE EXAMS [inaudible]
WHEN?
WHICH IS FRUSTRATING VERY
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE LACK OF OPPORTUNITY
IN THE PIPELINE FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
BECAUSE OF EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF DUMBING
DOWN IT'S A MATTER OF REMOVING
AN UNNECESSARY BARRIERS.
SO THAT WE CAN GET MORE
QUALIFIED ATTORNEYS INTO THE
PROFESSION.
WELL FIRST OF ALL.
STUDENTS AT THE LAW SCHOOL.
THEN ATTORNEYS IN THE PROFESSION
AND THEN.
ATTORNEYS.
REPRESENTING DIVERSITY ON TO THE
BATCH SO HOW DO I KNOW YOU
ADDRESS THAT BUT BUT HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THAT KEEPS
COMING UP ABOUT.
DUMBING DOWN AN EXAM SO WHERE.
IT ALMOST SEEMS LIKE WERE
ARTIFICIALLY THEN GIVING
OPPORTUNITIES WERE UP TO OUR
PLEASE DON'T DON'T.
LIE AND I HATE ARTICULATED THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE
HOW DO WE COMBAT THAT NOTION HOW
DO WE MAKE IT VERY CLEAR.
THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
MAKE SURE.
THAT WE GET THE BEST QUALIFIED
PEOPLE INTO THE PROFESSION ON
THE BENCH.
WELL I THINK YOU CHAIR THAT YOU
ASK THE QUESTION AND THEN YOU
YOU ANSWERED IT.
TOO BUT BUT I'LL JUST ADD.
A FEW MORE POINTS AT THE TO THAT
FIRST TO SAY THAT WE FIRST AND
PRIMARILY THE BAR EXAM ITSELF WE
KNOW HAS BEEN OPERATING AS A
BEAR YEAR. TO ENTRY.
MOST PEOPLE MOST STUDENTS PASS
THAT BAR EXAM.
IN THEIR SECOND OR THIRD TIME.
AND SO WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN NOT PASSING IT THE FIRST
TIME IN PASSING AT THE SECOND OR
THIRD TIME IT'S JUST GETTING
BETTER AT MEMORIZATION.
RIGHT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HOW
COMPETENT YOU ARE AS A LAWYER
AND LESS WHAT WE ARE SAYING.
IS THAT MOST STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING NEW YORK THAT
WE OFTEN COMPARE OURSELVES -- TO
THAT NEW YORK HAS LAWYERS WHO
ARE INCOMPETENT THERE ARE NO
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT AT ALL IN ARE
WE SAYING THAT DELAWARE LAWYERS
THEN ARE FAR BETTER THAN
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS BECAUSE THEY
ARE CUT SCORE.
IS HIGHER.
THERE HAS BEEN NO EVIDENCE AT
ALL THAT THE CUT SCORE THAT WE
HAVE ON OUR CURRENT BAR EXAM
SAYS.
ANYTHING.
ABOUT THE INTELLECT OR THE
COMPETENCE OF THE LAWYER'S HERE
IT IS SIMPLY ACTING AS A BARRIER
TO ENTRY.
OTHERWISE HOW DO WE EXPLAIN THE
STUDENTS TO PASS THEIR SECOND OR
THIRD TIME HAVE THEY BECOME
SMARTER.
IN THOSE SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR OR
TWO NO THEY HAVE JUST GOTTEN
BETTER.
AT MEMBERS ATION.
SO I EIGHT CHALLENGE I THINK
SOMEONE ELSE SAID BEFORE I THINK
IT WAS -- ASSEMBLYMAN CHU WHO
SAID THE BURDEN OF PROOF.
RESTS ON THOSE WHO WOULD KEEP
THE CURRENT CUT SCORE AND SO FAR
I THINK THE ONLY EXPLANATION
THAT HAS BEEN GIVEN IS THAT
TRADITION IS WHY WE'VE KEPT THAT
SCORE AND SO WE CARE ABOUT
DIVERSITY.
AND AND WHERE THE LOTS OF
DIVERSE LAWYERS HERE AND BY THE
WAY -- I CAME HERE FROM NEW YORK
AND WASHINGTON STATE I TOOK BOTH
OF THOSE BAR EXAMS AND THEN I
TOOK CALIFORNIA BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT I'M A SMARTER OR MORE
COMPETENT LAWYER.
BECAUSE I TOOK THE THREE DAY
CALIFORNIA BAR EXAM THAN I WAS
WHEN I TOOK THE WASHINGTON STATE
AND THE NEW YORK BAR EXAM.
IT IN FOR THE PROFESSION OR FOR
THE EDUCATIONAL PROFESSORS HERE
AS WELL INTERESTING THAT YOU'RE
SEEING THAT SAME PHENOMENON IT
IN THE GRE.
AND PERCENT OF THE THE THE LSAT.
SO IS THIS.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY FOR HOW WE'VE
USED?
TESTING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF DECADES.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THAT WE'VE HAD IN.
WE'VE HAD AN ARTIFICIAL OVER
RELIANCE ON A SCHOOL BOARD THAT
WE HAVE PRESUMED IN PREVIOUS
YEARS WAS PREDICTING SUCCESS ARE.
I KNOW WITHIN HIGHER ED FACULTY
SOMETIMES LOOK AT HIGHER JUROR
YOU SCORES AND MISTAKENLY ASSUME
THAT STUDENTS WHO SCORE HIGHER
OR MORE EQUIPPED ARE BETTER
QUALIFIED AND IT ISN'T THE CASE
BECAUSE WE STARTED TO DO.
DATA ANALYSIS TO SHOW THAT AND
SO I THINK WHAT IT'S SAYING IS
THAT WE HAVE INCORRECTLY USED A
MEASUREMENT THAT WE THOUGHT WAS
PREDICTING.
BETTER -- PERFORMANCE THAT
WASN'T AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
TRIED TO SHARE WITH -- FACULTY
AT LEAST AT UC DAVIS AND UCLA
WHERE WE'RE DOING OUR PROJECT IS
THAT.
WHAT IS IT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET ATIS EXCELLENCE?
AND WE WANT QUALITY WHAT WE HAVE
DONE HOWEVER IT IS USED TO TOLL.
AND MADE IT MEAN EXCELLENT ANY
QUIRK AND AND AND QUALITY BUT IT
DOES NOT AND SO IT IS IMPORTANT
IN ANY ENDEAVOR IF YOU'RE USING
INDICATORS OR CRITERIA THAT
YOU'RE ASSUMING LEADS TO A
CERTAIN OUTCOME TO REEVALUATE.
WHERE EDUCATORS THAT'S WHAT WE
DO WE ASK QUESTIONS WE CHALLENGE
AND WE REVISIT PREVIOUS
ASSUMPTIONS AND CHALLENGE THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS SO THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE?
BUT WE IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE I
THINK WE GOT A LITTLE LAZY.
AND AND AND AND RELUCTANT TO
MOVE INTO AND EVEN WITHIN HIRE
AT THE CUT OFF SCORES CLEARLY
SHOW.
THAT LARGE PORTIONS OF
POPULATIONS ARE NOT EVEN.
ABLE TO ENTER INTO THE THE
COMPETING PROCESS FOR POSITIONS
IN GRAD SCHOOL AND SO FORTH AND
SO REALLY CHALLENGING THOSE
INDICATORS AS NOT EVEN BEING
ABLE TO PREDICT THE SUCCESS.
BUT IT DOES REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
WORK IT DOES REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
TRAINING IT DOES REQUIRE THAT.
THOSE WHO ARE GATEKEEPERS OUR
REVIEWERS THAT THEY ARE WILLING
TO PUT IN THE EFFORT TO REVIEW --
CRITERIA AND CHARACTERISTICS
ABOUT THOSE WHO ARE ENTERING THE
PROFESSION AND AND BEING A PART
OF DISCUSSIONS LIKE THIS ONE TO
SAY WHAT IS IT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR WHAT DO WE NEED TO
DO TO MOVE FORWARD SO JUST.
CHANGING THE THE CUT OFF SCORE
IN THE ELSE THAT WON'T CHANGE
SOME OF THE DATA THAT LANDON
SHARED SO THERE'S ADDITIONAL
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE SO.
MAKING SURE YOU'RE INVESTED AND
MAKING SURE PEOPLE ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO MOVING FORWARD
AND REALLY REFLECTING THE
DIVERSE CITY THAT EXIST IN OUR
POPULATION.
WHEN I WAS I STARTED MY CLICK
OCCUR ON THE SCHOOL BOARD AND
THIS IS?
LATE NINETIES EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THAT.
I LEARNED VERY QUICKLY THAT WAS
FRUSTRATING.
WHERE THE STANDARDIZED TESTING?
AND WE KEPT ARTICULATING.
POLICY SACRAMENTO AROUND
MULTIPLE MEASURES FOR FOR
TESTING KIDS AND IT JUST SEEMS.
THAT THOSE STANDARDIZED TESTS
WERE USED WHEN THEY WERE HIRED
BY REALTORS TO SELL HOUSES BY
SCHOOLS TO BE TO COLLECT EIGHTY
A OR THE STATE TO PUNISH.
LOW PERFORMING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BUT DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE INDIVIDUAL.
ADVANCE BETTER CAPABILITY OF THE
STUDENTS AND SO THIS THIS
PROBLEM SEEMS TO GO ALL THE WAY
BACK THERE TO HOW WE
FUNDAMENTALLY USE.
I THINK INCORRECTLY.
THE STANDARDIZED TESTS AND WHAT
THEIR FOR THEIR NOT.
A BETTER SYSTEM I ALWAYS THOUGHT
WOULD BE ONE THAT TRACKED THE
STUDENTS PROGRESS THAT WAS USED
BY THE TEACHER YEAR TO YEAR TO
YEAR TO UNDERSTAND.
CHALLENGE THAT THAT CHILD HAD
WEAKNESSES IN THE EDUCATION SO
THAT YOU COULD MORE TAYLOR THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM. TO THAT OR THE
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE TO THAT
CHILD'S NEEDS AS OPPOSED TO JUST
RATING A SCHOOL OR NOT.
AND THAT SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
WHAT I'M HEARING.
NOW AT THE GRADUATE LEVEL WITH
THE HOURS A. T. OF THE GRE AND
THAT CERTAINLY WE WE ARE VERY
WHERE IN.
MY HAND THAT I I ALSO INCLUDED
THE IN CAT BECAUSE THEY ALSO
BEEN ENTERED THIS ENDEAVOR AS
WELL.
OKAY SO WE HAVE WE'RE WE'RE JUST
LOOK AT THE LEGAL PROFESSION BUT
CLEARLY WE HAVE.
A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT FOR
CALIFORNIA AND HOW WE RATE.
STUDENTS KIDS MOVING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM BUT THEN WHO WERE
WELCOMING INTO THE PROFESSIONAL
RANKS I IMAGINE DIVERSITY IS A
CHALLENGE IN ALL OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL RIGHTS I THINK THAT.
YES DIVERSITY HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING AND I THINK IF WE
ARE AIMING TO BE MORE EQUITABLE
AND INCLUSIVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK ACROSS A
RANGE OF FACTORS IN SO.
IT AS WE'RE HAVING THESE
DISCUSSIONS IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE
RANGE OF FACTORS ARE THAT.
LEAD US TO IDENTIFY CAPABLE AND
STUDENTS WHO ARE ABLE TO PROCEED
THROUGH THE PROCESS WHETHER IT
BE GRADUATE SCHOOL.
LAW SCHOOL MEDICAL SCHOOL BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO LOOK AT
THESE FACTORS AND NOT -- BE LAZY.
PROFESSOR CALENDAR BECAUSE
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT MORE THE
EARLY PART OF THE PIPE YEAH BUT
I WAS TO WEAR OUT THAT -- THESE
TESTS -- THERE A LOT OF TIMES WE
TAKE THEM AND ARE ON THEIR OWN
BUT IN FACT AT LEAST UP YOU KNOW
THROUGH COLLEGE WE KNOW THAT
HIGH SCHOOL GPA CONTINUES TO BE.
A BETTER PREDICTOR FOR MOST FOR
ENTRANCE AND AND THAT THAT
COLLEGE BOARD VALIDATES ITS
TESTS ABOVE AND BEYOND HIGH
SCHOOL GPA WHAT DOES IT OFFER
AND OFFERS VERY LITTLE AND OFFER
SOME WHICH IS WHY WE CONTINUE TO
USE THAT.
BUT OFFERS VERY LITTLE ABOVE AND
BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL GPA AND WE
KNOW THAT IT IS.
WHEN WE SEE AGAIN AS EVER?
AS I SAID IN MY REMARKS THAT
LEADS -- TO OF THE TEST ITSELF
IS NOT BIASED IT IS AT IT IS
BOTH DEMONSTRATING.
REVEALED -- EDUCATION EXPOSURE
TO YOU KNOW REAL DIFFERENCES IN
THE CLASSROOM BUT ALSO A HOST OF
OTHER DISADVANTAGES AND
ADVANTAGES THAT STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN IN TAKING THESE TESTS.
AS WE HEARD THIS MORNING
EVERYTHING FROM AN ADDITIONAL
PREP COURSE NETWORKS AT TEST
TAKING STRATEGIES AND SO WHAT WE
SHOULD JUST KEEP IN MIND AS AS
YOU SAID MULTIPLE MEASURES ALLOW
STUDENTS TO DEMONSTRATE THEIR
ABILITIES TO DO THE WORK AND IN
DIFFERENT WAYS SOME OF WHICH IS.
REPRESENTED BY TESTS AND OTHERS.
WELL I TAKES MY WORK IS
REPRESENTED BY PRIOR ACADEMIC
HISTORY BACKGROUND AND I THINK
LAW SCHOOLS AND AND OTHER
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS ARE USING
THAT MORE AND MORE BUT WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE THE SHORT CUT
UP.
A TEST THAT CONTINUES TO SORT OF
SHOW IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES BY
SOCIAL BACKGROUND BY RACE
ETHNICITY BUT BUT IT IN YOU SAID
BUT THAT THE TEST ISN'T BIAS
DOESN'T THAT MAKE THE TEST WELL
THAT'S SEC WITH THAT THAT IS
THAT IS THE ULTIMATE QUESTION
RIGHT SO IT.
AS LONG AS IT DEMONSTRATES I
THINK WHAT WE FORGET IS THAT --
IT IF IT IS DEMONSTRATING THAT
SORT OF DEEP INEQUITIES THAT
FROM EARLY ON ALL THEN THE IN AN
INHERENTLY DOES THE MEASURE.
BECAUSE THE ACTUAL ITEM IS NOT
BY IS WE'RE NOT ASKING STUDENTS
TO REFLECT ON YACHTS ARE THINGS
THAT THEY MAY NOT EXPERIENCE ANY
MORE A SPORT THAT THEY'VE NEVER
HEARD OF DEBT HAS REDUCED THE
ITEM BIAS THAT WE SEE YES TESTS
TODAY LOOK MUCH DIFFERENT
THEY'RE MUCH MORE CHEESEMAN.
ORIENTED OPTED TO THAN THAN THEY
USED TO BE -- THESE THESE
PARTICULAR THESE THESE THAT'S AS
IT USED TO BE MUCH MORE OF AN IQ
TEST THAN IT THAN AN ACHIEVEMENT
TESTS.
NEVER THE LESS IT IS STILL
CAPTURING.
BOTH REAL ACHIEVEMENT
DIFFERENCES AND MANY THAT AS I
SAID ARE.
YOU KNOW CORRELATED WITH LOTS OF
STRUCTURAL INEQUALITY THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR SCHOOLING SYSTEM AND
SO WE CAN'T TAKE THAT AWAY FROM
THE TEST SO.
THE TEST IS -- YOU KNOW IT'S
JUST ONE MARKER AS IS MANY MANY
OTHER MARKERS IT'S JUST THAT
WHEN WE CONTINUE TO USE THAT TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT KATE TWELVE
TESTING IN SCHOOL.
I I BELIEVE WE DO NEED THOSE
TEST BECAUSE THEY CONTINUE TO
SHOW US THE SCHOOLS WHERE WE
NEED TO INVEST MORE RESOURCES TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS.
ARE IN FACT GETTING ACCESS TO
GOOD CONTENT CURRICULUM THAT
ALLOW THEM TO SO I NEW TESTS
WHICH ARE MUCH MORE RIGOROUS
THAN THEY USED TO BE OUR COMMON
CORE.
SMART BOUNCE TESTS ARE VERY MUCH
REFLECTING CAN AGAIN THERE IT'S
NOT JUST THE SAT THERE'S LESS
RACIAL ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN.
IN -- OUR STATE TEST AND THERE
ARE AND ON COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
TESTS BUT THEY STILL REFLECT A
LONG WAY TO GO IN TERMS OF
REDUCING TIME DIFFERENCES BY
RACE AND SOCIOECONOMIC BACK TO
DO BUT BUT ACCESS TO THE PREP
COURSES.
FOR THE WAY THAT A PARTICULAR
SCHOOL IS IS ADDRESSING THOSE
KIDS NEEDS GETTING THEM READY.
TO TO BE ABLE TO PERFORM THAT
TEST.
AND THEN BUT WE SEEN SO MANY
KIDS WHO ARE GOOD TEST TAKERS SO
MANY KIDS WHO ARE NOT GOOD TEST
TAKERS.
JUSTICE MARK JUST AS CAPABLE.
BUT ONE WILL PERFORM BETTER
BECAUSE IN THAT ENVIRONMENT
THEY'RE BETTER.
AND THAT BUT THAT DOESN'T GIVE
US THE RESULT.
THAT WERE LOOKING FOR ULTIMATELY
IF WE'RE GOING TO SAY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SOMEONE WHO
WILL BE A IN AN ETHICAL
UPSTANDING HIGH QUALITY ATTORNEY
WHICH IS BACK TO THE QUESTION
THAT WOULD THAT WE'RE ASKING
HERE.
WE ALSO HAVE HIS BILL LOTS OF
SOCIAL SCIENCE EVIDENCE I THINK
BUT THAT AT THAT -- YOU KNOW
STEREOTYPE THREAT OTHER THAT
PERFORMANCE ON THE TASK AT THE
HIGH STAKES YEAH -- IS AGAIN --
IMPACTS AND GROUPS WHO ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED IN IN PERFECT
IN CERTAIN PROFESSIONS OUR IN IN --
HIGH STAKES -- SITUATIONS WOMEN
AND MATH TESTS -- UNREPRESENTED --
MINORITIES IN A HIGH STAKES
TESTS VERSES A LOS AT LOWER
STAKES TESTS ON UNDER PERFORM
FROM MY OWN RESEARCH WE SAW THAT
EVEN ON THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL EXIT EXAM.
THAT SIMILARLY PERFORMING
STUDENTS WHEN THE TEST WITH A
HIGH STAKES TEST WE SOUGHT
SIMILARLY ABLE STUDENTS UNDER
PERFORMING PARTICULARLY UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY GROUPS AND
DIVERSITY IS CONNECTED TO THAT.
PHENOMENON OF STEREOTYPE THREAT
NO.
OKAY OF I THINK WE NEED TO MOVE
ON THE NEXT PANEL JUST IN IN IN
ORDER OF TIME BUT WE SEE INTO
YOUR POINTS HAS THE FLU.
THIS IS A MUCH LONGER
CONVERSATION AND THERE'S A LOT
MORE.
INFORMATION WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
GATHER AND FACE.
AND BE WILLING TO FACE AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT COMES THROUGH AND JUSTICE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
WERE REALLY OUGHT TO THE USE OF
THE TIME. TO COME AND JOIN US
AND I THINK WE'VE GOT IT IF YOU
JUST THERE'S A LOOK THROUGH THE
LIST OF PEOPLE AND AND THE FOLKS
WHO ARE COMING.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE SET OF
PANELS AND INDIVIDUALS HERE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESENTING AND I WILL.
CHALLENGE YOU ALL AS WELL AS
OTHER PANELISTS KEEP US
ACCOUNTABLE KEEP US ASKING THE
QUESTIONS AND WORKING ON THESE
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE IN FACT.
LISTENING LEARNING.
AND MAKING PROGRESS SO ANY OTHER
IDEAS YOU HAVE AS YOU CONTINUE
ON THE WORK THAT YOU ARE WERE
VERY VERY OPEN TO THAT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT TO OUR THIRD PANEL.
EXISTING EFFORTS TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY WHAT MORE CAN BE DONE.
WE HAVE CHRISTOPHER.
PUT ON BY AN AND I'M SORRY IF I
DON'T DO YOUR NAME VERY WELL
THERE.
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF CHANGE
LAWYERS?
HAILING CHAD PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED TRUSTEES STATE BAR OF
CALIFORNIA MITCH WINICK.
DEAN OF THE MODERATE COLLEGE OF
LAW.
JUDGE FUJI FROM LOS ANGELES
WHO'S THE THE FROM THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT.
AND THEN JUDGE BRAZIL.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON PROVIDING
ACCESS AND FAIRNESS.
SO PLEASE COME FORWARD AND WE
WILL GO THROUGH IN THAT ORDER.
MR PEROT BY AT YET EVEN CLOSE
YES VERY GOOD OKAY YEAH I KNOW
BY PRESSING THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAMPION STONE AND
MEMBERS AND STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS CHRIS PUT ON BUYING
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA CHANGE LAWYERS OUR
MISSION IS TO BUILD A BETTER
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
WE BELIEVE THAT LAWYERS ARE
CHANGE MAKERS AND WE EXISTS TO
HARNESS THE POWER OF LAWYERS FOR
JUSTICE IN TO INVEST IN THE NEXT
GENERATION.
OF LEADERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
OF INCREASING DIVERSITY IN THE
PROFESSION.
ALBERT EINSTEIN ONCE FAMOUSLY
SAID WE CANNOT SOLVE PROBLEMS
WITH THE SAME THINKING WE USED
WHEN WE CREATED THEM.
I LIKE THIS QUOTE BECAUSE IT
INVITES US TO APPROACH
INTRACTABLE PROBLEMS WITHIN
ENTIRELY FRESH MINDSET.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO RE FRAME
THE ISSUES BEFORE US TODAY
BECAUSE WHAT'S AT STAKE IS MORE
THAN JUST A LACK OF
REPRESENTATION.
IT'S THE CURRENT INABILITY OF
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM TO SERVE ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN THE SAME MANNER.
IN WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
FAIRNESS.
IN OUR COUNTRY TODAY THERE IS A
GROWING LACK OF TRUST IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS.
IN MANY WAYS THIS HAS ALREADY
BEEN THE CASE FOR CAP FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND YES
EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
CONTEXT THERE'S A DEEP LACK OF
CONFIDENCE THAT THE SYSTEM WILL
TREAT ALL DEFENDANTS FAIRLY.
THIS IS COMPOUNDED BY THE FACT
THAT NATIONALLY 95% OF
PROSECUTORS ARE WHITE.
AND OVERALL 67% OF OUR
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ARE WHITE.
VIEW THESE FACTS IN LIGHT OF THE
REALITY THAT 75% OF INCARCERATED
MEN IN CALIFORNIA ARE MEN OF
COLOR.
THE FACT THAT BLACK BROWN AND
BLACK CALIFORNIANS ARE OVER
PUNISHED IS NOT COINCIDENTAL.
THIS LACK OF EQUAL JUSTICE WILL
NOT BE REMEDIED SOLELY BY
INCREASING DIVERSITY IN THE
PROFESSION.
BUT IT IS UNDENIABLE THAT
INCREASING DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION IN THE LAW IS A
POWERFUL PLACE TO START.
AS HAS ALREADY BEEN TESTIFIED
TODAY PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN IN
OTHER DIVERSE CALIFORNIANS DO
NOT FEEL A SENSE OF BELONGING IN
THE LAW.
IT'S THAT FEELING WHEN YOU WALK
INTO A ROOM AND YOU'RE THE ONLY
PERSON OF YOUR RACE GENDER
IDENTITY OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
AND YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE NOT ON
THE SAME PLAYING FIELD.
YOU CAN'T LIVE UP TO YOUR FULL
POTENTIAL AS A LAWYER.
OR FRANKLY AS A HUMAN BEING.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MORE
THAN JUST THE FEELING.
THIS LACK OF BELONGING IT'S
BACKED BY HARD STATISTICS ABOUT
THE BARRIERS FACING PEOPLE OF
COLOR ENTERING THE PROFESSION
STAYING IN THE PRACTICE.
AND DESCENDING TO POSITIONS OF
INFLUENCE.
THE REALITY IS THAT DIVERSITY
ATTORNEYS ARE MUCH LESS LIKELY
TO RISE TO POSITION POWERFUL
POSITIONS IN THE LEGAL SYSTEM.
SUCH AS JUDGES FIRM PARTNERS OR
NON PROFIT EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS.
THOSE WHO DO SO UP OVERCOME
TREMENDOUS ODDS BUT THE NUMBERS
ARE STILL FAR TOO LOW GIVEN THIS
DAY AND AGE AND THE PACE OF
PROGRESS IS FAR TOO SLOW.
YESTERDAY I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE A GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
SPEAK AT AN EVENT FOR ASIAN
AMERICAN HISTORY MOUNTAIN HE
SAID.
YOU CAN'T BE WHAT YOU CAN'T SEE.
SO WHAT CAN BE DONE.
CALIFORNIA CHANGE LAWYERS AS ONE
OF JUST A HANDFUL OF STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMS STEMMING
FROM A LACK OF DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION IN THE LAW.
WE EMPOWER A NEW GENERATION OF
CHANGE MAKERS.
WE HAVE CREATED A COMMUNITY
WHERE FIRST GENERATION LOS
STUDENTS AND LAWYERS FIND A
SENSE OF BELONGING.
WHERE THEY KNOW WE ARE COMMITTED
TO THEIR SUCCESS?
WE KNOW THAT THEY CAN BECOME THE
NEXT SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
THE NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL OR THE
NEXT SENATOR. TO LAUNCH THE
CAREERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS WE PROVIDE GRANTS TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
LEVEL. TO INCREASE EXPOSURE FOR
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES TO
THE PROFESSION.
WE PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIPS TO HELP
DEFRAY THE STAGGERING COST OF
LAW SCHOOL AND SCHOLARSHIPS TO
THREE ELVES WHO ARE TAKING THE
BARK TO PAY FOR PARKS FENCES.
WE PROVIDE PUBLIC INTEREST
FELLOWSHIPS TO PAY FOR SUMMER YA
SUMMER LONG OR YEAR LONG JOBS IN
LEGAL AID.
WE PROVIDE TRAININGS ON IMPOSTER
SYNDROME AND BAR PASSAGE ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND ACCESS TO
MENTORS AND NETWORKS.
AND WE'RE ALSO BEGINNING TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON
INCREASING ACCESS TO PRESTIGIOUS
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW CLERKSHIPS.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE THAT WHEN I WAS A LAW
STUDENT.
OF MANY YEARS AGO I RECEIVED A
SCHOLARSHIP FROM CALIFORNIA
CHANGE LAWYERS.
AND INVALIDATED IN ME THE BELIEF
THAT I COULD BECOME A LEADER IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT I'VE
MADE IT AND I'M PAYING IT
FORWARD -- FOR FUTURE SCHOLARS
AND LEADERS FOR OUR STATE.
IN SPITE OF OUR SUPPORT THERE IS
ONE ISSUE THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
RAISED AND THAT OUR SCHOLARS
TELL US IS A MAJOR CONCERN FOR
THEM WHICH IS.
THE RACIAL DISPARITY IN THE
RATES OF BAR PASSAGE.
IMAGINE YOU'RE THE FIRST IN YOUR
FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE AND THEN
CONTINUE ON TO LAW SCHOOL.
YOU HAVE AMASSED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
EDUCATIONAL DAT.
YOU HAVE FACED EXCLUSION LAW
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF YOUR IDENTITY
BUT YOU HAVE NONETHELESS
GRADUATED AND NOW THE ONE THING
STANDING BETWEEN YOU AND
PRACTICING LAW IS THE BAR EXAM.
THE PRESSURE TO SUCCEED IS
SIMPLY ENORMOUS.
WHILE BAR PASSAGE RATES ARE
HISTORICALLY LOW FOR ALL EXAM
TAKERS THE REALITY IS THAT IF
YOU ARE BLACK OR BROWN.
YOU ARE MORE LIKELY TO FAIL THE
EXAM THEN IF YOUR WHITE.
THIS HAS TO CHANGE PARTICULARLY
SINCE PAST EFFORTS TO REMEDIATE
THE ISSUE.
IN ANY SIGNIFICANT MATTER HAVE
NOT BEEN FRUITFUL.
A CHANGE LAWYERS WE BELIEVE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE CLOSEST TO THE
PROBLEM ARE ALSO THE ONES
CLOSEST TO THE SOLUTION.
WHETHER ON THE ISSUE OF BAR
PASSAGE CAREER PATHWAYS OR IN
ACHIEVING EQUAL JUSTICE.
OUR LEGAL COMMUNITY WILL NEVER
MOVE FORWARD ON THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES IF WE DO NOT CREATE
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LAWYERS OF COLOR.
LGBT LAWYERS WOMEN LAWYERS
LAWYERS WITH DISABILITIES TO BE
HEARD AND HAVE THE POWER TO
CHANGE THE STATUS QUO.
IN ORDER TO RADICALLY XCELERATED
PACE OF CHANGE WE NEED TO HAVE
LAWYERS WHO LOOK LIKE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE SEATS OF POWER IN ALL OUR
LEGAL INSTITUTIONS.
WE IN CALIFORNIA ARE SHINING
BEACON ON SO MANY ISSUES FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
WE STAND FOR THE PROMISE THAT
YES A MULTI RACIAL DEMOCRACY
WITH LEGAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
SERVE ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH
DIGNITY.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
WE ARE INVITED BY OUR VERY OWN
US CONSTITUTION TO FORM A MORE
PERFECT UNION.
AND YET WE HAVE STILL NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE CORE
ISSUES THAT PREVENT LAWYERS FROM
ALL OUR COMMUNITIES.
FROM REALIZING THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL IN THE WORKPLACE AND%
FOR SOCIETY.
THE TIME IS NOW FOR US TO
RETHINK OUR APPROACH.
REBUILD TRUST IN OUR LEGAL
INSTITUTIONS AN INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL CREATE
LASTING CHANGE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER BUCKET MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY -- MY NAME IS
HELEN CHEN AS JUSTICE WE WILL
LEAD TO EARLIER -- I AM THE CO
MANAGING PARTNER OF MUNGER
TOLLES OLSON.
A LAW FIRM BASED IN LOS ANGELES
WITH OFFICES IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND DC AS WELL -- DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME.
I AM A FIRST GENERATION AMERICAN.
THE CHILD OF IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME
HERE SHORTLY AFTER THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT WAS REPEALED.
I AM THE FIRST PERSON IN MY
FAMILY TO BE A LAWYER.
WHEN I STARTED AT THE LAW FIRM I
WAS A SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN?
I AM NOW ONE OF THE FEW WOMEN
LITIGATION PARTNERS IN MY FIRM
OUR NUMBERS ARE INCREASING BUT
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
AND IN LOS ANGELES I AM THE ONLY
WOMAN LITIGATION PARTNER WHO IS
NOT WHITE.
I AM A MEMBER OF THE STATE BAR
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO SHARE SOME THE
EXCITING WORK THAT WE'VE DONE IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS PART OF
OUR NEW MANDATE -- AS PART OF
THE CHANGE THAT WAS SHEPHERDED
THROUGH BY THIS LEGISLATURE --
TO RE FRAME OUR MISSION AND WE
ARE THE LARGEST A BAR IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND WE HAVE NOT UNTIL LAST YEAR
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT
THAT WE GET TO TOUCH.
EVERY SINGLE ATTORNEY EVERY YEAR
AT LEAST ONCE A YEAR RIGHT WHEN
WE ASK THEM TO PAY THEIR FEES.
WE GET THAT ONE TOUCH I'M AND IS
MISTER LEVER ON THE FIRST PANEL
NOTED WE HAVEN'T COLLECTED DATA
UNTIL NOW BUT WE STARTED DOING
SO IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE
LAUNCHED THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
DATA COLLECTION EFFORT.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
ATTORNEYS RESPONDED.
AND THIS IS OUR FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO YOU
THE RESULTS OF THAT REVISED
STATE AT I'M.
I'M EXCITED IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE THIS ALLOWS US TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH DATA INFORM
STRATEGIES.
UP UNTIL NOW MOST OF OUR WORK
HAS BEEN BASED ON ANECDOTE WHAT
ARE PEOPLE SAYING IN THE
PROFESSION.
BUT NOW WE HAVE CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC DATA.
ADAM AND IF YOU I THINK WITH
PASSED OUT COPIES OF OUR FLIGHTS.
IF YOU TURN TO THE AM FIRST
SLIDE AFTER THE COVER.
THIS REALLY SHOWS IN A NUTSHELL
THE RESULT OF HIS DATA
COLLECTION.
AND HOW ARE ATTORNEY POPULATION
LOOKS.
IN COMPARISON TO THE POPULATION
AT LARGE.
ATTORNEYS IN CALIFORNIA ARE MUCH
LESS DIVERSE THAN THE STATE AS A
WHOLE AND IN PARTICULAR LATINOS
ARE PARTICULARLY UNDER
REPRESENTED.
IF YOU SEE THAT WHILE THE STATE
POPULATION OF 35% LATINO ONLY 6%
OF ATTORNEYS.
ARE LATINA.
HE TURNED TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
THE SAME A SIMILAR DISPROPORTION.
YOU SEE AMONGST WOMEN AND MEN SO
EVEN THOUGH WOMEN MAKE UP ABOUT
50% POPULATION THEY REPRESENT
ONLY 42% OF THE ATTORNEY
POPULATION.
WE ALSO COLLECTED DATA ON
ATTORNEYS A DISABILITIES AND
LGBT ATTORNEYS.
OF THE ATTORNEYS WHO REPORTED
FOUR POINT 8% REPORTED
DISABILITY.
AN EIGHT POINT FOUR REPORTED AS
LGBTQ.
SO THE BOARD REALLY LOOK AT WHAT
IS THE ROLE OF THE STATE BAR
WITH RESPECT TO DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION.
AND IF YOU TURN TO THE NEXT
SLIDE YOU'LL SEE THAT
HISTORICALLY THE STATE BAR
PARTICULARLY THROUGH THE WORK OF
THE COUNCIL ON ACCESS.
AND FAIRNESS.
LOOKED AT MADE PIPELINE AND
JUDICIAL DIVERSITY ACTIVITIES.
WITH THIS NEW STATUTORY MISSION
OF THE STATE BAR THE BOARD TOOK
A NEW LOOK AT ITS DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION EFFORTS.
AND IT HELD A DIVERSITY SUMMIT.
IN AUGUST OF LAST YEAR AND IT
WAS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND REALLY
CONVENING A STATEWIDE SUMMIT OF
AFFINITY BAR GROUPS LOCAL BARS.
AND WE ASK THEM WHICH OF THE
STATE BAR BE DOING.
THE RESULT OF THAT SUMMIT
INFORMED OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BOARD STRATEGIC
PLANNING SESSION.
AND COMING OUT OF THAT THE MOST
COMMON REFRAIN WE HEARD WAYS WE
NEED DATA.
WE CAN'T MEASURE HOW WE'RE DOING
UNLESS WE HAVE DATA.
IF YOU TURN TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
FLIGHT FOUR YOU'LL SEE THAT THE
ROLE OF THE STATE BAR WITH
RESPECT TO DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION IS ENSHRINED IN ONE OF
OUR GOALS.
IN THE STRATEGIC PLAN SO THERE'S
A FIVE PART FIVE YEAR STRATEGIC
PLAN.
GOAL NUMBER FOUR ENSHRINES OUR
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION AND IT REALLY ALIGNS
WITH THEIR NEW STATUTORY MISSION
AND THIS IS REALLY THE FIRST
PART THAT GOES TO A QUESTION
THAT MISTER TO ASK EARLIER.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE BAR IS FOCUSED ON
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION?
IF THE PRESIDENT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT LEAVES WHEN THERE'S A
NEW PRESIDENT WHO MAYBE NOT AS
FOCUSED ON PERCEIVED TO BE AS
FOCUSED.
ON DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION WELL
WE'VE INSTITUTIONALIZED IT WE'VE
PUT IT INTO OUR FIVE YEAR
STRATEGIC PLAN AND WE NOW HAVE
TO REPORT. TO THIS COMMITTEE
EVERY TWO YEARS ON OUR PROGRESS
TO THE SCHOOL.
THE BOARD ESTABLISHED PARAMETERS
FOR WHAT THEY WERE LOOKING AT
WITH RESPECT TO DIVERSITY
INCLUSION AND IT WANTED TO FOCUS
ON THREE AREAS IN PARTICULAR ONE
IS ENTRY INTO THE PROFESSION
WHICH WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT.
SO BOTH WRISTS WITH RESPECT TO
HOW ARE FEW PEOPLE DOING IN LAW
SCHOOL.
AND HOW ARE PEOPLE DOING THE BAR
EXAM.
SECOND THEY WANTED TO FOCUS ON
CAREER ADVANCEMENT.
LAKE AT YOU JUST HEARD YOU CAN'T
BE IT IF YOU DON'T SEE IT AND IT
REALLY MATTERS IF THEY'RE PEOPLE
IN POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP
PEOPLE THE JUDICIARY WHO REFLECT
THE OVERALL POPULATION.
AND THE THIRD AREA WE WANTED TO
LOOK AT IS RETENTION BECAUSE AS
WE'VE HEARD.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN PEOPLE OF
COLOR LGBT AND DISABLED LAWYERS
ARE LEAVING THE PROFESSION IN
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS.
WITH RESPECT TO GOAL NUMBER FOUR
THE BAR HAS ALSO SET FORTH
PARTICULAR OBJECTIVES OR ACTION
ITEMS.
AND SO YOU'LL SEE ON THE NEXT
SLIDE A LIST OF THE ACTION ITEMS.
FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
WELL AS FOR SOME THAT WILL BE
COMPLETED IN.
TWENTY TWENTY AND IT'S PART OF
OUR TWENTY TWENTY PLANNING
SESSION WE'RE GOING TO IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL INITIATIVES FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHICH WILL TAKE US
THROUGH THE FULL. FIVE YEAR
CYCLE.
SO I WANTED TO START OFF BY
LOOKING AT SOME OF OUR DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION EFFORTS WITH
RESPECT TO ENTRY INTO THE
PROFESSION.
THE STATE BAR'S COUNCIL AXES IN
FAIRNESS COMMITTEE WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIX AM IF YOU LOOK
AT FLIGHT.
EIGHT ESTABLISH A TWO PLUS TWO
PLUS THREE PROGRAM WHICH BEGINS
WITH HIGH SCHOOL LIFE CATANESE.
HELPING TO PUSH PEOPLE IN TO THE
PIPELINE.
BUT WE LACK DATA.
AND SO.
THE BAR HAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
NOW LOOKING AT TWO AREAS LAW
SCHOOL ATTRITION AND BAR PASSAGE.
THOSE ARE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE
MEASURABLE DATA AND CAN MEASURE
RESULTS AND SUCCESS.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT SLIDE TEN
WE LOOKED AT LAW SCHOOL
ATTRITION AND THE NUMBERS THAT
WE FOUND ARE STARTLING.
THIS AFFECTS THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO ARE ACTUALLY
EVEN TAKING THE BAR EXAM IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
WHICH YOU KNOW IN ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER STUDENTS HAVE NEARLY
DOUBLE THE DROP OUT RATE OF
WHITE STUDENTS.
BLACK LAW STUDENTS ARE DROPPING
OUT IT NEARLY QUADRUPLED THE
RATE OF WHITE STUDENTS.
M. WELL I'M GONNA HAVE TO RUSH
THROUGH THE FIGHT.
AND WITH RESPECT TO CURRENT EXAM
TAKERS WE IMPLEMENTED A
WHICH IS NOW CALLED THE POSITIVE
STRATEGIES AND STORIES PROGRAM
AND DID IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
A CONTROLLED STUDY.
THE RESULTS OF WHICH ARE VERY
EXCITING -- I DID READ THE
MATERIALS THAT WERE FROM THAT
THAT COMMITTEE STAFF PREPARED
AND ONE THING I WILL NOTE IS
THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THIS 18% IMPROVEMENT
LIFTED ALL BOTH NOT JUST THE
RESULT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR WE
MAINTAIN THAT THAT IS KEY TO
DIVERSITY INCLUSION THE SAME
REASON.
THAT YOU'VE HEARD BEFORE WHY
FOLKS BELIEVE THAT LOWERING THE
CUT SCORE WILL HELP PEOPLE OF
COLOR IMPROVING BAR PASSAGE
RATES FOR EVERYONE.
ALSO INCREASES THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR ENTERING THE
PROFESSION.
SO YOU FEE FROM THE REST OF THE
SLIDES THAT WE'VE GATHERED
ROBUST DATA ABOUT DEMOGRAPHICS.
ABOUT PEOPLE'S CAREER
ADVANCEMENT HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
MAKING IT TO PARTNERSHIP IN LAW
FIRMS WE'RE ALSO LEARNING THAT
MOST LAWYERS IN CALIFORNIA OVER
60% THEY'RE IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
SO WE TOOK A DEEP DIVE INTO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR YOU'LL SEE THAT
REFLECTED IN THESE LIVES HERE.
WE ALSO GATHERED INFORMATION
ABOUT CAREER SATISFACTION
BECAUSE THAT REFLECTS RISK
RETENTION IN THE PROFESSION.
M. AND SO I'LL LET YOU GUYS GO
THROUGH THE SLIDES ON YOUR OWN
THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF DATA TO
GO THROUGH.
THEM.
BUT TWO MORE THINGS I WILL AND
WAY.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT OTHER EXIT
FROM THE PROFESSION -- WE'RE
LOOKING TO PARTNER WITH THAT
WE'RE PARTNERING WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON A JUDICIAL
DIVERSITY TOOL KIT.
AND DOING REGIONAL AT REACH AND
LOCAL TRAINING EVENTS WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT DISPARITIES IN
DISCIPLINARY OUTCOME.
SO.
IT'S A FIRST OF ITS KIND STUDY
ON RACE AND GENDER DISPARITY IN
THE BARS ATTORNEY DISCIPLINE
SYSTEM AND ITS BIAS AFFECTING
THE RATE AT WHICH ATTORNEYS OF
COLOR AND WOMEN ARE DISCIPLINED.
AB AND I'LL JUST CONCLUDE WITH
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY EXCITING TO
HAVE THIS DATA IT ALLOWS US TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM SIMPLY
ANECDOTAL.
EVIDENCE TO REALLY WORKING ON
DATA DRIVEN DATA INFORM
STRATEGIES -- ARE WE RECENTLY
MET WITH THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS WITH THE
CORPORATE MINORITY COUNSEL
PROGRAM TO GO OVER THIS DATA.
AND TO DISCUSS ADDITIONAL
ANALYSES THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL.
I'M WE'RE GONNA PLAN ADDITIONAL
OUTREACH TO THE LOCAL AN
AFFINITY BARS.
I'M AND THE INITIAL FEEDBACK
FORGETTING IS THAT THIS IS
REALLY USEFUL DATA TO HELP
TAYLOR DIVERSITY INCLUSION
EFFORTS TO WHERE IT'S REALLY
NEEDED.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THE WINNING WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FIRST WELL
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE
DISCUSSION TODAY.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
THIS IS ONE THE MOST CRITICAL
THINGS I THINK FACE OUR
PROFESSION RIGHT NOW AND THANK
YOU DEAR VERY CAPABLE STAFF.
WHO I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
ON ISSUES LIKE THIS AND THIS
REALLY HELPS US BRING?
UP PAPERS LESS AS THE ONE
THEY'VE PREPARED -- TO THE
PUBLIC.
I'M VERY HUMBLED WHEN I LISTEN
TO THE STORIES OF THOSE WHO'VE
WHO'VE BEEN HERE TODAY AND AND I
CERTAIN AT LIKE YOU.
AND WONDER WHAT ROLE DO I PLAY
WHAT WHAT VOICE TO I HAVE HERE.
AND SOMETIMES I WONDER WHY I
CARE.
BECAUSE BECAUSE I TO A STUDENT
PRIVILEGE.
OF MY PARENTS WERE COLLEGE
EDUCATED.
UP AS MANY.
IMMIGRANT FAMILY CAME AT THE
TURN OF THE CENTURY BUT NOT WITH --
CHALLENGES AND AND STRUGGLES
THAT WE SEE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND PARTICULARLY IN THE COUNTIES
THAT I REPRESENT THE WORLD
COUNTIES OF CAT.
OF CALIFORNIA WITH MODERATE
COLLEGE LAW AND SAN LUIS OBISPO
COLLEGE LAW AND KERN COUNTY
COLLEGE OF LAW.
IT SHOWS I WAS THINKING I WAS
LISTENING TODAY OR WHICH PART OF
MY BACKGROUND RESONATED.
SO MUCH WITH THESE THESE ISSUES
AND WHY I THINK IT'S SO CRITICAL
NOT JUST AS AN ACADEMIC.
I AM NOT AS I WAS LISTENING I
THOUGHT.
YOU KNOW IT IS INTERESTING WHEN
YOU'RE OLD LIKE I AM.
AS SIXTY FOUR I THINK BACK
GROWING UP IN TEXAS.
AND WHEN I STARTED PRIMARY
SCHOOL.
WE HAD SEPARATE SCHOOLS FOR THE
WHITES AND NON WHITES.
IT'S IT'S WITHIN MY LIFETIME.
IT WASN'T INCLUSION AND ACCESS
IT WAS SEPARATE BUT EQUAL AND
THAT'S WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
PRIOR TO THAT TIME SAID WAS
PERFECTLY FINE.
IT WASN'T UNTIL I WAS IN FIFTH
GRADE THAT THE INTEGRATED THE
SCHOOLS IN TEXAS.
SO I LIVED THROUGH THAT PROCESS
OF SEEING WHERE SOMETHING THAT
WE THOUGHT IN THE PAST WAS
PERFECTLY OKAY.
WASN'T EVEN CLOSE TO BEING OKAY
AND HAD HUGE COSTS TO THE
QUALITY OF OF OUR SOCIETY IN THE
QUALITY OF OUR OF OUR EDUCATION
AND OURS.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
I THINK WORD OF SIMILAR
WATERSHED MOMENT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT DIVERSITY OF THE
PROFESSION.
DEAN RICHARDSON SAID IT FAR MORE
ARTICULATELY THAN I COULD AND
VERY DIRECTLY SO.
THERE'S NOT A LOT I NEED TO
REPEAT ON THE ISSUE OF THE CUT
SCORE.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THE FOURTEEN FORTY CUTS COURT IS
AN ARTIFACT.
NOT UNLIKE SEPARATE BUT EQUAL
WAS AN ARTIFACT.
IT'S IT WAS SET UP FIFTY SIXTY
SEVENTY YEARS AGO WE KNOW WHAT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE BAR WAS
THEN.
IT WAS SET UP TO MEASURE A GROUP
THEN THAT IS NOT THE COMMUNITIES
WE REFLECT NOW.
AS SHE SAID IT IS TIME FOR US TO
TAKE A VERY.
CAREFUL LOOK AT THAT ARTIFACT.
SO THE QUESTION WE MUST HAVE AS
WELL ON WHAT BASIS COULD YOU
MAKE THAT CHANGE.
WELL THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
REALLY HELPS US ON THIS IT SAYS
THAT WE SHOULD NOT HAVE.
PRE EMPLOYMENT TESTING OR
LICENSING.
THAT HAS A DISPARATE IMPACT
BASED ON RACE GENDER AGE.
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD IT'S
FAIRLY EASY TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
I THINK IF WE USE THAT MEASURE
THAT THE CONSTITUTION GIVES US.
AND WE APPLY IT TO THE
INFORMATION WE'VE HEARD HERE
TODAY.
IT'S FAIRLY CLEAR THAT THE
STATISTICAL ANALYSIS SHOWS.
THAT SCORE FOURTEEN FORTY AN
ARTIFACT OF FIFTY OR SIXTY YEARS
AGO HAS A DISPARATE IMPACT ON
THE BASIS OF RACE AND ETHNICITY.
IS REALLY.
NO QUESTION ABOUT WHAT THE
STATISTICS SHOW.
BUT WE'RE LEFT WITH WELL WHAT WE
DO NEXT IF THAT'S TRUE WHAT
SHOULD WE DO.
AND IN RICHARDSON ALSO POINTED
OUT I THINK A VERY SIMPLE FACT
THAT THE THE LAW AND THE CASE
LAW SAYS THERE ARE TO BE
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS ARE
STANDARDS BASED.
ON THE JOB PERFORMANCE THAT WE
SHOULD LOOK [inaudible] TO FORTY
EIGHT OF THE OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
HAVE SAID THAT SOMETHING BELOW
FOURTEEN FORTY AND IN FACT.
A MINIMUM PASSING SCORE OF THE
BAR EXAM SHOULD BE BETWEEN
THIRTEEN THIRTY IN. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FORTY EIGHT OF THE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS.
I THINK THAT PROVIDES US A
PROFESSIONAL STANDARD AND
NATIONAL MEANS THAT WHEN YOU AS
A LEGISLATOR WHEN THE COURT.
AS THE DECIDER OF THIS ISSUE
LOOK TO WHERE CAN WE GET
DIRECTION ON WHAT TO DO NEXT.
CAN HAVE SOME COMFORT THAT WE'RE
NOT ASKING THEM TO WONDER IN THE
WILDERNESS AND AND PICK A NUMBER
OUT OF THIN AIR.
THERE ARE STATISTICS AND DATA
THAT REALLY CLEARLY GIVE US A
DIRECTION ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE.
WE PUT ONE MORE POINT OR TWO ON
IT AND THEN I'LL SEE THE REST OF
MY TIME.
WHAT IS THE EFFECT OF THIS BILL
AND WE TALK ABOUT STATISTICS AND
WE LOOK AT BAR CHARTS?
WHAT IS THE VERY HUMAN COST AND
I WENT BACK AND LOOKED DEAD
AGAIN IS LIMITED DATA THAT THE
STATE BAR THE NAME NATIONAL
COMMITTEE BAR EXAMINERS PROVIDE?
I LOOKED WHAT IS THE IMPACT
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN OF USING
FOURTEEN FORTY IN CALIFORNIA
VERSES THE NATIONAL STANDARD OF
THIRTEEN FIFTY AM I ESTIMATE
USING THE ACTUAL DATA IS.
A OVER [inaudible] EIGHT
THOUSAND EIGHT THOUSAND
QUALIFIED MINORITY CANDIDATES
FOR THE BAR EXAM [inaudible]
THEY'VE.
GONE THROUGH ALL OF THE THE STE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HEARD
DESCRIBED TODAY.
THEY'VE SUCCESSFULLY BEEN TO LAW
SCHOOL THEY'RE ELIGIBLE PASS
MORAL CHARACTER AND WE HAVE THIS
ARTIFACT NUMBER OF FOURTEEN
FORTY THAT IS THAT HAS KEPT US
FROM HAVING THE QUALITIES AND
EXPERIENCE.
OF EIGHT THOUSAND MINORITY
LAWYERS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN WHO WOULD BE LICENSE IN
PRACTICING HERE TODAY.
IF WE WERE USING THE NATIONAL
STANDARD.
THOSE EIGHT THOUSAND LAWYERS
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO PRACTICE IN
FORTY EIGHT OF THE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS.
SO WE CLOSE BY ANSWERING THE
QUESTION YOU ASKED EARLIER WHICH
IS WHEN I HEAR EVERY TIME I
DISCUSS THIS.
ARE WE JUST TALKING ABOUT
DUMBING DOWN THE BAR EXAM.
MAY I REMIND US THAT THE PURPOSE
OF THE BAR EXAM IS TO MEASURE
THE MINIMUM COMPETENCY FOR THE
FIRST YEAR PRACTICE OF LAW.
NOT WHO ARE THE MOST EXCEPTIONAL
LAWYERS NOT WHO ARE THE FORTY
AND FIFTY YEAR EXPERIENCED
LAWYERS.
THE MINIMUM COMPETENCY FOR THE
FIRST YEAR PRACTICE OF LAW.
WE LOOK AT FORTY EIGHT OTHER
JURISDICTIONS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF LAWYERS.
AND WE FIND EXACTLY WHAT DEAN
RICHARDSON SAID THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE.
THAT REQUIRING A SCORE ABOVE THE
NATIONAL STANDARD CREATES MORE
COMPETENT LAWYERS LAWYERS LESS
LIKELY TO BE DISCIPLINED HIGHER
INCIDENCE OF GRIEVANCES.
IN FACT THE STATISTICS SHOW JUST
THE OPPOSITE.
SO I WOULD I WOULD LEAVE IT WITH
YOU ONE QUESTION YOU MIGHT ASK
IS WILL WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE
DO BECAUSE THIS ISSUE WAS WITH
THE SUPREME COURT.
I WOULD LEAVE ONE THING TO THINK
ABOUT THINK ABOUT TO CONSIDER.
I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
UNREASONABLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO SAY THAT.
ALL LICENSING EXAMS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT FALLS UNDER
THE CRITERIA OF THIS THE
CONSTITUTION WHICH ARE PRE
EMPLOYMENT LICENSING EXAMS.
SHOULD HAVE TO PROVE ON A
REGULAR BASIS THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE DISPARATE IMPACT AND IF
THEY DO AS DEAN RICHARDSON SAID
THE BURDEN SHOULD SHIFT TO THE
STATE IN THIS COURT THIS CASE
THE SUPREME COURT.
I HAVING TO SHOW WHY ANY NUMBER
OVER THE PROFESSIONAL MEAN
THAT'S ESTABLISHED.
NEEDS TO BE JUSTIFIED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOES FUJI THANK YOU.
THE PALM I AM HERE AS THE CHAIR
OF THE STATE PARKS COUNCIL NEXUS
IN FAIRNESS AS OF MS CHAN HAS IS
MENTIONED CONGRATULATIONS HARLAN.
ALL MAY AND ALSO I AM I I'M HERE
A AS A CHILD OF INCARCERATED
PARENTS FROM WORLD WAR -- TWO AS
A JAPANESE AMERICAN I'M ALSO
HERE'S A JUDGE OF THE LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT WITH MY
PRESIDING JUDGE HERE MAKING SURE
THAT I DON'T MESS UP -- AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF I WANT
TO THANK THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATION FOR RECOGNIZING.
THE IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSITY IN
THE PROFESSION AND THE JUDICIARY
AT TO THIS TO THE STATE AND TO
THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I PARTICULARLY WANT
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
HAVING PREVIOUSLY INCLUDED IN
THE STATE BAR BILL FOR EXAMPLE
THE A REQUIREMENT OF THESE
HEARINGS AND OF THE REPORT CARD
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PUTS
TOGETHER OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH DIVERSITY IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION BECAUSE IT IS AN
ISSUE.
WHICH I SEE ON THE BENCH EVERY
SINGLE DAY AS AFFECTING THE
PEOPLE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
IT PARTICULARLY WHEN I SAT IN
THE THE FAMILY WHAT APARTMENT
WHEN I FIRST WENT ON THE BENCH.
SEVEN YEARS AGO I SAW THE NEED
FOR AN UNDERSTANDING OF CULTURAL
ISSUES OF GENDER ISSUES OF L. G.
B. T. ISSUES OF DISABILITY
ISSUES THEY ALL CAME BEFORE US
IN THAT COURT.
WHERE WE HAD APPROXIMATELY 70%
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS TO
UNDERSTAND PEOPLE'S DIFFERENT
POINTS OF VIEW AND TO SEE WHY IT
IS THAT NOT EVERY SOLUTION FITS
EVERY SINGLE SITUATION?
SO THE STATE BAR IS IN A
PARTICULARLY GOOD POSITION AND
IT NEEDS TO TAKE AN ACTIVE ROLE --
TO DIRECT AND COORDINATE EFFORTS
TO INCREASE DIVERSITY IN OUR
PROFESSION -- SINCE -- TWO
THOUSAND SIX CO F. AS WE CALL
OURSELVES HAS TAKEN A LEADERSHIP
ROLE AS A ST BARTS THINK TANK
AND CONSCIENCE.
REGARDING DIVERSITY AND THAT IS
NOT JUST WE WE TALKED ABOUT
ABOUT THE JUDICIAL PIPELINE WE
TALKED ABOUT HOW JUDGES ARE ARE
APPOINTED.
MAIL WITH THERE'S THERE ARE
JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS THEIR
JUDICIAL ELECTIONS WITH THE VAST
VAST MAJORITY OF JUDGES COME ON
THROUGH JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AND SO WE ARE VERY CONCERNED AT
CALL AFTER WITH WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR WORKING WITH.
THE JUDICIAL APPOINTMENT
SECRETARY.
WHO WHO ARE WHO SEES EVERY
SINGLE APPLICATION LOOKING AT?
LOOKING AT TO OF ALL THE
GOVERNING BODIES THAT REVIEW
THAT THOSE APPLICATIONS THE
JUDGE -- WHAT'S CALLED JENNY THE
JUDICIAL NOMINEES EVALUATION
COMMITTEE THE THAT THE L. LOCAL
COMMITTEES IN VARIOUS COUNTIES
THAT WHAT USED TO BE THE SECRET
COMMITTEE I UNDERSTAND IS IS
GOING TO BE NOT SO SECRET.
ANYMORE OF WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH -- WITH JOSH
GROW BUT NOW JUSTICE GROVE IN.
TO TO ENCOURAGE -- THE
APPOINTMENT OF OF DIVERSE --
APPLICANTS TO THE JUDICIARY WE
ARE WORKING NOW WITH JUSTICE
JENKINS WHO HAS A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF DIVERSITY ON THE BENCH AND
AND HAS ALREADY BEEN TRAVELING
ALL OVER THE STATE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT MESSAGE IS BEING HEARD
ALL OVER.
THE CO OUT HIS BEEN KEEPING
TRACK OF OF THE APPOINTMENTS AND
SOMETIMES HAS BEEN A POSITION TO
SAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE
THINK THERE'S MORE HERE WE THINK
THERE'S LESS HERE.
THAN HAS BEEN REPORTED BECAUSE
WE HAVE VERY VERY DEEP --
CONNECTIONS WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND WERE ABLE TO GO OUT ALL OVER
THE STATE IN EVERY SINGLE AREA
AND TO SAY GEE WE WE WANTTO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE.
L. BUT WHAT IS BEING REPORTED OR
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
KEEP TRACK WHO IS LGBT -- IF
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO
BE REPORTED IN IN THE STATISTICS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THOSE GROUPS.
WE ALSO INVOLVED WITH IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING TO JENNY TO THE
COUNTY BAR ASSOCIATION'S TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THOSE IMPLICIT
BIAS IS THAT YOU'RE NOT EVEN
AWARE THAT YOU HAVE.
DON'T AFFECT THE CHOICE OF
JUDGES AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
I'VE SEEN MYSELF I SIT ON THE ON
SENATOR FEINSTEIN'S COMMITTEE TO
POINT FEDERAL JUDGES AND I HAVE
ACTUALLY HEARD WITHIN MY
COMMITTEE AMONG THE FIRST MEMBER
SAYING.
ALL THAT PERSON LOOKS LIKE A
JUDGE.
WHEN THEY'RE A?
TALL WHITE MALE.
AND TO BE ABLE TO SAY YOU KNOW
THAT PERSON DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ME.
AND I AM A JUDGE.
SO SO THOSE TYPES OF THINGS ARE
ARE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
TRAINED IN IT SAID WHAT PART OF
THE A PART OF THE MISSION.
OF CO AFTER.
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT NOT
ALL JUDICIAL CANDIDATES ARE
GOING TO BE AS SELF DIRECTED IS
JUDGE MISSY IS WHO IS A FORCE OF
NATURE.
AND I THINK WOULD HAVE BEEN.
A JUDGE REGARDLESS OF WHAT
SITUATION YOU PUT HER IN BECAUSE
SHE'S JUST SO AMAZING JUST AS I
EXPECTED THAT MISS PATRICIA
PATRICIA IS GOING TO BE A JUDGE
REGARDLESS OF ANY BARRIERS THAT
ANYBODY PUTS.
IN THEIR WAKE BUT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE WITH EVERYBODY THERE ARE SO
MANY CULTURAL ISSUES THERE SO
MANY GENDER ISSUES THERE SO MANY
FAMILIAL EXPECTATION ISSUES THAT
COME INTO THE THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER YOU THINK THAT YOU LOOK
LIKE.
A LAWYER IF YOU THINK YOU LOOK
LIKE A JUDGE.
AND THE IDEA THAT YOU COULD
BECOME A JUDGE I WAS THE FIRST
API WOMAN IN A LARGE LAW FIRM IN
LOS ANGELES BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN NOBODY LOOKS
LIKE ME.
AND IT WAS IT WAS NOT THE IT WAS
IT WAS REALLY THROUGH.
THROUGH AGAIN AT THAT TIME YOU
HAD A MENTOR YOURSELF.
NOW THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO CAN BE
MENTORS PEOPLE LIKE HIGHLAND
CHEN PEOPLE LIKE CHRISTOPHER --
AND AND I'M NOT GOING TO
PRONOUNCE YOUR NAME BECAUSE I
KNOW I'M GOING TO MESS IT UP
I'LL BUT EVEN THOUGH I KNOW YOU
VERY WELL.
BUT BUT THE PEOPLE LIKE JUDGE
BRAZIL WHO IS OUT THERE ALL THE
TIME -- TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS WHAT THEY
CAN DO BUT THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THE COED DOES CALL áP
WORKS WITH.
THE LAW ACADEMIES WHICH THIS
LEGISLATURE'S SO WONDERFUL TO BE
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
PROFESSION THAT THEY CAN GO INTO
WE WORK WITH THE TWO PLUS TWO
PLUS THREE PROGRAM.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
BEEN IT WITH FROM THE BEGINNING
WITH A LOT CANNABIS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE FOUR
YEAR COLLEGES AND LAW SCHOOLS
WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO INCREASE
THAT PIPELINE.
BECAUSE WITHOUT THAT PIPELINE
INTO THE PROFESSION THEN WE
CANNOT CARE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
QUALIFIED TO BECOME JUDGES.
SO.
WE ARE INVOLVED WITH LEADERSHIP
SUMMITS BUT SOMETHING THE STATE
PARK IS A HAS DONE IN THE PAST
AND WE'RE HOPING WILL CONTINUE
DO IN THE FUTURE.
AND MENTORING PROGRAMS ON THAT
WE WERE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
START UP TO TO PROVIDE MENTORING
TO TO PEOPLE ALL OVER THE STATE.
IN ALL SORTS OF AREAS SO THEY
CAN UNDERSTAND EVEN IF THEY'RE
IN THE COUNTY SAY WHETHER VERY
VERY FEW MINORITIES VERY VERY
FEW OF THE WOMEN OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR LGBT.
OF THE DISABILITY OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN POWER MAYBE NOBODY ON THE
BENCH TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
CAN BE SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
ASPIRE.
TO AND WE WE WORK WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN PUTTING ON TRADITIONALLY
FIVE TO SIX JUDICIAL DIVERSITY
PROGRAMS WORKING RIGHT NOW WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON ITS
JUDICIAL TOOL KIT WHICH IS
WONDERFUL.
AND A GREAT RESOURCE ESPECIALLY
FOR THE SMALLER COUNTIES.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT BET I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT TO OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FRANKLY HAS THE
HAS THE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO GO
OUT AND PUT ON THESE PROGRAMS
ALL OVER THE STATE.
AS THEY NEED TO BE PUT ON IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS WITH THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES CAN BE.
AND SO.
THIS IS SOMETHING I GET THAT
THAT CO AFTER HAS DONE VERY VERY
WELL WE HAVE.
ARE VERY VERY PROUD OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND WOMEN AND AND OTHER
MINORITIES WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
BE BECOME JUDGES.
THROUGH THROUGH OUR PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS
SECRETARIES OUR WORK WITH WITH --
THE OTHER GROUPS INVOLVING
INVOLVING APPOINTMENTS BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
ALL THE TIME AND WE NEED TO BE
CONTINUING TO DO THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF DATA COLLECTION IS
WONDERFUL THE STATE BAR IS DOING
THAT AND TAKING A LEADERSHIP
ROLE WITH THAT.
BUT IN ORDER.
TO GET TO CREATE PROGRAMS TO
PROMOTE THOSE PROGRAMS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE.
ARE AFFECTED AND THEY ALSO ARE
BEING BEING FOLLOWED IS
SOMETHING THAT CALL AFTER DOES
BEST.
AND SO -- THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH C. LA WHICH IS DOING AN
AMAZING JOB WITH THIS WITH --
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE
GOVERNOR WITH BAR GROUPS TO
CREATE PROGRAMS TO INCREASE
EDUCATION TO INCREASE MENTORING
AND TO ENCOURAGE THOSE.
WHO WANT TO ENTER THE PROFESSION
WHO WANT TO EXCEL IN THAT
PROFESSION AND WHO WANT TO THEN
GET TO THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
THAT PROFESSION -- SO THAT WE
HAVE THE DIVERSITY THAT ALL OF
US ARE TALKING ABOUT THE WE ALL
UNDERSTAND IS SO.
IMPORTANT TO THE HEALTH OF OUR
STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JUDGE WAS A GOOD MORNING AND
THAT IT REALLY IS A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR -- FOR HOLDING
THESE HEARINGS I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING SUCH AN
INTEREST IN DIVERSITY SOMETHING
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT. TO MANY OF
US HERE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS WHO WHO SHOWED UP
TODAY I'M LAST SO -- I'LL TRY TO
KEEP IT BRIEF BECAUSE I GUESS
I'M STANDING BETWEEN LUNCH.
BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS WHO BEEN HERE -- IT'S
BEEN SO ENLIGHTENING FOR ME.
AND I COME HERE AS THE CO CHAIR.
OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCILS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON PROVIDING
ACCESS FAIRNESS.
AND I'M ALSO THE PRESIDING JUDGE
OF LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT.
AND I HAVE THE DISTINCTION OF
BEING THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
PRESIDING JUDGE OF LAWCENTER
SUPERIOR COURT.
STICKING A HUNDRED YEARS. FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN.
AND TO MY JOURNEY I WAS THE
FIRST SUPERVISING JUDGES CIVIL
FOR THE LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR
COURT.
AND WE'RE HEAD OVER TO PROVIDE
THE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE JUDGES.
I WAS FIRST ASSISTANT PRESIDING
JUDGE FOR TWO YEARS AND NOW THE
PRESIDING JUDGE.
WHERE WE HAVE THE LA SPIRIT
CHORDS LARGE COURT AT THE STATE
FROM THE TRIAL COURT?
OVER FIVE HUNDRED JUDGES SEVENTY
COMMISSIONER SO.
IT'S A BIG JOB [inaudible]
BUT DIVERSITY IS A AN EVEN
BIGGER JOB.
AND MORE IMPORTANT TO OUR WHOLE
STATE THAT WE HAVE DIVERSITY.
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT I'VE
LEARNED I'VE BEEN THE COACH HERE
NOW.
FOR ABOUT A YEAR FOR THE
PROVIDING ACCESS IN FAIRNESS --
COMMITTEE.
AND ONE OF THE MANDATES AND A
MAJOR CHARGE OR PROVIDING --
ACCESS AND OF THE ACCESS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE INCLUDES A FOCUS ON
INCREASING DIVERSITY.
IN THE JUDICIARY -- ARE CHIEF
JUSTICE HAS SHOWN A TREMENDOUS
COMMITMENT.
AND IMMENSE DEDICATION TO
PROMOTING DIVERSITY IN THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH.
AS THE GOVERNING BODY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COURT SYSTEM.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS FOR
MANY YEARS PERSONAL THE GOAL OF
INCREASING DIVERSITY.
IN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH.
UNDER THE OUTSTANDING LEADERSHIP
OF OUR CHIEF JUSTICE. TO
UNDERSTAND TO BE RESPONSIBLE TO
THE NEEDS OF COURT USES FROM
DIVERSE CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS
ETHNICITIES.
WE NEED A BENCH THAT REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE'S
RESIDENTS.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCILS ANNUAL
TRACKING AND PUBLICATION OF
JUDICIAL DEMOGRAPHICS DATA
PROVIDES.
A PUBLICLY AVAILABLE BASELINE
FOR ALL GROUPS INTERESTED
ADVANCING DIVERSITY.
IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND THIRTEEN YEARS OF REPORTING
THE DATA SHOWS STEADILY
INCREASING DIVERSITY.
BUT WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO GO
AND THERE ARE STILL LOTS OF WORK
TO BE DONE TO CONTINUE THE
INCREASE IN DIVERSITY.
NO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
COUNCIL HAS DONE IS THEY'VE
SPONSORED SOME JUDICIAL.
SUMMITS. 200-062-00011 IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THESE ARE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE DO IT THE
SUMMITS AND I PARTICIPATED IN
MANY OF THEM.
IS WE HAVE PANELISTS NAMELY
JUDGES LAWYERS OFTENTIMES A
JUDICIAL APPOINTMENT SECRETARY
WILL SHOW UP FOR EXAMPLE -- NOW
JUSTICE JOSH GROBAN WHEN HE WAS
ACTING IN THE ROLE OF JUDICIAL
POINT SECRETARY HE WOULD
OFTENTIMES A TEN THESE DIVERSITY
SUMMITS.
AND WHAT WE TALK ABOUT AND
EXPLAIN TO APPLICANTS THE
PROCESS FOR BECOMING A JUDGE
WHAT IS THE GOVERNOR LOOKING FOR
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO STRESS IN
YOUR APPLICATION.
AND THIS IS VERY ENLIGHTENING
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT IT TAKES
AND A USE MYSELF ON HIS EXAMPLE --
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF STORIES
ABOUT PEOPLE'S EXAMPLES AND
UNFORTUNATELY I I KIND OF FIT
INTO THAT SAME THEME I WAS THE
FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE -- WHEN I GRADUATED FROM
HIGH SCHOOL I HAD THE
DISTINCTION OF HAVING ONE OF THE
LOWEST GPAS OF ANY GRADUATING
SENIOR?
SO I PROBABLY WENT TO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WHERE AFTER TWO YEARS I WAS ABLE
TO TRANSFER TO THE UCLA?
AND I SHE'S MY **** DEGREE AT
UCLA THEN WENT ON TO UCLA LAW
SCHOOL.
AND WHEN I JOIN THE COUNTY
COUNSEL'S OFFICE AFTER A PASSED
THE BAR EXAM.
I WAS ONE OF THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO WORK AT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
WHICH DIDN'T START HIRING WOMEN
UNTIL THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
EVEN THOUGH THE OPPOSITE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE SINCE ABOUT THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES.
AND I CAME ON IN THE EARLY
EIGHTIES.
SO IT'S AN INTERESTING STORY.
BUT AN IMPORTANT STORY BECAUSE
THAT **** IN HELPED SHAPE WHO WE
ARE.
AND EXPLAINS WHY WE HAVE THIS
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY THAT YOU
SEE OF MIKE'S MYSELF AND ALL THE
OTHER PANELISTS -- WHO SPOKEN TO
YOU THIS MORNING IT COMES FROM
LIFE EXPERIENCE IT COMES FROM?
WHAT WE'VE HAD TO GO?
FOR SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE COUNCIL HAS DONE IN TERMS OF
WE TALK ABOUT.
DIVERSITY PATHWAYS.
AND ONE OF THINGS WE DO IS WE
FOCUS ON HIRING SUBORDINATE
JUDICIAL OFFICERS OUR
COMMISSIONERS REFEREES --
THERE'S OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY I
THINK IN THE STATE MANY OF THOSE --
COMMISSIONERS GO ON TO BE JUDGES
THINK OF RECENTLY I THINK THE
NUMBERS ARE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
COMMISSIONERS AS THEY ARE
SELECTED BY THE JUDGES.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
SELECTION COMMITTEES.
ARE MADE UP AND HAVE DIVERSITY.
BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
SELECTION PEOPLE SELECT PEOPLE
WHO LOOK LIKE VAMP.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WERE
FOCUSING ON IN LOS ANGELES WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE HAVING A
JUDICIAL -- COMMISSIONER
SELECTION PROCESS COMING UP VERY
SOON AND FORTUNATELY I'M IN I'M
THE PRESIDING JUDGE SO I'M GONNA
PICK.
IT WAS ON THAT SELECTION
COMMITTEE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I CAN
GUARANTEE IS THAT IT WILL BE
DIVERSE.
I'M EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ON THE COMMITTEE JUST TO
MAKE SURE WE DO HAVE DIVERSITY.
AND I HAVE A GOAL OF MAKING SURE
WE HAVE EQUAL NUMBER OF MEN AND
WOMEN.
ND AFRICAN AMERICANS LATINOS
ASIAN AMERICANS ON THAT
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS WHITES SO
THAT IT REFLECTS WHO ARE COURT
IS.
IN WHO ARE COMMUNITIES ANOTHER
THING THAT THE COUNCIL SUPPORTS.
WE HAVE VOLUNTEER ATTORNEY
SERVING AS TEMPORARY JUDGES.
AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE USE
THEM IN TRAFFIC MUSEUM IN SMALL
CLAIMS.
AND AGAIN THAT SELECTION PROCESS
WHICH IS DONE BY THE JUDGES.
THOSE PEOPLE ON THAT SELECTION
COMMITTEE HAVE TO BE DIVERSE.
BECAUSE AGAIN WE GO BACK TO THE
YOU PICK PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE
YOU.
SO WE'VE GOT TO HAVE WOMEN WE'VE
GOT TO HAVE MINORITIES TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE DIVERSITY.
IN THOSE TWO AREAS BECAUSE OFTEN
TIMES THAT'S A GOOD TRAINING
GROUND. FOR SOMEBODY TO BECOME A
JUDGE TO BE TO GET THE
EXPERIENCE TO GET THE KNOWLEDGE
TO GET THE RECOGNITION THEY NEED
TO BECOME A JUDGE SO THE COUNCIL
I'M I'M PROUD TO SAY.
THE BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN MAKING
SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS.
ANOTHER THING THAT THE COUNCIL
FOCUSING ON IS MANAGING AND
AVOIDING IMPLICIT BIAS.
SO KIND OF WHAT I'VE TALKED
ABOUT JUST PREVIOUSLY WHEN YOU
HAVE A SELECTION GROUP.
AND IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE YOU.
THAT'S KIND OF THAT IMPLICIT
BIAS COMING INTO PLAY WHERE YOU
AGAIN WE WE PICK PEOPLE LIKE US
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT WERE BAD
PEOPLE IF WE DO THAT.
BUT IT'S JUST THAT IMPLICIT BIAS
THAT WE HAVE.
SO IN RECOGNITION OF THIS.
AND WE AGAIN [inaudible]
WE NEED TO HAVE A DIVERSE BRANCH --
WE HAVE TO HAVE A BROUGHT THE
BENCH HAS A BROAD RESPONSIBILITY
RESPECTING.
AND UNDERSTANDING THE DIVERSITY
OF THOSE WHO COME TO THE COURT.
SO THE COUNCIL IS PROMOTED
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING.
WHICH IS INTEGRATED INTO THE
COUNCIL'S BIANNUAL EDUCATION
PLAN FOR JUDGES AND BRANCH
EMPLOYEES AS WELL.
AND THE CHIEF JUSTICE AS
DIRECTED REVIEW OF THESE
PROGRAMS TO SEE WHAT
IMPROVEMENTS.
MAY BE NEEDED IN THE FUTURE.
ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
DIVERSITY THAT WE SUPPORT THE
STUDENT PIPELINE.
WE HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED JUSTICE
COURT.
WHICH WE HAVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AS WELL AS COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND GRAD STUDENTS WHO
ACT IN SELF HELP CENTERS. TO OUR
VARIOUS COURTS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE COUNCIL IS
PROMOTED LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
JUSTICE COURSE STUDENTS.
WHO ARE HELPING TO OUR SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS PREPARE
MATTERS AND TO GET READY FOR
COURT?
WE'VE ALSO GOT ONGOING COMMUNITY
OUTREACH EFFORTS OUTREACH
EFFORTS THAT THE COUNCIL
SUPPORTS -- IN TERMS OF WORKING
WITH LOCAL LAW SCHOOLS -- WE
WORK WITH THE JUDICIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE INTERNS --
OVER THREE HUNDRED I BELIEVE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE BEEN THREE
HUNDRED SCHOOLS AND THIRTY
COUNTIES -- STUDENTS TEACHING
CIVICS.
AS WELL AS JUDGES AND EVEN THE
CHIEF JUSTICE HAS A PROGRAM.
AND SHE'S BEEN A LEADER IN THE
ROLE AND A MILE IN THIS AREA. TO
HER MANY OUTREACH EFFORTS AND
CIVICS EDUCATION INITIATIVE
LAUNCHED IN.
TWENTY TWELVE NOW ONE FINAL
IMPORTANT PROJECT AND IS CO
CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL'S ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON PROVIDING ACCESS
AND FAIRNESS.
TOGETHER WITH COURT OF APPEAL
JUSTICE LAURIE THE LINE.
I'M EXCITED TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION ON THE JUDICIAL
DIVERSITY TOOL KIT.
THIS TOOK IT STEMS FROM THE
OFFICIAL OVERSEE SUMMIT IN. TWO
THOUSAND TEN FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL PRODUCED A TOOL KIT OF
PATHWAYS TO ACHIEVING JUDICIAL
DIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA COURTS.
THAT IS AVAILABLE ONLINE AT THE
GENERAL COUNSEL WEBSITE.
LAST YEAR THE CHIEF JUSTICE
INITIATED AN EFFORT TO
REVITALIZE AN UPDATE THIS
RESOURCE.
AND TO CREATE THE JUDICIAL
DIVERSITY TOOL KIT VERSION TWO
POINT -- OH MY COMMITTEE IS
EXPECTED TO LAUNCH THE REVAMPED
ONLINE TOOL KIT LATER THIS YEAR.
WITH NEW INFORMATION NEW
APPROACHES AND NEW RESOURCES.
WE'LL HAVE A DYNAMIC PROFIT FORM
INCORPORATING ONLINE LAKES. TO
STAY CURRENT WITH WHAT OTHERS
ARE DOING IN THIS AREA OF
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
THE GOAL OF THE DIVERSITY TOOL
KIT IS TO CREATE A RESOURCE THAT
PROVIDES MULTIPLE IN PRACTICAL
WAYS. FOR LOCAL COURTS AND BAR
ASSOCIATIONS TO ENGAGE GUY AND
MENTOR POTENTIAL JUDICIAL
APPLICANTS [inaudible]
IN ADDITION. FOR THE JUDGES.
I THINK IT IS SO VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO BE ENGAGED.
AND ALTHOUGH WE HAVE THE TOOL
KIT AND IT'S VERY HELPFUL.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE FUTUR
JUDICIAL SUMMITS AGAIN WHICH ARE
VERY HELPFUL.
IN ORDER TO APPOINT A SECRETARY
MARTIN JENKINS IS GONNA BE
DISSIPATE.
AND SOME OF THESE JUDICIAL
SUMMITS.
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS FOR
JUDGES AND THIS IS WHERE I HAVE
TO LOOK TO MY COLLEAGUES.
AROUND THE BENCH.
WE HAVE TO BECOME MORE ENGAGED
WE HAVE TO BE MORE HANDS ON THE
DIFFERENCE TO ACHIEVING
DIVERSITY IS AND IT'S BEEN
ALLUDED TO HERE ALREADY IS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE MENTORING.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SUPPORT I DON'T
CARE WHO YOU ARE.
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES SOMEBODY HAS
TO BELIEVE IN YOU IN ORDER FOR
YOU TO BELIEVE IN YOURSELF.
AND THAT'S WHERE JUDGES HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT INFLUENCE ON
ME AND BECOMING A JUDGE.
IS ONE ANOTHER JUDGE TOLD ME.
I THINK YOU SHOULD BECOME
PROJECT.
THAT REALLY TURNED ON THE LIGHT
FOR ME.
BECAUSE GROWING UP I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT THE JUDGES DIDN'T KNOW ANY
LAWYERS.
AS I SAID THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY
TO GO TO COLLEGE BUT A JUDGE WHO
TOOK THE TIME TO TELL ME AFTER A
TRIAL.
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU THINK YOU
REALLY ARE PURSUE A JUDICIAL
CAREER.
THAT'S WHAT MADE THE DIFFERENCE
AND THAT IS SO VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF MINORITY GROUPS
THAT ARE INVOLVED -- FROM
AFRICAN AMERICAN JUDGES THE
LATINO JUDGES THE ASIAN JUDGES
WERE TRIED TO MENTOR.
JUDICIAL APPLICANTS BUT PART OF
THAT PROCESS WITH WHAT WE DO IS
WE IDENTIFY.
THOSE LAWYERS WHO WE THINK COULD
BE GOOD JUDGES BECAUSE JUDGES WE
BELIEVE OUR ANALYSTS LIKE SAY
FOR THE GROUP THAT I BELONG.
TO WHO BETTER THAN US TO
IDENTIFY WHO CAN BE A GOOD JUDGE
WE SEE THEM EVERY DAY WE SEE THE
LAWYERS.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SO FOR JUDGES IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE ENGAGED IN THE
MENTORING THE LEADERSHIP.
WE ALSO HAVE TO GOING TO THE
HIGH SCHOOLS WE ALSO HAVE TO
GOING TO THE JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE THAT PIPELINE STARTS
VERY VERY EARLY ON SO AT THE LA
SUPERIOR COURT WE HAVE A PROGRAM
WE WILL RECALL IT -- THE WOMEN'S
CONFERENCE AND THE MEN'S
CONFERENCE AND ACTUALLY JUST --
JAY IS INVOLVED IN THAT WERE
VERY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
INTO THE COURT AND IT'S BEEN
PRETTY MUCH HALF A DAY IN THE
COURT.
TALKING TO JUDGES LISTENING THE
PANELS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY ONE
ONE ON ONE FACE TO FACE
COMMUNICATION WITH JUDGES.
SO REALLY I THINK.
WE AS JUDGES HAVE A TREMENDOUS
ROLE TO PLAY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ACHIEVE
DIVERSITY.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE.
IT CAN BE DONE.
ANOTHER THING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT IS FOR STUDENTS AND
AND THIS IS BEEN TALKED ABOUT BY
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
TERMS OF GETTING INTO LAW SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR PREPARATION COURSES
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WHETHER
IT'S GETTING INTO LAW SCHOOL
PREPARING FOR THE LSAT PREPARE
FOR THE BAR EXAM THERE'S GOT TO
BE SOME FORM OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BAR
EXAM IT COSTS HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS. TO TAKE THAT EXAM PREP
COURSE WHICH I'VE HEARD
MENTIONED EARLIER CAN COST THREE
TO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND IF YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT MORE
THAN ONCE WHICH IS INDICATED IN
TERMS OF WHAT MINORITIES HAVE TO
DO.
THE FINANCIAL COST.
CAN THEN BECOME A PERIOD.
JUST LIKE THAT FINANCIAL COSTS
BECAUSE CAN BECOME A BEAR GOING
TO LAW SCHOOL.
BECAUSE YOU GOT TO TAKE THE LSAT
TESTS MAYBE HAVE TO TAKE A MORE
THAN ONCE WE NEED A PREPARATION
COURSE YOU'VE ALREADY GOT
COLLEGE BILLS.
ON TOP OF THAT SO SOME KIND OF
SCHOLARSHIP FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
ONE OF THINGS WE DO A LOS
ANGELES THIS WEEK.
VIOLENT VOLUNTEER LAWYERS
VOLUNTEER JUDGES HELP STUDENTS
PREPARE FOR THE BAR EXAM.
AND I WAS LISTENING TO THE
DISCUSSION HERE ABOUT.
THE CUT SCORE.
AND PART OF THAT IS.
GETTING PEOPLE PREPARE THE
COMING RIGHT OUT OF LAW SCHOOL
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE CAN DO
TO HELP US MAKE SURE THEY GET
THE PREPARATION COURSES.
NOT JUST ONCE THEY LEAVE LAW
SCHOOL.
BUT I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT THERE
SHOULD BE A PREPARATION COURSE
AS PART OF THE LAW SCHOOL
CURRICULA.
MAYBE THAT THIRD YEAR LAST
SEMESTER SOME KIND OF BAR
PREPARATION COURSE TO GET
STUDENTS READY.
AND AGAIN THE FINANCIAL ASPECT
MONEY TO PAY FOR THESE PROGRAMS
THE PAY FOR THE BAR EXAM TO PAY
FOR REPEAT COURSE.
IT'S A TWO DAY EXAM TO PAY FOR A
HOTEL SUITE YOU CAN TAKE WITH
THEM AND BE FRESH IN THE MORNING
WHEN YOU GET THERE FOR SIX HOURS
OF TESTING EACH DAY.
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS ARE
IMPORTANT.
SO AS AS I LOOK AT DIVERSITY I'M
VERY PROUD OF WHAT.
CHIEF JUSTICE IS DONE.
I MEAN SHE SEVEN AND MEN'S
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY -- YOU
LOOK AT THE MAKE UP OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNTY LOOK AT THE MAKE
UP OF THE ADVISORY COMMITTEES
WELL WE SEE INCLUSION THERE AND
IT'S AN EFFORT THAT CONTINUES.
AND A LOT OF IT HAS TO COM FROM
COURT LEADERSHIP.
WE HAVE TO STEP UP.
AND UNFORTUNATELY BEING THE ONLY
ONE OF THE FEW AFRICAN AMERICAN
PRESIDING JUDGES OUT OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
I HAVE A LITTLE INFLUENCE IN LA
BUT NOT AS MUCH STATEWIDE.
OKAY SO I TRY TO FOCUS ON THAT.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE WHAT
WE CALL INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY
SO IT'S IT'S AN IMPORTANT JOB.
THE COUNCIL I KNOW IS COMMITTED
TO MAKING SURE WE HAVE DIVERSITY
WE'VE GOT PROGRAMS IN PLACE --
TALKED ABOUT THE JUSTICE CORPS
PROGRAM WE ALSO HAVE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS THE ONLY WHO THE
COUNCIL BUT THROUGH.
SOME OF THE VARIOUS COURTS THAT
THE CHIEF STRONGLY SUPPORTS AND
I KNOW THE BARS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
WHICH HAS A ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS.
AS WELL CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION THEY'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH -- DIVERSITY
PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF JUDICIAL
SUMMITS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN.
HAVE LAWYERS AND JUDGES ENGAGED
IN THE RECRUITMENT PROCESS.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE TO REALIZE IS THAT ONCE
A MINORITY BECOMES A JUDGE.
THEN THERE'S ALWAYS THE PROBLEM
OF RETENTION.
BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES WHEN AS A
JUDICIAL ELECTION WHICH HAPPENS
EVERY SIX YEARS MINORITY JUDGES
USUALLY DRAW CHALLENGE IN THOSE
COUNTIES WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF MINORITY.
RESIDENTS SO WE HAVE TO LOOK OUT
FOR THAT IN THERE IT'S ALL ABOUT
MONEY FOR JUDICIAL ELECTIONS
INJURES RETENTION.
BUT THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM THAT
SOMETIMES GETS OVERLOOKED AS
WELL ONCE WE GET THEM ON THE
BENCH.
WE GOT TO KEEP THEM ON THE BENCH.
AND OFTENTIMES THAT VERY FIRST
TIME UP.
MINORITY CANDIDATE WILL FACE AN
ELECTION CHALLENGE.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
AND I KNOW THE COUNCIL THAT'S A
CONCERN OF THE COUNCIL.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE IN LOS ANGELES IS IS WE'VE
STARTED A A PACK FOR THE JUDGES --
TO HELP THEM FINANCE -- THEIR
CAMPAIGNS WHERE THE JUDGES MAKE.
MONTHLY CONTRIBUTIONS.
ARE THE CJ ALSO HAS A PET.
DACHSHUND SAME WAY.
SO.
I FINALLY FIGURED OUT THAT'S
WHAT THAT MEANS LIKE.
A A SUBTLE REMINDER OKAY THAT'S
WHAT THAT MEANS.
ALL RIGHT I'M A LITTLE SLOW BUT
GONNA FINALLY GOT IT.
SO ANYWAY I I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU. FOR TAKING THE TIME.
TO PAY SO MUCH ATTENTION TO
SHINE A LIGHT.
ON THIS ISSUE IT IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT.
HOPEFULLY SOMETHING CAN BE DONE
ABOUT THE BAR EXAM CUTS GORE I I
WHAT I HEARD THIS MORNING WAS.
VERY VERY COMPELLING.
AND AGAIN FOR ME AND ALL THE
JUDGES OF MY COLLEAGUES.
WE HAVE TO TAKE A LEADERSHIP
ROLE AND WE HAVE TO BE INVOLVED
SO THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALTHOUGH.
YOU PHRASE SOMETHING IN A WAY
THAT THAT IS ALWAYS BOTHER ME A
LITTLE BIT ANY BRING IT UP WITH
THE OTHER PAN AROUND TESTING.
BUT SINCE YOU HAD BROUGHT IT UP.
THIS NOTION OF MAYBE ASKING THE
LAW SCHOOLS TO TEACH THAT TO
PREP FOR THE BAR EXAM WHICH I'M
NOT.
ACTUALLY ADVOCATING BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WOULD BE A MISTAKE IF
WE SET UP AN EDUCATION SYSTEM TO
TEACH TO A TEST I I THINK THAT'S
A MISTAKE.
BUT WE HAVE THIS INDUSTRY THAT
WAS CREATED AROUND BAR SCHOOL
PREP COURSES.
AND IT IT'S BECOME.
NECESSARY TO DO A PREP COURSE
AND EVERY STUDENT GOES THROUGH
IT AND AND IT SORT OF BECOMES
PART OF THE LOWER.
EVEN.
UNDER YEARS AGO WHEN I WENT
THROUGH LAW SCHOOL SO.
THAT THE LOWER ABOUT WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO AND ALL.
BUT IT WHY.
BECAUSE IF THE IF THE BAR EXAM
WERE TESTING ON COMPETENCE. FOR
SOMEBODY IS COMING OUT OF LAW
SCHOOL OR WHO HAD BEEN.
PRACTICING IN ANOTHER STATE OR
WHO HAD GONE THROUGH INSTEAD OF
GOING TO LAW SCHOOL BUT HAD.
HAD IN IN TURN DOOR OR WORKED
WITH A AS THE CALIFORNIA LAW.
CURRENTLY ALLOWS BUT I DON'T
KNOW ANYBODY'S REALLY DUMB THIS
RECENTLY. TO BE WORK FOR AN
ATTORNEY AND AND AND TO GET
PRATT'S [inaudible]
THAT PREPARATION.
THE EXAM SHOULD BE A COMBINATION
OF THAT PREPARATION RATHER THAN
SOMETHING THAT STANDS ON ITS OWN
AND I CAN REMEMBER BACK
[inaudible]
THAT.
SOMEBODY HAD TALKED WILLOWS LAW
SCHOOL THAT THAT WE LEARNED.
THREE DIFFERENT DISTINCT TYPES
OF LAW.
THAT HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
DO WITH EACH OTHER THE FIRST IS
WHAT YOU LEARN IN LAW SCHOOL.
AND THE SECOND IS WHAT YOU LEARN
FOR THE BAR EXAM AND THE THIRD
IS WHAT YOU LEARN WHEN YOU
PRACTICE.
AND THERE'S NO IN RELATION
BETWEEN ANY OF THOSE.
A BIT OF A JOKE BUT YET SOME
REAL AND THAT'S UNDERSCORED BY
YOUR STATEMENT ABOUT HAVING TO
TAKE THESE PREP EXAMS TO TO BE
ABLE TO BE.
SUCCESSFUL AT TAKING THE BAR.
EXAM SO DOESN'T THAT MEAN THAT
THE BAR EXAM ITSELF.
DOESN'T RELATE TO THE STUDY'S TO
THE PREPARATION THAT FOLKS HAVE
GONE THROUGH A WOULD. THIRTY
SEVEN START IF I MAY ADDRESS
THAT GAP QUESTION BECAUSE THE
BAR ACTUALLY IS UNDERTAKEN RIGHT
NOW A PRACTICE ANALYSIS I MEAN
YOU ASK EXACTLY THE RIGHT
QUESTION IS THE BAR EXAM TESTING.
FOR WHAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY NEED TO
KNOW TO BE MINIMALLY COMPETENT
LAWYERS ENTERING THE PROFESSION.
AND TO THE STATE BAR RIGHT NOW
IS UNDERGOING AN ANALYSIS UP
WHAT ARE THE SKILLS THAT A FIRST
YEAR ATTORNEY NEEDS TO KNOW.
RIGHT I MEAN I CAN TELL YOU AS A
PARTNER IN A LAW FIRM WE HAVE
ASSOCIATES COMING IN THE DOOR OF
OUR VERY LEE LAW FIRM.
WHO HAVE NEVER LEARNED HOW TO
DRAFT THE DECLARATION?
RIGHT BUT YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
PRACTICING LAWYER THAT IS ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS YOU REALLY NEED
TO KNOW HOW TO DO.
I AM SO THAT STUDY IS GOING TO
BE HUGELY USEFUL TO LOOKING AT
WHETHER WE NEED TO RECONSTITUTE
THE BAR EXAM TO REALLY ADDRESS
THOSE SKILLS THAT PEOPLE NEED IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR.
OTHERWISE ANY GOOD PARALEGAL --
LEGAL SECRETARY COULD PROBABLY
SIT DOWN AND TAKE THE BAR.
BECAUSE OF THE THE PRACTICAL
ASPECT IN IN THE FIRST YEAR LAW
STUDENT.
IF THEY DON'T QUICKLY MAKE
FRIENDS WITH THE PARALEGALS AND
LEGAL SECRETARIES WILL READILY
STRUGGLE THE SECRETARY AT YOU
KNOW PROPERTIES A BUNDLE OF
RIGHTS.
YOU KNOW THAT.
I THINK IT'S SORT OF A TWO PART
QUESTION WHICH IS YOU KNOW DOES
THE BAR EXAM TESTS WHICH YOU
NEED TO DO TO BE A TO BE A GOOD
LAWYER.
THE NEXT QUESTION IS DOES LAW
SCHOOL PREPARE YOU TO BE A GOOD
LAWYER.
AND AND THE STEPS IN BETWEEN AND
I LOOK FOR EXAMPLE I WENT TO
BERKELEY AND THEY HAVE IT HAD.
A TREMENDOUS INCREASE WHEN WHEN
I WAS IN SCHOOL THERE IS NO SUCH
THING AS CLINICAL EDUCATION NOW
IT'S ALL ABOUT THEY HAVE.
DOZENS OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CLINICAL EXPERIENCES THAT YOU
CAN GO THROUGH ALL OF WHICH ARE
GOING TO TEACH YOU HOW TO DO A
DECLARATION.
SO IT IT TAT BUT IT MADE IT MAY
OR MAY NOT PREPARE YOU TO TAKE
THE BAR EXAM I DON'T KNOW.
YEAH I THINK I DIDN'T AND LAW
SCHOOLS IT SHOULD BE ALSO
TEACHING.
HOW TO THINK HOW TO ANALYZE HOW
TO DO THOSE KINDS OF IN DEPTH
THINGS THAT DON'T NECESSARILY
COME ON THAT'S FINE BUT THEN
THERE'S THE PRACTICAL ASPECTS OF
IT IN AND? FOR YOU AS WE HAVE.
THE AND I WANT TO ANSWER THIS
BUT ALSO YOUR SCHOOL THING YOU
MENTIONED WHERE YOUR SCHOOLS ARE.
YOUR PIPELINE IF YOU WILL OF THE
INTO RURAL AREAS.
YES DAD WHERE THERE'S A LACK OF
ATTORNEYS WHERE THERE IS A LACK
OF HI A PAID EXPENSIVE LAW FIRMS.
SO WE A LOT OF THE THE STUDENTS
THAT YOU TEACH THEN GO OUT INTO
AREAS THAT ARE PROBABLY
UNDERSERVED BY NUMBERS OF
LAWYERS.
THAT HAVE TO BE COME OUT OF
SCHOOL READ THE TACKLE ALL HOST
OF DIFFERENT THINGS BECAUSE ONCE
YOU PASSED THE BAR EXAM.
WERE QUALIFIED TO DO LOTS OF
THINGS WHICH IS THE PROMISES I
WOULD SERIOUSLY QUESTION.
BUT TECHNICALLY QUALIFIED TO DO
A LOT OF THINGS RIGHT SO HOW DO
YOU PREPARE YOUR STUDENTS THAN
THIS PIPELINE TO GO OUTINTO
THESE RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND TO BE EFFECTIVE SO THE GOOD
THE GOOD NEWS IS AS LEGAL
EDUCATION IS INVOLVING.
I DON'T THINK IT'S UNREALISTIC
TO EXPECT BELOW IN THE COURSE OF
A LARGER DEGREE TO DO ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING WE'VE JUST DISCUSSED
HERE.
THERE'S THERE'S NO REASON WE
CAN'T INTEGRATE ADDITIONAL
CLINICAL TRAINING.
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR OVER A
DECADE IT WORKS VERY WELL I
THINK ALL OF THE MAJOR LAW
SCHOOL ALL LAW SCHOOLS I BELIEVE
OF INTEGRATED MORE CLINICAL
TRAINING BECAUSE WE'RE LISTENING
TO THE BENCH IN THE BAR.
AND AND THE PRACTICING LAWYERS
WHO SAY THIS WHAT WE WANT THEM
TO DO.
IT THE SKILLS TO PASS THE BAR
EXAMINER TO EXCLUSIVE TO
ANALYTICAL REASONING READING
COMPREHENSION WRITING THESE ARE
THE SAME THINGS WE DO IS LAWYERS.
IT MAY NOT BE IN EXACTLY THE
SAME FORMAT AS THE BAR EXAM.
IT IS UNUSUAL THAT WE'VE NOW
HAVE 50% OF THE CALIFORNIA BAR
EXAM THAT OUR MBT QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE NO RELATION TO THE PRACTICE
OF LAW WHATSOEVER.
BUT THE ESSAY EXAMS IN THE
PERFORMANCE EXAMS ARE ARE NOT.
A NOT FUNCTIONALLY UNLIKE THE
WAY WE PRACTICE LAW.
IN THE DAY TO IDENTIFY ISSUES ON
OF THE RULES.
DO THE ANALYSIS AND AND DRAFT A
CONCLUSION.
SO I THINK IT IS REALISTIC TO
EXPECT US AND TO DEMAND.
US AS LEGAL EDUCATORS TO BE ABLE
TO DO ALL OF THESE THINGS WE CAN
WALK AND CHEW GUM AT THE SAME
TIME WE CAN DO ALL OF THESE
THINGS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND FOR OUR STUDENTS.
WITHIN THE CURRICULUM THAT WE
HAVE.
AS TO THE ISSUE OF RURAL EDUCATE
OVERLY WORLD SERVING LAWYERS AS
A YOU KNOW WHEN WE WERE HERE TWO
YEARS AGO IN. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
STUDIES THAT REPORTED THAT
SHOWED.
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
SERVING THE RURAL COMMUNITIES OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A VAST.
AREA OF CALIFORNIA COME OUT OF
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPPORTUNITY LAW
SCHOOLS NOT ONLY LIKE OURS LIKE
MANY OF THE LAW SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE AND THE REAL TRAGEDY IS
WE SUCCEED ON THE INPUT SIDE
WITH NOW 52% OF THOSE WHO SAT
FOR THE JULY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BAR EXAM.
BEING MINORITIES COMING FROM
THOSE COMMUNITIES INTERESTED IN
GOING BACK INTO THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND YET HAVING THE
BARRIER OF THE FOURTEEN FORTY
STAND IN THEIR WAY OF GOING OUT
SERVING THOSE COMMUNITIES AS
LAWYERS.
FORTUNATELY MANY OF THEM STILL
SERVE THOSE COMMUNITIES THEY'RE
JUST THEY'RE EFFORTS ARE BLUNTED
BY NOT BEING ABLE TO DO IT AS A
LAWYER.
AND IF I COULD JUST ADD ON THAT
POINT ABOUT THE NEED FOR RURAL
SERVING ATTORNEYS IT IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM IT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGALLY COMMUNITIES LOOKING
CLOSELY AT OUR FOUNDATION.
PROVIDES FELLOWSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW ATTORNEYS
TO PRACTICE IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
SO THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BREAKING THROUGH THE BARRIERS
AND DEFYING THE ODDS BUT ONE BIG
CHALLENGE RELATES TO THE COST OF
REPAIRING YOUR LOANS -- AS A LAW
STUDENT AS A PUBLIC INTEREST
ATTORNEY IT IS A TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGE AND A COLLEAGUE IN THE
AUDIENCE SELENA COPELAND FROM
THE LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN INCREASE THE PIPELINE AS
WELL AS OUR ORGANIZATION.
OF ATTORNEYS WHO WILL SERVE THE
COMMUNITY.
IN THE MORE REMOTE PARTS OF THE
STATE WHERE THE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ISSUE IS EXTREMELY
PROFOUND. ONE THING I JUST WANT
TO TACK ON SINCE I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS IS THAT I
MEAN WE SHOULD THE THE BAR
PROVIDED INFORMATION IN THEIR
MARCH FIFTEENTH REPORT TO THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE DIVERSITY OF
NONPROFIT ATTORNEYS AND I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT.
ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF NONPROFIT
ATTORNEYS ARE WOMEN AND SO IT IS
AN AREA OF THE LAW WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN A GREAT STRIDES -- AND
AT THE SAME TIME.
ONLY ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THOSE
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE WORKING IN
LEGAL AID -- ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
ATTORNEYS OF COLOUR SO WHILE
THERE IS GREAT STRIDES AND I
THINK THERE ARE LESSONS TO LEARN
FROM THE LEGALLY COMMUNITY ABOUT
INCREASING DIVERSITY IN THE
PROFESSION OVERALL.
IN ITS LOOKING AT THE THINGS
THAT I HAD MENTIONED ABOUT
CREATING.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT.
YOU CAN REALLY GET A LOT OF JOB
SATISFACTION -- WHERE YOU CAN
YOU KNOW FOR FILLED THE YOU KNOW
THE PURPOSE THAT YOU CAME TO LAW
SCHOOL IN IN IN THE VERY
BEGINNING? TO TO DO LIKE -- MISS
PROGRESS THE SAID WHEN SHE
TESTIFIED SHE WANTS TO SERVE HER
COMMUNITY SO WE NEED TO LOOK.
LONGITUDE EARLY AT THE PIPELINE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING TO
GETTING ATTORNEYS WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE TO ADDRESS THE
JUSTICE GAP -- BUT LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE SUCCESS OF THE NO
LEGALLY COMMUNITY.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD PLACE TO
START.
SO DO WE HAVE TOO MANY ATTORNEYS
IN CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE LEGALLY
COMMUNITY THERE IS A DRASTIC
NEED FOR MORE ATTORNEYS
ABSOLUTELY THE NUMBER OF
INDIGENT CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE IN
FACT MAJORITY PEOPLE OF COLOR
MORE THAN 60% ACCORDING TO THE
CENSUS.
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN POVERTY IN
NEED A LAWYER ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND SO WE DO YOU
DRASTICALLY NEED MORE ATTORNEYS
OF COLOUR MORE DIVERSE ATTORNEYS
TO BE SERVING AND ITCHING
CALIFORNIANS THE THE STATISTICS
I DON'T HAVE THE THE NUMBER BUT
IT'S THOUSANDS.
TO ONE OF ATTORNEYS.
OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WHO NEED
LAWYERS -- COMPARED TO THE
NUMBER OF ATTORNEYS AVAILABLE TO
SERVE THEM.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT IN THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND IN THE
INNER CITIES IN EVERY.
AREA OF CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE
UNDERSERVED UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS THERE UNDERSERVED
AND DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AT THE SAME RATIO
THAT OTHERS DO.
AND QUALIFIED LAWYERS ARE NEEDED
TO SERVE ALL OF THEM WE DO NOT
HAVE TOO MANY LAWYERS CALIFORNIA.
IF IF I MAY ADD THAT THE AS THIS
COULD AS THIS COMMITTEE HAS HAS
RECOGNIZED.
WE NEED TO GET GET TO PEOPLE OF
COLOR PEOPLE OF UNDER UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS INTO
POSITIONS OF POWER.
NOT JUST INTO THE PROFESSION BUT
INTO POSITIONS OF POWER WITHIN
THE WITHIN THAT PROFESSION SO
THAT LIKE -- PRESIDING JUDGE
BRAZIL WE CAN PROVIDE LEADERSHIP
AND AND BECAUSE THE CHANGE THAT
WE'RE ALL HOPING TO SEE IN THE
PROFESSION.
AND AND THE JUDGE WAS -- YOUR
DESCRIPTION OF HOW YOU'RE
CREATING THAT COMMITTEE FOR
COMMISSIONERS AND ALL IS A CASE
IN POINT NOT THAT ANOTHER.
PRESIDING JUDGE WOULD HAVE DONE
ANYTHING WRONG RIGHT BUT
DIFFERENTLY.
AND THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
WE MET RIGHT IN BECAUSE I'M THE
PRESIDING JUDGE I PICK.
SO.
THEREFORE I CAN INSURE THERE'S
DIVERSITY.
AND I CAN TALK TO THE JUDGES WHO
WERE PART OF THAT AGAIN IT GOES --
TO IMPLICIT BIAS THAT WE ALL
HAVE.
THAT THE COUNCIL IS WORKING ON
WITH IN TERMS OF EDUCATION OF
THE COURT TO DO THAT.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE GET AWAY FROM WELL I
ONLY PICK PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE
ME OR WHO IS WITH WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER WHO LOOK LIKE A JUDGE
NOT SURE WHAT THAT IS.
BUT FOR ME AND I LOOK AT IT
BECAUSE I'M IN A POSITION TO
PICK I CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
I WILL.
RIGHT IN AND THE REASON I ASK A
QUESTION ABOUT TOO MANY
ATTORNEYS WAS I DON'T THINK WE
DO AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT SUPPLY
AND DEMAND IF WE HAD MORE TERMS
IF WE HAD THOSE SIX TO EIGHT
THOUSAND ATTORNEYS.
MINORITY ATTORNEYS WHO.
WERE PRACTICING BUT BECAUSE OF
THAT THE CUT SCORE WE ALSO
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE
RECIPROCITY WITH OTHER STATES.
WE HOLD OURSELVES SORT OF ABOVE
AND AND SEPARATE FROM.
BUT THAT HAS A NARROW THE FIELD.
AND I THINK IT THAT PUSHES THE
THE TERM IS THAT WE HAVE TO WHAT
THOSE HIGH PAYING JOBS IN THE
BIG LAW FIRMS WHICH IS I THINK
PART OF THE PROBLEM FOR STARVING
SOME OF THE RURAL AREAS THAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT.
SO FOR THE BAR IN FOR JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND THERE'S THERE'S
INTERPLAY BETWEEN THE BAR THE
JITTERS CANCELS RECORD HAS SOME
OF THESE AUTHORITIES BUT BUT WHY
NOT LOWER THE CUT SCORE AND WHY
DON'T WE HAVE RECIPROCITY WITH
OTHER STATES [inaudible]
AND SO WE DID PROVIDE YOU KNOW
THE BAR PROVIDED A STUDY DONE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
STANDARD SETTING STUDY I'M WHICH
DID SHOW THAT IT PROVIDED THE
SUPREME COURT WITH THE RANGE
FROM.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT TO ONE FORTY
FOUR AM SHOWING THAT THAT WOULD
SUPPORT MINIMUM COMPETENCY AND
GAVE THOSE OPTIONS TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
AND SO IT'S TIME AT THAT TIME
THERE WERE A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES
GOING ON IS TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE COURT SAID COME BACK AND
TALK TO THEM AGAIN.
MY HOPE WOULD BE THAT THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD HERE
TODAY HAVING JUSTICE LIEU HERE
TODAY WAS.
IMMENSELY VALUABLE -- I BELIEVE
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
COURT TO OPEN THAT DISCUSSION
AGAIN AND TO ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT THE STATE BAR AS
COMPILING DATA.
OTHER.
GROUPS WITHIN THE STATE OF
COMPILING THE DATA WE NEED THE
VENUE FOR THE DISCUSSION.
AND IT IS NOT ONLY HERE IT IS AT
THE CORE SO HOPEFULLY JUSTICE
LOSE OPENING THAT DOOR FORCED TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION MORE
BROADLY.
AND AND AND THAT'S WHY I ASKED
THE THE COURTS AS CHIEF JUSTICE
REMINDS ME THAT SEPARATE
KHOEKHOE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
ABSOLUTE YES WE HAVE
[inaudible]
SOME.
INFLUENCE THERE I WOULD HOPE AS
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT.
I THINK THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH ARE
USED TO WORKING WITH EACH OTHER
BUT NOT ALWAYS BETWEEN.
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH AND THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH AND I AM
HOPING AND HAVE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE CHIEF
JUSTICE THAT THAT WE CAN DO A
BETTER JOB BETWEEN THE BRANCHES
OF COMMUNICATING UNDERSTANDING.
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND
HELPING TO INFLUENCE EACH OTHER
PROCREATE WITHIN THE SEPARATION
OF POWERS.
ON SOME OF THESE DECISION BUT I
CAN'T SAY NO THE CHEAPEST IS
GOING TO LISTEN AND SHE'S VERY
ABSOLUTELY OPERATIVE.
AND TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE BAR GROUPS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SHE HAS A VERY
OPEN MIND.
SO WE GOT THE RIGHT PERSON AT
THE HELM TO MAKE SOMETHING
HAPPEN AND IS IRRITATING AS WE
CAN BE YES I THINK THAT THAT
MAKING SURE THAT THAT WE'RE
BUILDING THOSE OPPORTUNITIES --
FOR THAT TYLER BUT I I JUST
SPOKE MINOR POINT OR NOT A MINOR
POINT BUT AT SMALL MENTION.
JUDGE WOULD YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE SECRET COMMITTEES THE
JUDICIAL SELECTION ADVISORY
COMMITTEES.
WHICH HAVE BEEN A GREAT POINT OF
CONSTERNATION.
AND I THINK.
SAM CRITICISM HAD BEEN LEVEL
THAT -- AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THE SURVEY RECENTLY BUT I THINK
OVER TIME PROBABLY SOME TRUTH TO
IT.
THAT'D BE COMES A BIT OF A GOOD
OLD BOYS CLUB AND I THINK WE'VE
SEEN SOME OF THE RESULTS SINCE
IT'S PART OF HOW.
JUDICIAL DECISIONS WERE MADE
APPOINTMENTS WERE MADE IT'S PART
OF THAT VETTING TO SOME EXTENT.
THAT.
CENTS WERE MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE US SAID AND
I THINK IT POTENTIALLY
PERPETUATED THAT SENSE OF GOOD
OLD BOYS CLUB WHAT WHERE DOES
THAT STAND HOW DOES THAT.
A FACT THEN AGAIN WERE WEIGHING
INTO SOMETHING THAT IS A AN
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE TO DO IS TO
PICK JUDGES THAN AND WAYS THAT
THAT.
THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO BUT
TRANSPARENCY.
CONFIDENCE IN HOW THOSE
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE.
TELL US ABOUT THAT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AND I UNDERSTAND
THIS IS STILL.
AN ISSUE BEING DISCUSSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT CERTAINLY
THE ISSUE OF WHETHER THAT
COMMITTEE THE WHAT THEY CALL THE
CHASE ACTED JUDICIAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE A STANDS
FOR BUT AT APPOINTMENTS
SELECTION IS ELECTION ADVISORY.
I KNOW SOMETHING LIKE THAT --
BUT BUT TO HOW THOSE OPERATING
WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SECRETIVE NOT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT IS THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THAT THERE'S BEEN I'VE
HEARD SOME PEOPLE SAY THAT.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE SECRET ANYMORE
I'VE HEARD SOME PEOPLE SAY THAT
PERHAPS IT'S IT'S STILL A MATTER
DISCUSSION BUT I DO KNOW IT'S
BEING DISCUSSED I ALSO KNOW.
THAT JUSTICE JENKINS IS VERY
VERY CONSCIOUS AS AS THE
GOVERNOR OF MAKING SURE THAT
WHAT EVER -- THE WAY THAT THAT
COMMITTEE OPERATES IT IS GOING
TO BE VERY DIVERSE IT'S GOING TO
BE VERY CONNECTED TO THE VERY
END TO THE VARIOUS -- ADD ADD
THAT ALL OF THE GROUPS THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HERE THAT THEY WILL BE PEOPLE
WHO BE CONSCIOUS OF THESE ISSUES
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO BE PART OF
THE OLD BOYS CLUB.
AND WHO ARE GOING TO BE -- GOING
TO BE VERY AWARE OF EVERYBODY
FROM THIS LEGISLATURE -- TO TO
AT THE JUDICIARY'S CONCERNS IN
THE BARS CONCERNS ABOUT MAKING
FOR THE JUDICIARY IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE STATE SO I
KNOW THAT'S VERY FIRST AND
FOREMOST IN THE MIND OF THE
GOVERNOR.
AND IN THE MIND OF JUSTICE
JENKINS AND I HAVE A FEELING
THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE THAT'S
GOING TO REFLECT.
OF BE REFLECTED IN THE J. SEX IN
THE FUTURE.
GOOD.
THANK YOU HAVE ACTUALLY THE
INTEREST OF TIME I I DO WANT TO
MOVE TO TO PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I
VERY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE.
THERE ARE MORE QUESTIONS YET.
TO RAISE THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUALLY DO THAT BUT I ALSO
WHAT I'VE OFFERED IN FOR FOR YOU
FOR THE PALACE AND FOR ANYBODY
WHO IS WATCHING AND PAYING
ATTENTION.
WE ARE VERY INTERESTED IN IDEAS
AND ACT IN IMPLEMENTATION AND I
SAY THIS BEING A LEGISLATOR
WHERE WE SOMETIMES ALL WE DO IS
TALK.
AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO STOP
TALKING AND TAKE ACTION IN
EMPLOYMENT AND AND WORK BETWEEN
THE BRANCHES AND WITH THE
VARIOUS AUTHORITIES ENSURE THAT
WE'RE DOING THE BEST WE CAN. TO
GET CHANGE ON THE GROUND AND GET
THE LEGAL PROFESSION LOOKING
LIKE CALIFORNIA DOES I THINK
THAT THAT IF NOTHING ELSE THAT
CASES WELL BEEN MADE HERE.
TODAY ABOUT THE NECESSITY OF OF
THE LEGAL PROFESSION LOOKING
LIKE CALIFORNIA.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH OF A BERMAN RECEIVING HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE [inaudible] THREE
PEOPLE.
SIGNED UP. FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON WOMEN ASK YOU TO COME FORWARD
COURTNEY.
GOMEZ SALINA COPELAND AND DEBBIE
MANNING BUT ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT YOU
ARE WELCOME.
TO WE JUST ASK THAT YOU IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR A RECORD WE HAVE
A A MICROPHONE.
YEAH WHAT USE THAT MICROPHONE
[inaudible]
AND IF YOU COULD LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO A COUPLE OF MINUTES
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED SO
THAT WE CAN.
CONSERVE RE UP THE CAR THE THE
COMMITTEE ROOM THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME A MOMENT TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS COURTNEY
GAMMA'S I'M AN IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
IN LAW SCHOOL I HAD TO LEARN TO
TEND TO TRUST MY INTUITION AND
TRUST MYSELF -- I DIDN'T GET
INTO THAT POSITION BY ACCIDENT I
HAD WORKED MY WAY THERE I HAD
EARNED MY POSITION THERE -- AND
I LEARNED MANY LESSONS DURING MY
TIME IN LAW SCHOOL.
TELLING ME TO TRUST MYSELF IN
TRUSTS MY EXPERIENCE -- MOSTLY
WHEN MY SUPPORT A SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY'S WERE WRONG AND I WAS
CORRECT -- IN SECOND YEAR LAW
SCHOOL I HELP TO WIN AN ASYLUM
CASE FOR A WOMAN FROM NIGERIA --
AND IF I HAD TRUSTED MYSELF
EARLY ON IT WOULD HAVE SAVED US
MANY MANY HOURS OF WORK INSTEAD
I TRUSTED THAT MY SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY WAS CORRECT -- AND WE
HAVE ACTUALLY FOUND OUT THAT --
I I I SHOULD HAVE GONE WITH MY
GUT IN THE BEGINNING -- THE
POINT OF I WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT
TODAY IS I GRADUATED IN -- TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT TOOK ME
THREE TIMES TO PASS THE BAR EXAM --
IT WAS DEVASTATING AND CONFUSING
FOR ME TOO I'M BEING TOLD I
WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH TO BE AN
ATTORNEY BUT GOING TO WORK STILL
AND HAVING MY SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY'S ASKING MY OPINION ON
CASES -- WINNING CASES THAT MY
ATTORNEYS HAD HAD THE NIGHT
BEFORE -- AND IT'S STILL NOT
BEING ABLE TO SAY I'M A TURN I'M
AN ATTORNEY I'M GOOD ENOUGH TO
BE AN ATTORNEY -- I WAS THE ONE
ON THE FRONT LINES DOING THE
RESEARCH AND MOST OF THE CASES
THE ATTORNEYS FOR DOING IT.
THE US STRATEGIZING I WAS THE
ONE MAKING THE ARGUMENTS -- BUT
I STILL COULDN'T BECAUSE OF THAT
EXAM I WASN'T ABLE TO STAY RIGHT
AWAY THAT I WAS AN ATTORNEY.
I'M IN GOOD ENOUGH SO -- I ALSO
WASN'T THE ONLY ONE THE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL COMMUNITY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO IS NOT VERY BIG AT
ALL.
AND WITHIN MY CLASS ALONE THERE
WERE ALMOST TEN PEOPLE THAT
DIDN'T PASSED THE BAR EXAM THE
FIRST TIME AROUND THAT WE'RE
GOING INTO IMMIGRATION -- AND
THERE ARE MANY ACTUALLY THAT ARE
STILL TRYING -- BECAUSE OF OUR
STATE POPULATION DIVERSITY IS
HUGELY IMPORTANT I'M NOT ONLY
JUST FOR IMMIGRATION LAW BUT FOR
ALL FIELDS OF LAW BECAUSE ALL OF
MY CLIENTS HAVE OTHER LEGAL
ISSUES IT'S NOT JUST IMMIGRATION
THEY HAVE OTHER NEEDS.
THAT AREN'T BEING TAKEN CARE OF
ARE BEING REPRESENTED BECAUSE
THERE ARE PEOPLE DEDICATED TO
THEIR ISSUES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO HELP THEM.
I AM I PERSONALLY BECAME AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY BECAUSE I
DEDICATED A LOT OF TIME TO
LEARNING -- SPANISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE WHILE OTHER PEOPLE CAME
FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS I
JUST HAD A PERSONAL PASSION.
I'M FOR IT.
AND I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT -- THE BAR EXAM SCORING IT
AND PASS IT RATES ARE
DEVASTATING ON DIVERSITY AND ON
THE I'M THE TYPE OF LAWYERS THAT
ARE ENTERING THE COMMUNITY THE
OTHER THAT ARE REPRESENTING.
THE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED US -- ENDS THE BAR EXAM AS
IT IS -- IS PREVENTING US FROM
BEING ABLE TO SERVE SUCH A HUGE
POPULATION OF OUR OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SELLING A
COUPLE AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
AND I REPRESENT ROUGHLY ONE
HUNDREDS OF LEGALLY NON PROFITS
ARE ADVOCACY IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I'VE TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE FOR ON THE BAR EXAM
CUT SCORES IN THE IMPACT ON
CIVIL LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS.
PARTICULARLY ON THE IMPACT ON
RURAL LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS.
I WILL BE BRIEF -- SO WHAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING IS THAT CIVIL
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS DESPITE --
OUR LOW PAY WE ACTUALLY DID A
MUCH BETTER JOB AT RECRUITING
MORE DIVERSE ATTORNEYS AS
CRISPIN ON BUYING SHARE EARLIER --
WE HAVE MORE WOMEN WE OUT NUMBER
MEN TWO TO ONE IN CIVIL LEGAL
NONPROFITS AND WE HAVE TWICE
NUMBER OF LATINOS -- ATTORNEYS
AS PRIVATE FIRMS -- MORE ASIAN
AMERICAN ATTORNEYS AND NEARLY
TWICE THE NUMBER OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN ATTORNEYS.
ARE DOING SOMETHING RIGHT IN
RECRUITMENT OF OUR ISSUE OF
COURSE IS RETENTION BECAUSE WE
CANNOT COMPETE WITH THE PUBLIC
SECTOR SALARIES -- WHAT WE WHAT
WE DO IS WE RELY REALLY ON A
DIVERSE PIPELINE OF NEW
ATTORNEYS IN ORDER TO REPLACE
THE FOLKS WERE LEAVING TO GO
INTO GOVERNMENT WORK?
OF THE STATE BAR DID OF A
PREVIOUS SURVEY THAT SHOW THAT
ACTUALLY A LARGE NUMBER OF CIVIL
LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS WHEN THEY
LEAVE LEGALLY THEY DON'T GO IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THEY GO INTO
GOVERNMENT WORK.
SO WHAT WE DO IS WE TRAIN WE
SUPPORT AND WE MENTOR BEFORE
THEY MOVE ON AND THE HIGH COULD
SCORE HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE
EFFECT ON CIVIL LEGAL AID NON
PROFITS.
BECAUSE AS A DISPROPORTIONATE
EFFECT ON ATTORNEYSOF COLOUR --
WOULDN'T BECAUSE WOMEN OUTNUMBER
MEN IN BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE
DIVERSE -- ATTORNEYS WITH THAT
MEANS IS THAT OUR PIPELINE IS
HURT AND ULTIMATELY HURTS THE
CLIENTS THAT ARE SERVED BY CIVIL
LEGAL AID NONPROFITS.
THEY DESERVE TO RECEIVE SERVICES
FROM ORGANIZATIONS THAT REFLECT
THE DIVERSITY OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES -- IT JUST VERY
BRIEFLY I KNOW CHRIS HAD
MENTIONED THAT HE WASN'T SURE
THE NUMBER OF LEGALLY CLIENTS
ARE ELIGIBLE CLIENTS TO
ATTORNEYS AND IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ROUGHLY.
SEVEN THOUSAND ELIGIBLE PEOPLE
PERCIVAL LEGAL AID ATTORNEY SO.
AND WE WOULD LOVE TO INCREASE
THE PIPELINE AND HAVE MORE
DIVERSE LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS MORE
DIVERSE ATTORNEYS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- WHETHER IT'S AN IN
SACRAMENTO IN LOS ANGELES OR
LAKE COUNTY WE NEED MORE PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO REPRESENT LOW
INCOME FOLKS.
THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.HELLO MY NAME IS DANNY MANNING
AND I WAS -- FORMALLY CHIEF OF
THE SENATE SERGEANT ARMS HERE AT
THE CAPITOL AND RETIRED AFTER
THIRTY FOUR YEARS HERE -- I'M ON
MY RETIREMENT AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE APPOINTED ME TO THE
STATE BAR.
AND I'M A POOR TRUSTEE WASN'T
SOMETHING I WAS NECESSARILY
LOOKING FOR BUT HERE I AM.
I WHEN I STARTED SCHOOL AT DAVIS
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THERE
WAS WITH THE INTENTION OF GOING
TO LAW SCHOOL.
BUT AS HAS BEEN STATED BY LAW
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HERE EARLIER
THAT'S KIND OF THE IT WAS
DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY THAN IN.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE IN THE
LATE SEVENTIES FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN FEMALE FROM A SINGLE
PARENT HOME. TO WE WANT TO HIRE
MOVE ON TO GRADUATE SCHOOL IT
WAS WITHOUT A FACT THAT STARTED
WORKING IN THE BUILDING WHILE I
WAS STILL IN AN UNDERGRAD.
SO I JUST WANTED TO TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW THAT AS A TRUSTEE --
AS THE PUBLIC MEMBER BECAUSE I'M
NOT A LAWYER.
THAT I REALLY TAKE THAT.
MY POSITION THEY'RE VERY -- I
FEEL IS RELEASED INTO A DUTY TO
REPRESENT.
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND PEOPLE LOW
INCOME BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE I
COME FROM AS A PUBLIC MEMBER
THAT'S WHAT I REPRESENT AND I
THINK THAT I AM I HAVE A VOICE
FOR THAT.
I THINK THE BAR SINCE I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR ONLY A YEAR.
AND I DON'T KNOW ALL THE OTHER
STUFF THAT.
WENT ON FOR YEARS BEFORE.
IS REALLY IN A GOOD PLACE NOW AS
TO WHAT IT IS WE'RE DOING THE
REALLY THINK LIKE THE DATA
COLLECTION AND FINDING OUT WHERE
THE PROBLEMS ARE WHERE THE NEEDS
ARE.
AND THEN ADDRESSING THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT --
THAT WE TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY
INCLUSION OF THE STATE BAR AND
FOR US IN A PARTICULAR WE HAD A
A BIG MEETING ON IT IN ON
JANUARY.
IS THAT WE'RE NOT JUST SAYING
THE WORDS IS NOT JUST FOR SAYING
THE WORD TO SOMETHING THAT'S
BECOME A CORE VALUE FOR US.
AND I FEEL REALLY PROUD TO BE A
PART OF HELPING THAT COME ABOUT
ALONG WITH THE INTENTION WHO MY
COHORT.
IN TERMS OF REALLY PUSHING THE
DIVERSITY INCLUSION FOR THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES SO.
I THOUGHT WHAT TO SAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S NOW
OFFICIALLY AFTERNOON HAVE WE
WILL BE VERY BRIEF MY NAME IS
HEATHER ROSING I HAVE THE
PLEASURE AND HONOR OF SERVING AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE VOLUNTEER
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION -- YOUR
COMMITTEE AND YOURSELF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE WERE INSTRUMENTAL
IN CREATING US THROUGH SB THIRTY
SIX FORMED AS YOU KNOW JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
ARE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
STRONG AS WAS COMMENTED BEFORE.
I'M I DON'T KNOW IF OUR MISSION
STATEMENT IS WELL KNOWN BUT ONE
OF THE COURT TENANTS OF OUR
MISSION STATEMENT IS INCREASING
DIVERSITY IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION.
IT'S IT'S ONE OF OF THREE THINGS
THAT WERE COMMITTED -- TO AND I
WANTED TO JUST COME UP HERE
TODAY TO TELL YOU THAT WE ARE
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF THESE
HEARINGS AND TO PUT OUR
RESOURCES AT THE DISPOSAL OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THIS EFFORT.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU OUR OUR
DEDICATION I'M I'M HERE THIS IS
OUR WONDERFUL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
ON A DOES THE M<c.cyan> WHO JOINS US</c>
FROM THE BROOKINGS INST
INSTITUTE IN DC WE BROUGHT WITH
US OUR DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS ALL BURKE WHICH ARE VICE
CHAIR CHIP WILKINS.
AND OUR VICE PRESIDENT EMILIO
VERNI AND OUR DIRECTOR OF
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS AND
RELATIONS ARBOR.
PARTNERSHIPS INITIATIVES ELLEN
MILLER AND IN FACT ELLEN WAS
SPECIFICALLY HIRED YOU CAME TO
US FROM THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BAR
ASSOCIATION TO HELP US.
INCREASE OUR IMPACT IN THE
DIVERSITY ARENA.
I JUST WANTED TO BRIEFLY COMMENT
THAT WE ARE SO EXCITED THAT
TODAY BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN MANY
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
REGULARLY DIALOGUING WITH.
IN ORDER TO BEGIN -- OUR PROCESS
OF MAKING AN IMPACT IN
INCREASING THE DIVERSITY OF THE
PROFESSION THE STATE BAR LEAH
WILL SEND HAILING CHEN ON THEIR
OTHER COLLEAGUES CHANGE LAWYERS
CRISPER NEARBY AND SELENA
COPELAND FROM OF COURSE THE
LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION.
AND CALAF HOLLY FOOD GA THE
ACCESS COMMISSION KATHERINE
BLAKE MORE AND JUDGE YOU HIGHS
ON THESE ARE ACTIVE DISCUSSIONS
THESE ARE PUTTING PARTNERSHIPS
AND WE ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
TAKING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND BRINGING THEM TO
BEAR. FOR THIS IMPORTANT EFFORT --
WE WELCOME ALL FEEDBACK AND
IDEAS -- I DON'T HAVE TO
OUTLINED THE PROBLEMS ON ANYMORE
THAN HAS BEEN OUTLINED BUT
SOMEONE NEEDS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND WE WANT TO BE A
PART OF MAKING THAT DIFFERENCE --
OWNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE'RE OUT
OF TIME AND WE WERE DOING THIS
TOGETHER SO I WON'T TAKE MORE
TIME.
EXCEPT TO SAY IT AS YOU KNOW --
I AM RELATIVELY NEW TO THIS
STATE -- BUT EAGER AS HEATHER
HAS OUTLINED TO PARTNER WITH THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE US TODAY TO TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM AND IT IS BECOME
PATENTLY APPARENT TO ME.
THAT -- SORT OF THE USUAL
SOLUTIONS AND THE OF THE PAST --
APPROACHES ARE NOT GOING TO BE --
WHAT REALLY RADICALLY MOVES THE
NEEDLE AND WE HAVE TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT I'M SOME DRAMATIC
CHANGES AND SO I'M DEEPLY
GRATEFUL -- IT TO YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND TO YOUR STAFF --
AND TO EVERYONE WHO CONVENE THIS
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STE
JUDGE YVONNE COMPOST AND I'M
FROM THE SAN DIEGO SUPERIOR
COURT -- I PAID MY WAY TO COME
UP TODAY BECAUSE I CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THIS ISSUE BOTH FOR THE
PROFESSION AND FOR THE JUDICIARY.
I'M A GRAY DAVIS APPOINTEE.
AND I'M A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN.
I WOULDN'T BE IN THE LEGAL
POSITION THAT I'M IN AS A JURIST
OR AS HAVING BEEN -- IN BIG LONG
OR AS A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR HAD
IT NOT BEEN.
FOR CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
EDUCATION I'M A PRODUCT OF
WILLARD ELEMENTARY IN ROSEMEAD
CALIFORNIA.
BACK WHEN CALIFORNIA INVESTED IN
ITS PEOPLE BACK WHEN CALIFORNIA
HAD GIFTED AND TALENTED PROGRAMS
THAT TOLD KIDS HEY YOU'RE SMART
YOU CAN BE SOMEBODY.
AND I FEAR THAT IN THE
DESTRUCTION OF OUR STATE WIDE
PUBLIC EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM WE'VE
LOST PEOPLE THAT COULD BE LIKE
ME THAT ARE THAT ARE OTHERWISE
OUT THERE.
I SENT MY KIDS TO LOCAL K.
THROUGH -- SIX PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND THEY HAD AN EXCELLENT TIME
WHEN THE BUDGET CRISIS HIT I HAD
TO SEND THEM TO PRIVATE SCHOOL
SO THEY COULD GET QUALITY
EDUCATIONS.
AND SO.
I THINK THAT THIS IS BEEN
FANTASTIC I APPLAUD YOU I THANK
YOU -- BUT ALSO PLEASE KNOW THAT
AS A JURIST FOR ALMOST SIXTEEN
YEARS.
THERE IS A WIDE SPREAD OF REALLY
BAD LAWYERS OUT THERE.
AND I URGE YOU -- TO LOOK AT THE
TOTALITY OF WHAT WOULD GO INTO
THE CUT SCORE I DON'T KNOW I'M
NOT SOLD I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING
AGAINST IT SO I JUST ASK THAT
YOU HAVE A FULLY INFORMED.
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE PASSING
THE BAR DOES NOT MAKE YOU A
COMPETENT LAWYER AND I'VE SEEN
PLENTY OF INCOMPETENT LAWYERS.
AND I WORRY ABOUT THE PEOPLE THE
STATE BEING SUBJECT SUBJECTED TO
MORE INCOMPETENT LAWYERING --
AND SO WITH THAT I THINK YOU AND
I'LL SEND AN ADDITIONAL WRITTEN
COMMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SOPHIA
CREEL AND THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STANFORD LAW GRADUATE.
AND I AM A JUDICIAL LAW CLERK AT
THE FEDERAL COURT -- I WANTED TO
SPEAK BECAUSE I'M A PRODUCT.
OF DIVERSITY PIPELINE NAY AND
JUSTICE I GREW UP IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
I WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL THAT HAD
ABOUT A 30% DROP OUT RATE.
FROM STANFORD LAW GRAD AND I'M A
LAW CLERK AT THE FEDERAL COURT
THE ONLY LATINO LOCKER THERE.
ON I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT I
APPLIED THAT.
YOU'RE HAVING THESE DISCUSSIONS
BY ONE ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE BULL.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT PIPELINE INITIATIVE.
THERE WERE TWO PROGRAMS THAT HAD
ENORMOUS AFFECT MY ABILITY TO GO
TO LAW SCHOOL.
BOTH OF THEM HAPPENED WHEN I WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THE FIRST WAS PARTICIPATION IN
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
FOUNDATIONS MOCK TRIAL PROGRAM.
IT'S ACTIVE IN ALL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES I HIGHLY RECOMMEND YOU
LOOK INTO HOW YOU CAN PARTNER
WITH THEM OR HOW YOU CAN PARTNER
WITH OTHER INITIATIVES.
I SAY THAT THAT HAD THE BIGGEST
IMPACT BECAUSE NOT ONLY DID A
GETTING ON A PATH TO SING MYSELF
AS A LAWYER MY PATH TO LAW
SCHOOL.
THEY GOT ME TO A PATH OF COLLEGE
READINESS THAT I WOULD NOT HAVE
HAD IN MY HIGH SCHOOL THEY DID
NOT HAVE.
ACADEMIC PROGRAMMING THAT WAS
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS.
THE SECOND WAS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'D EVER MADE AWARE.
WAS THROUGH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS PROGRAM THE MOCK TRIAL
PROGRAM.
AND THROUGH THEIR PROGRAM WITH
UCLA HAVING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
GO TO UCLA TO SEE THEMSELVES IN
PRE Là PROGRAMMING IT WAS THE
FIRST TIME I HAD EVER MET A
LAWYER.
THERE I LOOK BACK AT MY
EXPERIENCES AND I TELL PEOPLE
THAT I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
PURPOSE.
IN LAW SCHOOL I WAS ABLE TO HELP --
COCHAIR A CASE WHERE WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING OUR CLIENT
ASYLUM.
I SERVED WOMEN AND CHILDREN IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION AND ROLL
TEXAS.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO MY
COMMUNITY AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
AND CONTINUE TO SERVE.
I STOOD UP IN LAW SCHOOL IN OVER
TWENTY STATE CASES.
I'M READY TO BE A LITIGATOR.
I FIND OUT FRIDAY FIVE PASSED
FOR THE FINGERS CROSSED.
BUT BUT I WANTED TO HAVE MY
VOICE HEARD BECAUSE I I WANT TO
IMPLORE YOU WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE
AND WHEN I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO
HAVE.
MENTORS EXTEND A HAND TO
PROGRAMS TELL ME YOU CAN GO TO
LAW SCHOOL EVEN WHEN I COULDN'T
SEE COLLEGE ON THE HORIZON.
THAT MADE A DIFFERENCE.
IT'S EASY TO GLANCE OVER THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE PIPELINE
PROGRAMMING AND SAY.
HOW MUCH DIFFERENCE CAN REALLY
BE MADE I'M TELLING YOU?
AS A STAND FOR LAW GRADUATE.
I CREDIT THOSE PROGRAMS FOR
PUTTING ME ON THE SPOT.
THE OTHER ISSUE I WANTED TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION IS
EMPOWERING OTHERS WHO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF PURPOSE LIKE ME. TO
ACTUALLY SIR.
I KNOW THAT.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO BALANCE
DIFFERENT THINGS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS -- WITH WHEN IT COMES
TO THE BAR EXAM SCORING.
BUT WHEN I THINK ABOUT MY
COMMUNITY.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT PASSIONATE
LAWYERS WHO WANT TO HELP THEM.
I'M WORRIED THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE WERE READY TO GO
DOWN AND SERVE THOSE RURAL
COMMUNITIES SO BE BOLTS.
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS BESIDES THE
CUT SCORE.
WHICH I'M NOT SAYING IT'S A GOOD
OR BAD IDEA.
THAT CAN BE EMPLOYED FOR EXAMPLE
IF YOU'VE TAKEN THE CALIFORNIA
BAR YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT SUBJECTS AS
WELL AS THE ANTI THAT YOU NEED
TO BE PREPARED.
FOR WHY NOT GIVE US SIX ESSAYS
ONLY FIVE OR SCORED.
AND GIVE THE CHOICE OF WHICH
FIVE TO TAKE.
WHY NOT EXCEPT IN THESE SCORES
THAT ARE PASSING FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS?
AND FOR FOLKS WHO CANNOT AFFORD
TO PAY OVER THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EVERY TIME YOU TAKE
A TEST.
THAT'S THREE MONTHS.
NOT WORKING PLUS THE BAR EXAM
FEES.
WHY DON'T YOU HONOR IF THEY HAD
A PASSING IN THE SCORE FROM A
PREVIOUS TEST?
AND HAVE THEM SIT.
ESSENTIALLY FOR THE ATTORNEYS
EXAM THAT WOULD TEST THE
EIGHTEEN SUBJECTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AGAIN PLEASE BE ABLE AS YOU LOOK
AT PIPELINE PROGRAMS AND AS YOU
LOOK AT WAYS. TO EMPOWER THOSE
WHO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
PURPOSE TO ACTUALLY GO INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU PASSED THE BAR THEY
WERE GOING TO PUT YOU IN CHARGE?
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARCUS
REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC AND INTEREST LAW.
STEVE HI AL AB SUPPORTS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
THE BAR EXAM REFORM AND THE
TRANSPARENCY RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING THE APPOINTMENTS TO
THE JUDICIARY WE BELIEVE THAT
POLICYMAKERS ARE IN PARTICULAR --
NEED OF DATA GATHERING SO THAT
WE CAN FURTHER UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF CALIFORNIA'S EXTREMELY
HIGH CUT SCORE ON NOT ONLY THE
DIVERSITY OF THE LEGAL
PROFESSION BUT ALSO THE JUSTICE
GAP IN GENERAL WE ENCOURAGE
ALLEGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT SUCH A STUDY.
AND DATA GATHERING THAT WOULD
BOLSTER THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU ARE CONSIDERING TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING.
AND THIS IS.
CLEARLY SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA BE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THERE'S A
ROLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE THERE'S
A ROLE FOR THE SUPREME COURT.
ROLE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION HERE
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF WORKING TOGETHER
AND MAKING SURE WE'RE
ESTABLISHING APPROPRIATE
STANDARDS.
THE BAR EXAM DOES NOT ASSURE
COMPETENT ATTORNEYS AND THE
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
VERY CLEAR.
BUT THAT'S THE ROLE OF THE STATE
BAR TO ASSURE COP INTERNEES THE
ROLE THE STATE BAR'S PUBLIC
PROTECTION [inaudible]
AND THE BAR EXAM IS MERELY AN
INDICATION OF MINIMUM STANDARDS
FOR BEING ABLE TO PRACTICE LAW.
BUT ETHICAL CONSIDERATIONS
COMPENSATE CONSIDERATIONS THOSE
CERTAINLY DEVELOP OVER TIME I
THINK THE HISTORY OF THE
PRACTICE.
SHOWS AND THOSE ARE VERY
CRITICAL COMPONENTS THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE SERIOUSLY WITH RESPECT
OF PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
ENSURING.
THAT.
CONSUMERS HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPETENCY INNARDS.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK BACK
INTO THE EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN TAKING.
SERIOUSLY INVESTING IN
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION LOOKING AT
THE EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS
ENSURING THAT ALL KIDS HAVE
ACCESS. TO QUALITY EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES AND HIGHER
EDUCATION SHOULD THEY SO DESIRE
AND THAT I'M HOPING WILL INCLUDE.
THE LEGAL PROFESSION AS ONE OF
THOSE PATHWAYS SO WE CLEARLY
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
I APPRECIATE THE PANELISTS FOR
BEING WILLING TO COME FORWARD
AND GIVE US THE BENEFIT OF YOUR
WISDOM.
I THINK WE HAVE RAISED A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS THAT STILL HAVE YET
TO BE ANSWERED AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION.
THIS IS SOMETHING I KNOW THAT A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE ALSO
VERY INTERESTED IN SO THEIR LACK
OF PRESENCE ON THE DISS NOT
INDICATION OF LACK OF INTEREST.
BUT MERELY THIS TIME OF YEAR I
SUPPOSE SO I THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE.
WE'RE GONNA BECAUSE DATE ON THIS
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS AND FINDING A REAL
SOLUTIONS TO DIVERSITY ON THE
BAR.
AND WITH THAT THIS COMMITTEE
THIS.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS
ADJOURNED